foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
wow
foreign
[Music]
will step into the Play Zone it's going
to be a razor sharp battle savvy's
impeccable calculation against hikaru's
unbreakable resistance this is the Grand
Final welcome to the adjustable Masters
[Music]
how on Earth has he save this position
well Magnus just widening in his eyes
they're shocked by this last decision he
is showing no fear whatsoever
man we got kids watching this is
Checkmate incoming 19 goes to A6 and
there are no checks on the boys
Thorn into the white side holding on
here for dear life
you see the bar go back to equal oh my
gosh it is beautiful tactile awareness
it's the day that we've all been waiting
for the Grand Final is here we are so
pumped to see two incredible Fighters
bring in their best check today and so
that you can sit back and enjoy the show
we will be bringing exclusive insights
in the studio as always David Howell
we're here and Grandmaster Robert Hess
we've got a big matchup coming up on day
three Fabi knocked down Hikaru Nakamura
to the losers bracket day four Hikaru
eliminated the world champion David is
there a big favorite today I'm not gonna
choose size here Tanya but I will say
Hikaru Nakamura is coming into this
match on a high after that dramatic
Victory yesterday against Magnus Carson
momentum is on his side yeah he's got to
be feeling very confident today James
Hikaru has been your pick from the very
start what will it take to get by today
of course the big fellow swinging he's
just gonna have to relax him I literally
don't care right and then he's gonna
have to sit there and do what he does
right he's on the momentum swing and
hopefully the momentum ship Works in his
favor
well he will be playing one of the best
players on the planet it is a fight
against Fabiano caruana Robert how
difficult is it for Hikaru
psychologically to know that he has to
beat Fabi twice today
revenge is a dish best served cold
unfortunate is a cold-blooded calculator
I don't think that Fabiano caruana is
gonna make much of the win over Magus
Carlson yesterday great for a car
Nakamura but Fabiano he took down the
car two days ago why not again today
it's gonna be a lot of fun the story
could have been very different Magnus
Carlsen was so close to taking that
Armageddon but kaisa had different plans
he is thinking currently in the position
he's burnt the car and he doesn't he
doesn't
oh trick from levonne aronian he throws
in a check if this Knight is captured by
the white Bishop Black's Rook is
actually on the third right gonna come
and take a pawn with check attacking
multiple pieces look how well
coordinated they are the white knight
protects the white Bishop the white king
is marching either side forward now the
white Pawn in the center just doing a
fantastic job of black is stuck Magnus
taking the first game in his mini-match
against Levon
yeah and the bishop still isn't
attacking that King Side Pawn anywhere
and you've got to find a way and he says
I'm gonna get my king to safety Levon
immediately grabs and it's a big blunder
because you lose the G3 pawn and you
lose the game yeah that's the wrap
levana Ronin he looks at his position
it's hopeless the game is over pick
a very exciting draws this looks like a
massacre it should end in a chat meeting
attack
he goes for it Robert you got it he
finds it in Hikaru immediately hates the
fact that Magnus found this move
really nice defense he's actually trying
to slide his King back the other way and
uh the black rook and the black queen
are actually lined up so watch out for a
counter attack against the white king
later it's all about the clock now it's
a winning position for white we think
always a better position but is it
enough on the clock
oh and what's happened there what
happened we see a reaction
oh no Magnus Mouse slipped blundering
into that Queen
what an end
wow it was a dramatic day of Chester in
the losers final we started with eight
players and this is how far we've gone
into the grand of final Magnus ended his
run in the chessable masters with a
mouse slip David how heartbreaking was
that that would have been devastating
for Magnus Carlson Not only was he
knocked out of the chessable Masters but
that was his final game his final move
as a reigning classical world champion
heartbreaking stuff and you can see how
much it meant to him that game
feels and
band in this tournament Robert he's been
knocked out he's been defeated twice how
brutal is this format uh it's the Forma
and the field the second event was even
stronger than the first vladislav
artemiev was Magnus Carlson's first
round opponent and artemia beat him so
I'm not surprised by the results from
the very starters I said we would not
have a Magnus Hikaru showdown in the
Grand Final we're not seeing that today
yeah Magnus had a definitely a great run
obviously me being world champion doing
what he does right but I mean here you
got a tough competition or timia took
him down right so he let him let you
know hey we all are swinging here we all
can fight even Nakamura loss right so
it's very tough in his format here
obviously nakamura's got to bring it to
Fabi today yeah
that's gonna be the big one it is all
eyes on Hikaru Nakamura taking on
Fabiano caruana look at that achievement
list of course we could bring up 20 more
slides and still not fit everything that
Hikaru has achieved but this time it
will be a big battle we see there five
times U.S Champion he did win the speed
test championship against Fabi as well
what a match that was what is it James
that makes him such a beast in these
formats he plays so much chess he
remembered ICC days internet chess club
right he was Smallville who remembers
that right the guy's back home
Smallville guys Superman okay they've
been playing so much chess before chess
was internet chess you know what I mean
so so many games so much experience like
that the guy is an absolute beast and
he's going to try to show that today and
hopefully he'll be probably twice if not
of course Bobby just gonna take it he's
playing very precise chess this time and
that's the thing it's just part of his
daily routine winning Hikaru he might
say he's not a chess professional but
day by day he's winning hundreds of
games so this is just normal for him and
you can tell he's just in the zone all
the time he's such a monster uh when
he's in good form Hikaru and he cares
right that's the thing is sometimes his
shirt says otherwise but he does he puts
his all into every game he plays he may
not be preparing as much but that's been
useful for him he's the world champion
of a game that doesn't start like
regular chess Fisher random he won that
world title he is playing some great
chess yeah and David you mentioned that
hikaru's made it a bit of a habit of
winning but Fabiano caruana he has been
Unstoppable in this event so far he's
undefeated yeah not just in this event
this year in Rapid chess he's just upped
his game and he continues to do so there
we see he did win division two of the
air things Masters a couple of months
ago and uh yeah he's a man in form he's
already beaten Hikaru once he will
believe that he can do it again he's so
close now
guys think about look let me actually
look pull this up my phone but you know
my screensaver actually is Fabiano do
you all know this right but actually on
it it's a quote from property says chess
players have very complex Styles there
are stereotypes which is natural but
most top players are very Universal
there are slight stylistic differences
but those don't manifest so clearly in
games because mainly often the main tool
is the calculation they call
a calculator bro
right so of course I'm always a fan of
Fabi because of that calculation and
what he brings up yeah and we see
Fabiano on screen he's just trying to
figure out his settings here but
whatever he's been doing has been
working and they say save your best for
Laughs if his best is to come today that
is a scary proposition for a car
Nakamura because
Fabiano's play has been stellar and if
he has his best remaining today good
luck to you yeah
well the two have played each other a
bunch of times we've seen this match up
it's a classic in the Chess World most
recently just two days ago and it all
ended very abruptly
he refuses repetition he says game on
and is taking big risk here but what's
happening if you just Shuffle across
look you're pinned along the a file and
you're pinned on this diagonal oh wait
you're right about that whoa
brilliant because the pawn A4 has
stranded it's gone too far Fabiano
cannot lose this game he's a pull-up 10
seconds dude yeah two
but a horrible Bond structure yeah but
it's all about the white d-pawn if he
kicks the Central Pawn alive he might
oh you said they don't blunder shot me
into one and then a car immediately does
you commentator's curse
is going to cost Hikaru the whole match
[Music]
it's a rematch between these two last
time they played in the winners final
Fabiano caruana wrapped up that match in
just three games David is Revenge extra
motivation for Hikaru today it certainly
is and also he is in the flow Fabiano
had a day off yesterday maybe he lost a
bit of momentum so uh Hikaru knows this
is his chance to strike but he of course
as mentioned he needs to do it twice
today and that's the difficult part
beating Fabi once is uh almost
impossible beating him twice that is a
Herculean task of course like the
Newton's law right you know in motion it
stays in motion that momentum as we
mentioned here he's in the momentum
swinging right he's swinging and of
course hey Bobby might have slowed down
a little bit but he also didn't have
that break and that mental Clarity can
definitely help Fabi today just having a
day off relax watch everything prepare
correctly and maybe I can swing it at
the Nakamura today you know a lot of
these top players they say I need a
break this is such grueling chess but it
actually is helpful for them to play
every single day and for Fabiano we know
he was watching the chess but playing's
a whole another story story so for five
minute carwana you better hope that he's
ready to play when the clock starts
ticking yeah well it's such a big toss
Carolina twice
I'm into our mind who are capable of
pulling something like that and I I
would think to come to mind Hikaru is
one of them would you agree I definitely
agree because Hikaru Nakamura he is
somebody who doesn't matter who he plays
he is going to be that resilient
tenacious Defender and he does not go
down without a fight so I feel like for
Fabiano he needs to be careful his clock
management that is something that hikara
does better than anybody is keeping a
lead on the clock and even in the
waiting seconds he plays great bullet
chess yeah it will come down to those
critical seconds when there's a mess on
the board and that is going to happen
there will be chaos there will be mess
the players with those extra seconds on
the clock that could be a very decisive
it's an exciting day of Chess coming up
and we are also so excited to bring you
the trophy at the end of the day chess
Champs is providing the official nft
trophies for the Champions Chester each
trophy is unique and created by a
digital artist this one it is by Daniel
Salzburg and as always there will be two
trophies one will be given to the winner
of the chessable Masters while one will
be put on auction for the fans on chess
charm champs.io that is trashchamps.io
the owner of the trophies will be
invited to see the Stars play in person
at the season of finals how exciting is
that James that is exciting I mean wow
you get like a piece of art here I mean
you get like a look at look how cool
this looks you know what I mean like wow
I'm still looking at it it just it's um
you can see the little spaceships in the
back there like you got the trophy there
this is really cool you could stare at
this for like five to ten minutes and
still like oh look at that I didn't even
see that I looked at it for 10 minutes
right it's a very nice piece of art here
and of course the crowd gets to be a
part of it as well that's gonna be a lot
of fun that is the big aim the golden
ticket today to the winner is to the
finals of the Champions chess tour
season this is the format for today's
Grand Final Hikaru Nakamura and Fabiano
kaiwana will first fight it out in a
best of four mini-match if Fabi wins he
wins the tournament but in case Hikaru
wins the first match then we will have
another grand final reset which will be
a best of two rapid game with 15 minutes
and a three second increment in that one
as well in case any of the matches are
tied we will have Armageddon to decide
and The Winner Takes It All will win The
chassisable Masters and punch his ticket
into the Grand Final Robert there is a
lot at stake there certainly is I mean
you know these players they want to win
here now mark their stamp toward the
playoffs the end of the year win thirty
thousand dollars and what more is there
well a rivalry these two players they
just want to say I beat the other yeah
yeah there is a lot of Glory at stake as
well and we see Hikaru Nakamura looking
very chill but this time he doesn't have
the literally don't care t-shirt on
yeah what does the T-shirt say that I
knocked out a pro wow boasting about his
win over Magnus Carlson yesterday
clearly Hikari of course yeah I knocked
out a pro I mean he put his hands on him
there as you can see wow and he did his
thing that's a nice shirt I like like
this let me see where I can get there
that's very good I have to give them a
call get that shirt from him yeah
I'm struggling with the shoulder
shouldering that's gonna bother him
today Robert well Mouse speed is
essential here in the chest of Masters
but 5.0 he showed Stellar mouthpie when
it came down to the wire in game one but
you could see him nursing that shoulder
we typically don't talk injuries in
chess but it seems to be bothering him
quite sincerely because it's the second
time in a row we've seen him with a
heating pack on his shoulder wow that
clocks are ticking we are about to have
the first moves very very soon what are
we expecting with white from Fabi E4
I'm saying E4 all day baby you already
know come on now yep uh when these two
play each other they don't alter their
styles that much
that's how you feel Bobby that's how you
feel bro is that a surprise on move one
how big of a shocker is this for Hikaru
he was definitely expecting one E4 as
well yeah but I think it's a smart
decision by Fabiano caruana you don't
want to have a Target on your back you
don't want your points to be able to
prepare deeply for you every single time
so playing a queen C2 nimzo which is
what we're seeing here it's a good idea
white already has secured the pair of
Bishops and this Intermezzo buy hikards
kicking the queen away this is all
standard opening fare neither side has
played a novelty I like the choice from
Fabiano but I like the reaction from
Hikaru yeah I will say that Hikaru
nakamur is very predictable in this uh
in this variation in the Quincy 2 nimzo
he sticks to his repertoire never uh
kind of moves it up there and uh Fabi he
would have been studying this exact
position before had you see the speed of
the two players at the silly stage black
is so well mobilized look at all the
black's pieces centralized black is
castled Fabby still needs to catch up a
bit but long term white is doing great
extra Central Pawn two versus one and
the E and D files there and the bishop
power we talk about it a lot but it can
be vital later in the game so Fabi just
needs to survive he needs to get his
King to safety and the middle game will
be promising for white if he is given
time but uh Hikaru of course will have
something to say about that will have
studied this position as well
previously uh prior to the match against
1d4 the Queen spawn opening the ninja
response is an aggressive line to choose
is Hikaru making his intentions very
clear that he wants to go all out from
game one itself I don't think he's
really going out for a win in this game
but he doesn't want to be ground down by
Fabiano Fabiano when he gets a strangle
hold on the position he does not let
loose so what Hikaru is doing is he is
trying to claim some space for himself
you notice that black is safely castled
black has all three minor pieces
developed a rook in the center white
lacks development that Knight next to
the king hasn't moved the King has not
castled but what white does have is the
pair of Bishops a very healthy Pawn
structure two Pawns in the center
compared to just one Pawn the center for
black so the Dynamics are such that
black is ahead in terms of activity but
in the long run white should have the
advantage if he can stabilize yeah James
we've been talking about that King side
night Fabi having a think where do you
see that coming out which Square would
you move it to yeah what concerns me
right here is actually fabi's thinking
already and in fact act like uh this is
why maybe you just stick to your guns
right of course he usually doesn't play
as much D4 like this I mean he has and
he's even played C4 and other things but
playing this way I mean usually Fabi is
more a calculator he likes more you know
sticking it to you really just being not
aggressive but semi-aggressive I would
say not Super Hyper aggressive but
definitely aggressive enough and very
well prepared and you know a prepared
Fabi is a very scary Fabi and it doesn't
seem like he's very prepared here right
now as he's thinking he's already down
time here need to figure out obviously
where to move this Knight of course you
do have a grip on the E5 Square so maybe
Knight to F3 is what I like to play here
and then at some point maybe put a
knight on E5 and try to get rid of the
Knight on C6 maybe put some pressure on
the C7 Pawn I also of course I like to
play G4 so I do want to play G4 at some
point but so I am thinking about 92 this
is probably what he's thinking about as
well don't want to go 92 don't want to
go Knight F3 the Knight on E2 actually I
need to figure out where I'm going from
there do I go to G3 like what do I do so
it is definitely something to think
about here but I think Bobby definitely
should have had this um in his
repertoire already yeah and he makes a
decision it was definitely going to be a
night move there were threats actually
in the air and he brings it to F3 so the
first idea you mentioned there Jameson
may be hopping in to the center a bit
later on I actually prefer keeping that
square free for important the other
option bring the Knight to E2 would have
given you the option of kicking away
Black's Knight but uh yeah it's a matter
of taste here and fabi's happy to play
the long game next move he is going to
try and castle and we will see the game
take a slower Pace but I would take
white here unless Hikaru has something
immediately I would say I don't really
see any immediate plans for black that's
the issue unless you start throwing
pawns towards the white pieces opening
up maybe the black king but that comes
with a risk attached as well so I do
expect Hikaru to take a pause himself
just like Fabi did just that and try to
work out what to do next and I know just
saying that to make James happy black
might throw some king-size pods for it
that actually is a standard plan in this
position and one of The Oddities in the
position is that black queen side note
it's in front of a pawn usually we went
our nights behind ponds because ponds
will stare into the center if you can
imagine that C7 Pawn up two squares it
would immediately put pressure on the
White Center the D4 square but as it
sits on C6 the dst4 pawn is now
protected the bishop on F4 staring
through that Knight and that Knight
can't really move very easily you would
drop a pawn there but as David said
perhaps it's time to throw kingside
pawns forward with G5 Hikaru says no but
it is an option available to him yeah
watch out for this Pawn push happening
later and here I don't think you can be
greedy if you're Fabiano caruana we
talked about this Pawn but if you go and
take it you will live to regret this
immediately the black black Rook just
slides across hitting the bishop and
when the bishop moves out of the way
there will be a discovered attack for
example Knight takes pawn and The Rook
unleashes against the White Queen so
don't be greedy here Fabiano I do expect
him to Simply Castle kingside still a
very stable position but watch out for
those black porn pushes later on
and we saw in the chat earlier that we
were that it was pointed out that it is
a huge Advantage for Fabi today as he
needs to win only one of the two matches
but the feeling is that if if Hikaru
does take that first set the momentum
shifts completely for the best of two
how important is it for Fabi to actually
try and close this match in the first
set well I would say in general in terms
of momentum it depends how you lose a
match if you just get crushed you may
feel dejected but if it's a really tight
match and you blunder like a magazine
yesterday with a mouse slip so I'm just
like okay this happens we reset the
second match if there is a reset there's
only two games yeah so you don't have to
worry about a whole nother four game
match we were feeling out of it it just
would be two extra games with potential
armor again so I feel like that's a long
ways away from now Fabiano he's not
thinking about that he's really just
taking this move by move and it's
important for Hikaru as well not to
focus on that and just take it one match
at a time one game at a time as well and
we see right now he's the one who's got
on in a bit of a tank James how
seriously is he considering the idea of
G5 absolutely in fact this is a very
common in fact you will see it in the
which variation is this it's like the
queen C2 Knight C3 E4 classical
variation is what they call it in the
classical variations of the nimso which
of course you can actually get from said
NASA torment from um sorry I gangulies
part two he actually covers it in depth
with these G5 lines you even seen it
with Jeffrey Zhong Wesley so has played
it too as well with the black side of
this playing this G5 move it looks
absolutely crazy but it is part of it
because you are playing aggressive you
put the King on h8 you play G4 at some
point and that's very strong stuff now
of course engine doesn't like it now
there must be some tactics here maybe
like I don't know Bishop G5 or Knight G5
Knight G5 and after Knight G5 Bishop F5
so right now it doesn't work but G5
definitely is something to consider at
some point just uh right now the timing
is not correct so maybe you have to prep
it with maybe an H6 to play G5
um from there but he is definitely in
the think tank here I wonder what else
wants to play here David I'm not sure
I've actually James I think it's a
really difficult moment for Hikaru it's
all about this porn as well at some
point Fabi might get greedy and be able
to take this so we'll let Karu have to
take a time out and move his Rook it's
not the type of move you want to play
it's not a happy move uh for his pieces
but sometimes you need to do what is
necessary and at least that would Shore
up his defenses and then he could switch
his Focus uh his Focus to uh James's
planner of throwing pawns towards the
white pieces towards the white king but
uh yeah Hikaru now thinking deeply and
Robert and James you're from the US is
there a hierarchy do you think in terms
of these uh super Grand Masters in the
US now you have so many of these
world-class players
all right I guess I have to be the one
to bite this bullet
that a hierarchy is not the right word
for it because they're so close in terms
of rating that you see the players a
Hikaru Nakamura five minute karwana
Lavon aronian who we just saw yesterday
here in the chesso Masters Wesley so he
got eliminated the day before all these
players along with lenier Dominguez you
have Sam Shanklin uh former U.S Champion
there is so much respect amongst that
crowd but when it comes time down to it
and they're playing against each other
there is a rivalry sometimes it's
healthy probably not always so healthy
because you're just trying to take your
opponent's head off I think between
these two there is a ton of mutual
respect in fact they get along quite
well uh they've you know they don't work
together in terms of sharing chess ideas
because they are mostly opponents but
Knight D6 I think Fabiano you know he's
happy about that move seems a little
friendly as the eval bar suggests yeah
so you call them Frenemies these two
friendly rivalry and uh okay yeah the
evaluation part does react to this night
Retreat and that does hint to me that it
must be something concrete because it is
a very kind of slow type of position if
it's just about maneuvering White having
a small space Advantage then the
evaluation bar might not react so much
but okay Fabi just shuffles this Rook
across I thought maybe he could go Pawn
hunting uh trade off some pieces that
Fabi says no I'm not gonna kind of
engage in any complications here I'm
just going to improve my pieces and
suddenly actually I don't like the
placement of hikaru's knights those two
black knights are completely Frozen if
they ever move some pawns might drop
behind uh so nice move by Fabi there and
Hikaru really struggling to come up with
a productive plan look at hikaru's face
he's not happy at all with his position
I've got to say
yeah calculating that yeah he's really
surprised right now and Roxy one is not
the kind of move that will take that
you've got to have that expression for
but something Hikaru doesn't like about
his position and potentially could that
be the fact that Fabi can also jump into
the Central Square with his own Knight
we'll see we see that the bishop pair
Advantage has been neutralized is now
Fabi wanting to come over to the
opponent's side bring that Knight to
that Central E5 Square yeah maybe a
threat on the boat Tanya if black just
takes a timeout plays a very logical
type of move we mentioned this earlier
uh just either supporting a pawn push or
taking control of some key squares then
the Knight can potentially jump in and I
think the reason you're highlighting
this Tanya is because there's a threat
you want to take this Knight win a pawn
or at least wreck black structure and
black of course cannot capture in the
center because of this double attack
costs material and okay Hikaru defends
against that Potential Threat of the
night jumping into E5 by plonking his
own Knight in the white half and okay
eyeing up this Pawn potentially and the
whole all idea is white cannot kick you
yet or maybe you can but at least it
would come at the cost of this Rooks
Pawn really complicated stuff it looks
like the Knight is trapped but maybe
nowhere to catch it that's weird because
I have to Rook a while I was like can't
you just trap this but then he plays
like Queen E7 and then it just stares at
you all crazy through the camera like I
got a pawn and like play A6 and Knight
B5 like weirdly enough you can't trap
this night yeah that's such a crazy idea
but yeah Knight C4 is such a strong move
and obviously Mika was an absolutely
strong player here so it's a really
annoying move right he crossed into the
halves of the board as we talked about
before Robert talks about this too as
well with halves of the board Knight to
C4 black is uh Black's Knight is very
very annoying on C4s and whites half of
the board here it's attacking B2 and I'm
going to take it and go right back home
like nothing happened if you don't do
anything about this so you may have to
make a defensive move here like Rick to
C2 not too bad but Rick to C2 is
actually something maybe double the
Rooks from here but it's kind of
annoying that you have to respond to
this right now yeah and uh Robert would
you ever consider even sacrificing
getting rid of this Knight do you think
white does have to take your time out to
me maybe play a defensive passive move
to defend B2 yeah it's one of these
moments where I want to feel inspired
and sacrificed but I know I shouldn't I
think that you can actually bring your
knight back from F3 to D2 offer a trade
of knights because you do not want to
take this Pawn on B2 just yet why not
Roy Hikaru I'm gonna move my queen say
to B5 for example and I'm gonna hit all
your pawns it doesn't matter which
Square there David you you lead the way
hitting the Knight hitting all the Pawns
in Black's position and they're going to
fall so I think that for uh Fabiano he
could try to kick that Knight out of
there James made a good point that
Knight is frustrating to deal with so
maybe we're treating your night and
trying to trade off or I'm wondering now
if your knight takes B2 is a threat can
white steal the C7 Pawn the answer is oh
there it is true he takes it and the
whole idea now is if the Knight does
grab this Pawn as Robert points out very
strong reply Queen to B5 hitting
everything hitting the knights hitting
the pawn and another very important
point on B7 so uh and nice move that by
Fabiana caruana and the evaluation bar
does agree with his decision looking
good for white unless Hikaru comes up
with something a bit magical here uh
what does he have in store why he's not
blitzing out his reply which is a bit
strange because when you just give up a
pawn like that you would think that
Hikaru has something up his sleeves you
guys pointed out that the B2 Pawn can't
be picked out I'm struggling to find an
idea does he just simply want to slide
in with the rook and start targeting
that Bishop yeah the bishop will do a
smash and grab though it's taken upon
and it will just run away Retreat to
safety and any time that black knight
goes to capture White's pawns the White
Queen breaks three and starts attacking
things so I'm taking white here every
time I think kavi's had a great opening
definitely something and then uh the
coral Mist here um as he's uh just kind
of looking here I'm done upon races he's
thinking puts his to the side here hmm
what do I do here right I am down upon I
think he just missed the idea of Queen
to B5 and I see Force definitely was a
nice move but after Knight takes B2 you
do have this queen B5 and it's very very
annoying I'm gonna take a B7 Pawn C6
would be hanging the Rooks on the file
too as well right uh you have two
Knights versus the bishop here the
bishop is you know grab and go like a
grab-and-go bag at the grocery store
here I'm gonna grab this pawn and I'm
just gonna go back home and really just
tell you to prove that you um you're
down to pawns you're gonna figure this
out and you need to figure out fast
right now from hickover you know I like
that uh in the twitch chat Hikaru
calculating 100 lines right now and uh
you mentioned 100 lines yeah Hikaru is
pretty much having to pay his poison
here okay he does kick back the white
Bishop and uh what does white replay I
think just drop that Bishop back any
safe square and you're happy and uh
Fabby chooses immediately terrible
position for Hikaru no I'm not you know
trying to overdo it I mean he just lost
the pawn and he's not getting it back
right so white has the pawn and the
compensation as Ben Feingold likes to
say and I just don't like Black's
position because white has a bishop
white has extra material if you take
this Pawn on B2 the rest of your
position might collapse after it so I
think Hikaru understands that his
opening has completely backfired he was
playing quickly Fabiano sat in thought
but not because he was uncomfortable
because he was like wait is this really
the way black should be playing these
variations and now Hikaru is resorting
to a creature and he needs to dig deep
because if he after the queen trade
isn't able to stabilize he'll be down
upon and that should be sufficient for
Fabiano to push for a win and uh should
we have a vote are the Queens coming off
or will they stay on the board which one
is Fabi going to go for Hikaru asking
that big question right now that's a
good one let's think about this is he
gonna take that boy or not calculate
let's see co-e-c-o-e-c-o-e how would you
calculate here James Queen takes Queen
he takes Queen he takes towards the
center always we're not always obviously
but take toward the center and then I
have to deal with the B2 Pawn so I mean
Rook C2 I mean I could in-game you but I
don't feel like doing that like I just
don't want to I feel like the queen is
actually weirdly placed on G6 so I'm
actually maybe gonna move the queen but
the question is where if I go Queenie
two I do want to go to E2 oh and uh okay
this is the current score line
but uh yeah the other option drop back
to this Square maybe you can slide
across to find your pawn and attack at
the same time but of course you have to
deal with potential night jumps these
Black Knights are really annoying I've
got to say these two pieces uh
especially the knights on C4 uh Fabi
chooses to use this Square because he
doesn't want to get attacked but this
Knight is Black's compensation as long
as it remains that black has chances I'm
looking at girl he's a little is by that
decision by Fabi he's shaking his head
it does look a bit dangerous just
placing your queen on the same file as
hikaru's Rook is that him just unhappy
with his position or unhappy with the
fabi's last move unhappy with everything
that's happened in this game look at his
clock he's down on time look at the
number of pieces he's down a pawn all
right you can see Fabiano making
accurate decisions not trading Queens
the evaluation bar has stayed the same
so I feel it hit Karu I mean he's found
a Fabiano in fantastic form and in just
a couple moves that Knight on C4 blocks
best piece it might be kicked out of
there and you can see he's rubbing his
eyebrows he's like she doesn't want to
look at this position because he's
sliding his Queen back and forth and I
think white can make progress yeah and
the last time these two played it's not
just the score but the score line in
just three games Fabiano caruana took
that mat and that's definitely going to
be something that's on hikaru's mind he
can't be feeling too easy this is Fabby
in the best shape of his life yeah the
last two these met when Hikaru had black
Fabi won and what a move by Fabiano
kicking back that black knight
immediately he's on a winning streak two
games in a row with the white pieces
against Hikaru could it be three now I
don't see what black can actually reply
to this move with if you take that pawn
you would have got trapped let's just
show this Hikaru oh not a move he wants
to play he Retreats and now it's just a
clear Pawn Advantage for white but if he
had been greedy here and grabbed a pawn
then there would have been consequences
okay the Knight would have been trapped
but uh yeah Fabi now just move the White
Queen off the line of the black rook and
white has an advantage uh just to show
that here Knight takes Pawn would have
been met by the very strong Queen to C5
the Knight is trapped no escapes quests
that was after Queen E7 I'm sorry the
same question and I think the bishop
would step in then yeah yeah wow nice
line and pick up the knights so Hikaru
had to retreat but Fabi firstly you can
take this Knight and just simplify the
equation up one Pawn long term or you
just move your queen out the way any
safe square and uh yeah your opponent
for later Black's Pawn in the center
isolated two
looking good for white and
Fabiano caruana up on the clock as well
he does have a very healthy extra Pawn
but what is progress from here uh Hikaru
jumping in with the Knights so still
trying to keep control over the center
how do you improve further from White
hair uh do you start advancing the queen
side Bond what's the big plan I think I
would try to trade Knights because
Black's Knight on e4 is super
frustrating for white at some point
there could be a fork if you're not
looking out for it so maybe we move
Knight forward for white up to G5 that
hits the black queen if it puts the
knight in contact with one another and
it may just swap them off we didn't want
to take the Knight with our Bishop we
prefer to keep our Bishop on the board
because our Bishop is a long range piece
that Knight on C6 can't go anywhere
forward so I think that knight g5's move
I would play here but I do like the
hikaru's chances I mean I'm not counting
him out I haven't liked his position I
still don't like his position but I
think that he is the type of resilient
when he's only down one Pawn he can make
his own chances and that could be a
problem for fabino down the line yeah uh
Hikaru is definitely not out of this we
would all take white here we know that
objectively uh according to the engine
at least and this one should be a
winning position for white but so far to
go into this game it might come down to
an end game grinder we all know Hikaru
with his defensive skills almost
impossible to beat uh if he's feeling
tenacious if he's really really focused
and Fabby as well six minutes it is
enough time of course but he might start
to get nervous if he can't make progress
often when you're pulling up you feel a
burden you feel a pressure to convert it
immediately to kind of hammer that nail
in and win the game but you have to play
it slow sometimes and this is one of
those positions yeah you know I'm
thinking about Fabi from the 2018 World
Championship match and they're in the in
the tie breaks in the rapid it was just
so one-sided and now there's this other
Fabi version 2.0 where he's been
undefeated throughout the trustable
Masters he won the second division of
the air things Masters Robert he's put
in so much work in speed chess format
and that couldn't have been easy for him
no because he loves classical chess
because when you play classical chess
with the longest time patrols you're
often playing your best chess so for
Fabiano to switch I mean Kobe was not an
easy time for him you saw his classical
rating dip quite a lot he was struggling
in most of the terms that he played in
but he played a lot online and he has
had success in various online formats of
course in the speed Chess Championship
he lost very badly to Magnus Carlson it
was a very lopsided match but Fabiano he
has his podcast the c-squared podcast
and he talks about it so he's very open
about some of his struggles but also his
triumphs and he has given new attention
to Rapid chess and look at his well his
results they speak for themselves yeah
absolutely and you were talking about
trading pieces in the position while he
has decided to trade one pair of Rooks
another pair of Rooks have been offered
for a trade is Fabi going to go for just
the Queens on the border do you see him
you can't really let go of the C file
you can't allow the black Rook to come
on to the first rank yeah all the Rooks
are disappearing it's as simple as that
it's just Fabby trying to make sure it
happens on his terms he wants the Rooks
to come off but as long as he keeps
control over the open C file ideally
with his Queen I think the question that
faby's asking himself right now as well
is do you want to trade one set of
knights for example as Robert pointed
out that idea is still on the board
maybe you have to give the white king
some breathing space at some point there
are few things you need to sort out in
your own position whenever I play chess
when I'm a pawn up I just think okay
let's keep everything nice and safe what
are the opponent's counter Play Chances
let's shut those down so first he
realizes that Black's Knight in the
center on the juicy E4 Square was the
best piece was the MVP and he wants to
trade it off logical play logical last
move but again if you imagine the Rooks
coming off the Queen's coming off even
one set of nights coming off if it's
just Bishop versus knight it is still a
bit blocked so White's extra Pawn will
not be easy to convert I think Hikaru
will Bank on his chances in that type of
end game and uh what do we think yeah
definitely not easy to convert I
actually like this Knight d2 move of
course because you're keeping the
tension you didn't have to take and give
him the file so vertex C8 we just allow
black to have the file kind of for free
and you also you have back rank problems
yourself on C1 so Knight D2 is a very
nice move it attacks E4 I can also play
F3 at the right moment believe it or not
I can even even put the King on F2 it's
a strange move but also it's the fact
that hey we're getting closer to an
in-game I'm up a pawn so if I play F3
I'm gonna threaten to actually play E4
at some point Bishop versus knight my
king is closer to the center this is
what you want Indian games and I'm still
up that clear Pawn that you're down so
of course yes uh practical chances are
there for um for white as as winning but
also practical chances for Black 2 as
well to try to make some uh some type of
draw maybe even get the pawn back just
because I'm down to pawn doesn't mean
that the game is losing right so it is
difficult um to still make this happen
you have to be precise practical
practical sense here so Knight to D2
very nice move from Fabi here and now
it's up to uh Hikaru to figure this out
yeah and Hikaru he looks slightly less
emotional than he did earlier when he
was losing that pawn when he was really
hating his position he knows now it's a
purely defensive task and sometimes
that's easier for a player we talked
about being a pawn up what the mentality
is when you're pulling down you know in
this type of position you're just
playing for the draw but actually that
kind of helps you focus you know you
have to just think about all these
pieces to exchange and okay he doesn't
want to exchange any he's throwing pawns
forward James what do you think of this
there's G5 oh that's G5 all day wow my
man's just swinging he definitely
bringing the fireworks here you're
supposed to play that early in the game
in fact not when I'm down a pawn here
but I mean I guess he's just fighting G5
is a very aggressive move so of course
oh I see what he's saying though so what
do you think what if you take on e4
while he was a piece dang that was nice
so you have to go Bishop G3 so the idea
here is I think he's gonna take on G3
and just say okay yeah you got the pawn
but like it's doubled your Pawn is
double maybe he's gonna take on G3 it is
possible to double the pawn but I could
end up undoubling it as well I also
maybe could go Knight F5 there's lots of
things to it what do you think Robert
yeah no it's a big question here and I
was just reading the chat up I think
about hurting my shoulder if it helps me
play chess this well that was pretty
funny don't hurt yourself don't do it do
that but what white wants here what
white is angling for is perhaps having a
pure night end game the reason why the
bishop can suffer in some end games is
restricted to its own color complex so
that means that if it's just the dark
Square Bishop that the Black Knight can
sit in a light square and there's
nothing the bishop can do about it so
that's why I'm a bit nervous for Hikaru
here as he decides do I take this bishop
on G3 that's a long range piece that's
got good activity especially with Queens
on the board but if I take the knights
off the board that means in certain end
games white will not be able to push a
pass Pawn through because white will not
be able to compete as well for the light
squares it's a big moment for a card
Nakamura G5 was a perfectly good move
especially with the limited material his
king is not going to be in danger but
the follow-up here is critical yeah I
would expect Hikaru to throw some pawns
towards the white Bishop just to ask the
question actually where are you escaping
to for example if you push this Pawn now
I'm not sure whether you trade Rooks
first then uh this bishop certainly has
questions to answer I'm not sure how you
get it out actually you might be forced
to play a move such as F3 just to
retreat the bishop but no I see that
this would actually okay I see why be a
mistake suddenly Rook takes Rook the
Knight takes the bishop and next move
Queen takes Pawn Suddenly It's black in
charge so that was the move I was
expecting first Hikaru puts his Rook on
a square a very solid Square where white
can capture but it would improve the
black pieces I think this move is coming
next or at least over the next couple of
moves Fabi has to watch out for that one
yeah and there's only one open file in
the position
also perhaps planning to sometimes fall
back with his own Queen and double up on
the C file to try and get control off
the only open file on the board so
Hikaru is still trying to find that
compensation for the pawn that it has
been lost out of the opening but he
can't be too happy with black to get
this kind of position where you're just
basically struggling for a draw yeah
you're groveling for a draw at this
point it's not the type position you
want I've said it from the very
beginning but I love his defensive
resourcefulness I mean he's making this
look like a battle it's not just
clear-cut Fabiano using the extra Pawn
pushing forward creating a passer not at
all as you said Tonya the queen can
slide back for black compete for that
open C file a White's next move isn't
particularly easy any pawn push you make
can weaken other squares and so Fabiano
he's deep in thought but now he's down
on the clock and that is dangerous
territory for him he's not the best with
just a few seconds he did prove to be
quite sturdy two days ago when he beat
hikar Nakamura in game one in mutual
time travel but that's not where he
thrives in typical chess yeah this is
what Hikaru does right when his opponent
is really low on the clock that's when
he starts to create these Dynamic
positions and the pawn breaks come in
and suddenly there are threats all over
the board so when you're playing against
Hikaru you need those extra seconds to
navigate all these complications on the
board but luckily for Fabi he does have
things in control it can't get too messy
in such a position yeah it can't get too
messy and he's saying with his last move
that he just wants to defend everything
I mentioned one variation where one of
White's pawns might fall off if you get
too hasty and play the move F3 to kick
away that black knight from the center
fabby's saying okay I'm defending my
Bishop now with my knight I'm defending
all my pawns my white king is super safe
and he will focus on maybe those peace
exchanges next and you guys mentioned it
Hikaru every time I watch his 3 dreams
he does end up in bad positions just
like the rest of us do he is human but
it's how he handles those bad positions
that kind of set him apart from the
crowd and here I do expect him to
actually hold this game suddenly because
white is forced to retreat yes it's a
solid move by Fabi I like it but somehow
it doesn't feel like it makes any
progress and I could well see that uh
good night versus bad Bishop scenario
that Robert highlighted earlier okay
on the board that's a trap David yep
very tricky move there's an idea of
Knight takes Bishop Black's Knight if it
jumps out the way taking the white
Bishop now it will actually win a piece
because there's tension between the
Queen's White Queen undefended loose
feast's drop off as they say and white
needs to put that Queen on a safer
Square
how to react to this threat
Queen B5 I'm thinking about it but maybe
as H five and I have F3 now let's show
this takes
take with the Age part maybe so you want
to move the queen potentially
the idea James Knight takes Bishop is
the threat because uh the queen takes
Queen now would be met by any return and
Knight capture and uh therefore we need
to move and it's in this position but
we're thinking not going to E3 but uh
maybe Queen B5 whoa whoa what the hell
whoa this looks natural I was just
showing the move you mentioned I I
wanted this too James
what is this how would this lose for
white is it 193 Knight C3 and maybe
after 37 92 Queen a a B1 oh my goodness
Queen Ace wow yikes well okay he didn't
fall for this but he's actually under
pressure this shows that Hikaru is
turning things in his favor he jumps in
with the Knight anyway but Fabi did find
a safer Square for the White Queen Queen
is the King's best friend when it comes
to defending just tuck this queen away
I'm not sure where you go now maybe
you're safe to step forward just don't
allow any checks Hikaru he's asking
these questions look at fabi's clock one
minute and actually it is Hikaru who's
creating the threats this is so
unexpected and now he's going back he's
happy to repeat the position or at least
ask Fabiano to continue playing on
momentum black I've got to say yeah the
good news though for Fabiano is he sees
what those one-off threats are so that
was a nasty tactic but Fabiano says my
king is not the safest let me keep my
queen eyeing along the second rank so
five minute he is doing a good job
hikara needs to prove that he can hold
this game move after move that's the
tough part he's pressing forward that
looks good it's threatening maybe to
trap the bishop if White's not looking
out for it but of course Fabiano is
going to be focused on that side of the
board all that said Fabiano's clock is
ticking down to one minute at this point
that's really not good news for Fabiano
Robert he play H5 how you feel about
that I like it because we live but I
think that Fabiano he knows who's coming
next he's just trying to figure out a
way to deal with it and if I'm Fabiano I
might start thinking about trading
pieces ASAP so I don't get in the time
trouble and lose this game yeah on 40
seconds so Fabi how difficult is the
time situation to actually handle this
right now hecaro coming with a threat
after threat on every single move you
got to start doing the same thing but I
just play F3 right now he played H4
that's a scary looking move Brave stuff
from a Fabiano not defending passively
he's defending actively here he's saying
okay if you want to come for my king you
might have to ruin your own Pawn
structure or give me control over some
squares in hindsight I do think Fabi
missed a trick earlier not trading off
his Bishop for a black knight when he
had the opportunity feels like those
Black Knights are so strong but how does
Hikaru keep things going shaking his
head there Hikaru for the first time
really in a while I think he wants to
take the pawn with his Pawn but he's
nervous at the resulting Pawn structure
if black does capture the pawn his
remaining pawns are all on isolated
lines you see Pawn takes Bishop takes H5
F7 D5 those are not pretty sitting there
but we see the evil bar reacting maybe
there's a queen G4 Pawn H4 type of
maneuver get an attack going it looks
like what attack how could you possibly
attack that very safe King but you only
need a few pieces a queen a knight in a
pawn they can do some serious damage
yeah Queen not ever dream attacking Duo
they work so perfectly together in
harmony once they get going but okay he
does block It Up Normally block
positions are good for Knights so I
totally understand why Hikaru did this
but now it's harder to get to that white
king suddenly the king side is closed
and the white king will be uh will breed
the sigh of relief okay he's coming
around with the other night Hikaru
trying to get more pieces into that side
of the board 20 seconds for Fabby
oh my God does he try and trade those
knights with Knight G3 is that an idea
that Fabi should think about get pieces
off the board that way he never loses so
he could make a nitrate and he will
never lose the game but he wants to win
he's up upon he does trade the knights
first that doesn't give away his
Advantage you see the evaluation bar
still suggesting white is better and
that white king can go up to H2
perfectly safe there so a good start to
this attempt for a win for Fabiano yeah
and if this was an Armageddon game this
would be perfect strategy you just put
that white King on H2 never get
checkmated you can pre-move on the other
side of the board for the rest of uh for
the rest of time and look at what he's
done white King Super safe of course
this isn't Armageddon that is increment
so he still needs to win on the board
Fabby but uh okay he's achieved step one
that white King's Super safe and whoa we
had moved by uh Nakamura there giving
away all the dark squares F5 bro F5
definitely I mean Bishop is definitely
an extremely strong piece now but the
queen has no entry squares so this is
actually very nice for me Karo here but
there's no entry squares right now uh
maybe we oh yeah he stopped the queen B5
yeah that's nice I think he's trying to
set up a fortress Hikaru he's totally
blocked the light squares the Black
Knight is the only piece on a dark
square right now everything controlling
those light squares the Breakthrough and
how does the White Queen get in Fabiano
kind of wincing there and the Black
Knight is coming around he's setting E4
yes he is he might play it right now
it's a good chance he can give up upon
the center and go for the dark Square
she says why give up material he's doing
the same thing but Tanya I was in the
same wavelength as you yeah
that's what
for 14 seconds but he's got all the
trumps in the position
does but he still needs a breakthrough
if Hikaru shuts the door and stops that
White Queen getting to the top of the
board if you stop her entering it's
still extremely hard for white to win
but the evaluation Bar says yes it is
winning why is he putting pieces on dark
squares it's against this strategy the
white Bishop now sneaking in trying to
break through and black creating counter
play suddenly the white king not so safe
anymore because the White Queen is so so
far away is so distracted okay that's a
check do you take this bishop or not
what do we think geez Knight takes
bishop or leave it on the board he says
the white Queen's coming in Queen d8
threatening Checkmate in one is training
the queen queen D6 that's the big
question black is down upon Hikaru goes
for he understands that this end game
should not be bad from that Knight could
actually attack the white pawns on the
queen side Bobby has to be careful yeah
Hikaru is going to be optimistic about
this end game look at the Black Knight
it drops in double attack attacking two
pawns it's level material now anything
can happen is it advantage of with the
queen side passes is this going to be a
difficult position for Fabi to defun in
10 seconds yes he could lose this game
oh my God he's allowed he can't have a
pass Pawn there it is all of a sudden
it's winning for black the bishop cannot
handle that pawn the knight's gonna move
out of its path and that Pawn's gonna
promote yeah there's no path back there
is no path back you can't even find the
eye diagonal to put the bishop on that
is going to stop this position is
winning how does Nakamura finish it off
classy move you cannot take this Knight
it's poisoned the black b-pawn will run
and make a new Queen you have to bring
the white Bishop back but it's going to
cost you time it's going to cost you
points there it is and okay you've got
the bishop back you stopped it but
suddenly Hikaru is a pawn up he's going
to win this game
white is totally stuck
unbelievable magician he's a magician
yeah 100 now of course we talked about
this before with the time right when you
get low on time against Hikaru it is
it's almost over every game it sucks
yeah this is Brute Force what he's doing
just move after move you can't pick up
that pawn with the King there is a fork
to follow and it appears on the board
and Hikaru there throwing his hand I
think he can't believe it himself what
has just happened in this game no
because he was worse all game until
Fabiano got in time trouble and once
that happened Fabiano he stumbled Hikaru
took full advantage that's a well-earned
victory for a car Nakamura oh my God
that was a total roller coaster game one
we are
starting
so many twists and turns it is time for
Aliso at our learning point
foreign
and what we've learned today is to not
get in time trouble against Hikaru
Nakamura things will never end well
actually Fabiano caruana played a
perfect game up to this point he still
had the advantage white with an extra
Pawn but this next move lost control he
underestimated the strength of the Black
Knight in the end game he brought his
Queen to the top of the board allowing
Hikaru to trade off the Queens with a
nice check White's King is hit the
Queens had to come off the board and if
we fast forward a few moves later we saw
this position with the black pawn
running down the board the Black Knight
doing such a good job and here the
killer move after King takes porn was
Knight takes D4 taking away a key pawn
and winning the race because this black
pawn is so strong after Bishop to A5 the
pawn was stopped but the Black Knight
keeps the white king in a cage on the
edge of the board and this was the
finishing Finishing Touch Pawn to F4
trying to create another passport and a
nasty check because after King takes
born this Knight Fork won the game
Knights so tricky just as Hikaru
Nakamura was in that game
has to beat Fabiano caruana in two
matches to take the Grand Final but he
has a dream start winning a game one
with the black pieces that was an
extraordinary start to our day and of
course we've got a twitch break coming
up but on the other side of that a big
game two
foreign
to take control of your journey towards
chess Mastery Magnus Carlson introduces
chessable the definitive solution for
studying chess move trainer uses the
science of spaced repetition to identify
your strengths and eliminate your
weaknesses there's no need to set up a
board remember which page you're on or
keep track of all the moves you miss get
started now and join our growing
community of over 100
000 chess enthusiasts chessable take
control of your journey towards chess
mastery
he is the chess streamer of the
of these men has arrived on casible you
want to know how to counter the Sicilian
the French the Carol Levy shows the way
with one E4 he brings masterful
technique to bring in those wins with
white head over to chassebel and start
upping your game today use the command
Gotham transable in chat to Master One
E4
wow we've had such an incredible start
to this Grand Final with hikaunakamura
taking that first game
David Fabiano caruana was the one who
was dominating game start to pretty much
the Finish how difficult is it for him
to make a turnaround now I think for me
immortal's recovery would be almost
impossible but these top chess players
they are well versed they are well
trained in these types of tournament
situations when the stakes are extremely
high so I do think Fabiano will recover
but it won't be easy he needs to get
some fresh air splash some water on his
face anything to reset yeah he's just
got to keep this behind him and for
Hikaru now the margin for winning is two
and a half do you think with the white
pieces he's going to push a little more
or is he just gonna shut down any any
tactics from uh from Fabi just keeping
it solid I would just step on the gas if
I'm a car over here hey pressure you on
the clock now of course he moved a
little bit too fast that's how he lost
the spawn in the first place so you have
to like readjust hey what did I do in
that last game oh I dropped the pawn I
was moving a little bit too quick but I
was up time and it made him blunder so
maybe a little bit of the same strategy
of moving quickly but you're gonna have
to be a little bit more accurate in
calculations and Robert what about you
what did you think of the form of these
two players coming into the the Grand
Final from that game one action we just
saw well Fabiano played superbly until
the end game when he was in time trouble
so I think both players actually played
well Fabiano played well at the start
and Hikaru played mesmerizingly awesome
towards the end so I think they both are
in good form but hikar got the dub
that's all that matters right now yeah
snatching that wind from a position we
thought the best result would be to get
a draw how Hikaru does it is a mystery
his chess in these difficult positions
is from another planet David Hikaru
starts with the white pieces what are
you expecting in the opening from him
oh it's hard to call Hikaru can of
course play anything he can play 1b3 he
can play the bomb Cloud he can play one
E4 and I do expect him to play something
solid uh we know Hikaru he doesn't
really push himself unless he really
needs to unless the opponent gives him
the opportunity to strike look at
Fabiana meanwhile just uh hatching up a
game plan here look at Hikaru just
really really calm I think he'll play
solid and wait for Fabi to come at him
yeah looking really chill there Robert
you know Fabi really well what do you
think is his mindset between the games
what is he doing to just get ready for
this game too well I know what he's not
doing he's not putting his camera out
come on get yourself centered on the
screen for all of us but in all
seriousness I feel like for Fabiano he
knows his preparation is superb and he
actually I think could take it into game
three he needs to hold here in game two
he will have his chances with the white
pieces yeah it's really important for
Fabi to stop the bleeding to not let the
match go out of control so not take too
many risks well Hikaru starts with the
kingpong opening are we gonna see a
Berlin
I don't think so I expect Fabi here to
kick away this bishop oh he's poor there
we go throughout the tournament he's
played this opening with success
Mainline Spanish rather than the Dell
Berlin and here we see okay the bishop
comes out James chessball courses on
this one oh there's a ton of them but of
course the one that I like the most is
the most aggressive one Fabiano he
actually references this in his course
which is a SP said thorman actually in
fact he has very aggressive intentions
semi-slave of course black with E5 he
has the E4 part one and two um he also
got the Janus uh whatever that is Janice
whatever how you say that thing but it's
a very cool one in fact the Archangel is
very strong and very aggressive one of
the most aggressive ways to play the Roy
Lopez for you fans out there they want
to play it from the black side but
that's the SP sister me here and the
ideas are very strong and we have even
uh Fabiano has many games here that he's
played in the Archangel uh Roy Lopez the
most aggressive intention here you can
play moves like H6 here Knight takes D5
Rook to B8 is a move right it's very
flexible you get the bishop outside the
pawn chain in usual Roy Lopez as you put
the bishop on E7 and played D6 but
that's more passive so Bishop to C5 is
nice you get the aggressive intentions
here it almost resembles a uh what is
this which is in the course as well a
Italian game an Italian game where
actually the bishop comes out quickly
you play A6 or A5 you play H6 but the
difference here is that the pawn is on
B5 so so far so good this is Mainline
Theory yep still uh very started stuff
he carry that just pushing a pawn taking
control over the center watch out for
later white stepping forward in the
center gaining even more space but I do
notice Hikaru is staying really flexible
he hasn't castled the white king yet so
I do wonder whether he's got ambitious
intentions on that flank on that side of
the board Hikaru looking away frowning
maybe this wasn't in the notes this
wasn't in the course uh has Fabi
switched up his move order here what has
Hikaru got in mind he's saying wait he's
saying come on wait wait a second shot
wait for this watch this right chat I
don't think that's right chat I don't
think wait uh the juicer here no I don't
think that's right wooden Shield but
sometimes you can check yourself though
you know when you're like thinking oh my
opponent made a mistake I could take
advantage but he is going for the
attacks of James you're probably
thrilled right now but I think Fabiano
should be happy about this move even if
it ends up being good for white it gives
Bobby some chances absolutely Rickshaw
one is a very interesting one here I
mean this is the the files are very deep
in the Archangel Roy Lopez you're very
very Demi that's a fake course SP said
throwing I think that's his first
accessible course was one E5 with black
so it was so much material in there and
it's very very aggressive but G4 G5 is
coming here but I don't think it
actually works the way that we want it
to him you can even play G5 yourself
here if it's black G5 like ah I'm gonna
play it before you do right G5 and then
maybe G4 maybe H5 and all kind of crazy
stuff like that's a crazy line by the
way G4 G5 H5
takes G4 what the heck is going on bro
you want to play H5 it's Blacklist
exactly I just wanted to I just want to
see if it works there's poor black King
James but also I mean you can't move the
Knight yet I guess you just go Bishop B3
right after H5 or something take it and
then G4 and Bishop E3 you have nothing
right so I mean some aggressive stuff
here from both sides but definitely
aggressive intentions from Hikaru
playing Rook to G1 that is out of book
for sure yeah don't try this at home
kids he has put his Rook on G1 rather
than castle and look G4 chaos has been
initiated yes there's been a trade of
light Square Bishops but Hikaru is going
all out for the win here despite a troll
being a decent result he's going for the
black king on the G file look where this
white Rook is placed and this is a hook
on H6 you use the hook to break open the
position uh by force and okay he's gonna
start throwing pawns off the board maybe
the Knight will come into F5 I've
actually seen this idea before it has
been analyzed out there I can't remember
if it's some books or some video courses
but as James says uh dangerous stuff for
black to face
I love it this is such a fun opening and
some committed choices there by Hikaru
Nakamura when he's already leading the
match by one point Rook G1 he is going
for Fabiano caruana's King Savvy has to
keep the clock under check as well David
you pointed out the Knight is jumping on
to F5 black really doesn't have a way to
stop that knight from coming there but
you can't allow it to survive on that
square for too long are you expecting
some nitrates to follow
possibly Black's Knight could Retreat
just preempt white jumping in but any
nitrates might open up this G file for
the white Rook Hikaru can get away with
this kind of anti-uh well this
counter-intuitive setup just because the
center is blocked so I wouldn't be
surprised if Fabi just says okay you try
Checkmate me fine I'm gonna blow open
the center and take my chances there uh
like you say Tanya maybe retreating the
Black Knight is the most solid but he
will uh also want to not allow this turn
to turn into a one-sided game he will
look for counterplay Fabiano that's how
he defends it depends how much he
believes Hikaru because Hikaru is on the
attack right now he's on the prowl and
five minutes looking like okay that
night is happening that looks scary but
oftentimes the best way to counter an
attack is by striking in the center
because if you just shell up the attack
may still break through and you're going
to be in trouble with more open lines
but D5 as David is highlighting here
that is a standard way to play The White
Knight is trying to jump into F5 you
can't stop that you're not pushing Pawns
in front of your own King but if we swap
Pawns in the center bring Rook to d8 yes
the White Queen lands on F3 but all of a
sudden you have to think for White is my
speed three Pawn hanging can black steal
that one I know it looks very scary here
but the eval Bar says Black's actually
doing quite well yeah and it still takes
while a while for white to break open
towards the black king it looks like
it's gonna end in Checkmate sure but uh
black can close this line down I'm also
looking for tricks like the Black Knight
jumping into this square like jumping
into this square with the white king not
safe either so he has gone for this
active defense uh that tends to be the
recipe for these world-class players and
it's not one-way traffic here your car
route needs to be careful himself
especially in this situation a win for
uh for Fabi would be disastrous Hikaru
will have blown all of his good work in
the previous game D5 is a very strong
move here and actually another course in
accessible courses on chessable courses
right but this is uh this actually
reminds you of a black lion in fact you
can actually do it in reverse black lion
actually comes from Simon Williams it's
uh you have the tame lion and you have
the risky line right that's what he says
in the course right but you can play it
for both sides I have students that
actually do exactly that they play it
for black and they play it for white
It's actually an aggressive filler door
in fact you just always just play G4 the
Knight comes around to uh F1 and G3 and
F5 very quickly a very very so much
resembles a black lion in Reverse here
but lots of times you do actually put
this Knight on F5 you play G5 you're
just all out attack King actually sits
on E1 lots of times you can go Queen C2
Bishop E3 or D2 and Castle Queen side
because the king actually is in the
center it could also sit on F1 as well
but it is difficult here for white
you're gonna have to if you get this
aggression off and you're able to get
this attack then you're good but of
course Fabiano striking with D5 is
definitely going to make a Hikaru think
as you see his hands on his head he is
in the zone calculating like a machine
looking at all the lines that he can
find right now that's not very typical
Hikaru pose that we see this is such a
critical moment in the position it is a
race to each other's King is what it
seems like but Fabi striking in the
center Hikaru lining up all his pieces
for a king side attack big moment here
and we've got a big update from division
two Robert we certainly do we know one
of our four contestants at the very
least in the third event division one
that will beat no direbec Abdul sitarov
the Uzbek teenager Olympia Champion
former World rapid Champion now division
two Champion here the chess of Masters
he takes down Maxine vashilagrove in
four games he wins ten thousand dollars
and he earns the right between division
one in the next event
yeah fantastic performance and uh we
can't wait to follow his games next
month uh Abdus tour of meanwhile back to
this one Nakamura is going straight for
that black king he's not messing around
what do we think of this James it's your
type of position going for checkmate
absolutely G5 and we live of course
again if you go through the black lion
chorus I highly recommend it's very fun
but as you get stronger you're gonna get
your hair cracked against very strong
players okay because it's actually not
supposed to work like that even as the
eval Bar says yeah G5 looks cool but
it's not going to actually work right so
because I mean you need more pieces here
I mean you're not all the way developed
look at all you got four pieces on the
back rank right so it is very difficult
still as well to actually make this
attack work but G5 you you're going for
this and you the black lion is all about
attacking the risky Lions what they call
Air you just have to attack and you have
this position this is exactly what you
need to go for you got to take maybe if
G6 we have a queen H5 there maybe yeah
maybe Queen H5 immediately but then
there's King H7 right yeah this is this
is not good like so I mean he can just
play GC and you might be in some trouble
here as from Hikaru maybe you have to
take on the E on e4 and allow a rook to
d8 I mean this is chaos but that's what
you actually get and all the risky line
positions it's very risky you know to
say the least sorry and I love this idea
that you pointed out James if actually
the black king either now or in the next
few moves parking itself in front of the
white Pawn yes white is one upon yes
white has opened some lines but the
black king is still super safe and
White's kind of just neglected the rest
of his position uh pursuing this attack
and Hikaru doesn't go for it yet he
doesn't open up the lines he does
capture on e4 I wouldn't be surprised if
we do see a black Rook land on the open
line and yeah counter play for black I'm
not sure who's better here I'm not sure
who I pick but it's complicated but I
think it's very instructive but you keep
choosing the f8 rook and actually
there's multiple reasons why for
starters the A6 Pawn of blacks is under
attack from The Rook on A1 don't forget
about that you may want to play Rook a
to the eight that may be the tempting
move but you'll likely blunder upon down
the line you see the evaluation go up
towards White so I think that if we go
Rook after Da we also open up the f8
script for our Bishop our Bishop will
come back to its home to defend the
black king so I think it's important
instructive moment to point out why
we're bringing the F rook and he
actually brings Dave Rook as soon as
we're saying that wow okay we jinxed him
commentator's curse has worked a bunch
this tournament now I'm expecting the
White Queen to move but where Hikaru big
question for him I don't think he wants
to go in this direction yes you keep an
eye on this B Pawn that might be
vulnerable vulnerable to the black queen
as we pointed out but the White Queen
will never participate in the attack on
the other flank so it's going to be I
feel one of these three squares I'm not
sure which one we're not going to G4
David don't even highlight that square
big but don't even do that we need by
the trade Queens but we do have Queen H5
and queen F3 are the only possible moves
in this position now of course Queenie
two maybe okay whatever I think he's
gonna do one of these three games yeah
right F3 or H5 I think Queen H5 it
doesn't work for some reason but Queen
F3 just seems like that is right it just
feels good but engine doesn't like it
but Queen F3 just feels good I mean yeah
B3 is hanging but I mean that that
definitely moves the queen away
you don't have an immediate threat I
mean D1 is actually covered I can
probably take on H6 I mean there's yeah
yeah take on H6 this is getting crazy
that's crazy goodness right now let's uh
give the players some time to work out
this total mess on the board but uh I do
expect Hikaru to go for the attack oh I
want to see him go for the attack he can
offer a queen trade I don't think that's
actually uh too bad for white but it
depends on his mood now Hikaru Nakamura
will he go for Glory will he go for
checkmate keep the Queens on the board
or will he trade off and play it safe in
light of the match situation big
question well considering he's up 1-0 I
think you know your match situation
calls for him to not take too much risk
uh he could potentially win this game
with an attack but I think his own King
stuck in the center he can't Castle King
side he's already moved his Rook he's
definitely not castling Queen side but
he chooses to go for the attack I think
that Fabiano should be happy about this
he may lose the game I said that earlier
but at least he has his chances and if
he plays as accurately as we know he's
capable of he could in fact win the game
you see the evaluation bar and his
favorite right now the white king is in
the center it's not just about the
attack against the black king white king
may be attacked first yeah this one is
chaos I think I would need an hour or
two on the clock during a long classical
game to sit down put my head down and
try to work out uh what's going on here
this is not the type of position you
would be evaluating either if you're
Fabiano if you're Hikaru you're not
worrying about who's slightly better
here it's just pure calculation attack
for white versus uh Black's counter
threats and uh Fabi knows that if he
plays it too slow if he plays it too
passive then white will break through
anyway so he might as well go for it and
uh how is he gonna do that maybe it is
Queen takes Pawn that black queen I'm
just staring at that juicy white B Pawn
and thinking okay I have to take it at
some point but is it now or is it this
chaos it's straight up chaos because of
course you can't award H5 oh my goodness
that's sick takes you play G6 won't be
like that you're gonna do that Bobby
just throwing a point
wow Tayson just played G6 and just look
at you all crazy after that Queen 6
Queen B3 Bishop D2 baby to yeah you're
calculating James five take bro I'm like
I'm in the tank right now but then the
queen might be trapped bro what is this
if you put the queen on this Square it's
definitely getting trapped at the very
least I might move just move my rook and
uh drop the bishop back try to trap you
I think the queen has to fall back but
the drop is done for Fabiano I'm not
sure where the queen goes next move you
happily grab this pawn and uh black is
doing okay look at White's attack it's
gone this King's Super safe and one of
the big issues is afternoon H5 white
wants to play G6 in the live position
don't do that look at that Rook on f8
this is why Fabi chose to move his A8
Rook he prevents G6 in this position so
he saw that this is not possible which
means his King will in fact be safe and
now it's akaru who needs to be worried
about his own King wow that is quite a
long Vision there by Fabiano moving that
a truck sliding it down to d8 when the
more obvious move was with the other
Rook but just preempting that you would
need this position to counter G6 this
last move by Fabiano is that just saying
that it is less dangerous to open the H
file than it would be to open the G file
yeah that's where White's Rook stands
right now the G file and that's where
the black king as well is also situated
so really classy move I've got to say
that's a world-class move it will take
me way too long to even consider it but
Fabi spotted it very very quickly he
knows he's not materialistic he knows
it's worth giving up a pawn if you can
totally shut down your opponent's
activity
I don't think it was on his radar either
he was not expecting this one yeah
that's a sick move I mean that's just
sick I like Rook A6 here but that was
that was a sick move
[Music]
could maybe be taken Tanya you mentioned
this one attacking the White Queen
attacking the white Rook if uh the queen
is captured this is a check and uh here
you win material you win the white Rook
at the end so you're up the exchange uh
up rook for night but uh I guess this
Knight could be captured but then Bishop
before
and then I run away
good for black though probably only for
Hikaru in that position so Rook A6 what
does he want after Knight D4 David I'm
not sure maybe he's bluffing Hikaru he's
just forcing uh Fabiana to think I think
he might be trying to minimize the
damage because we saw Magnus attempt
this against a car yesterday going down
the exchange but saying my pieces will
be on good squares in the event of
Knight D4 he I think will have to take
this queen on E6 and the line we're
looking at where black gets the Knight
taking the queen with check then white
takes back we see the king step up to E2
potentially and it doesn't look good
it's not good for white but Black's
pawns are not on good squares either
double nice in Center White has one pawn
and a knight for a rook that means
you're not down too much material and I
feel like this is the type position the
car is going to try to hold at this
point he's all about minimizing the
damage yeah and that we do see the
stockfish suggestions the engine
suggestions and actually for black three
strong moves give the advantage the Top
Choice here incredibly difficult find
just pushing a pawn he goes for it he
goes for the most natural move but it
wasn't one of the top three Suggestions
by the computer and now white still back
in the game if uh Hikaru goes for the
line that Robert mentioned Rook takes
Queen will lead to slightly better end
game for black but not winning yet
so tempting to play this move Knight D4
and that end game that we were looking
at it still feels like Fabi will try and
grind that one out he's going to have
his chances it kind of feels like quite
a dream start for Fabi when he's
trailing this match you get this as soon
as the move Rook G1 was played I'm
looking at the opening as a success for
Fabiano he has winning chances from the
start he definitely has winning chances
now and did you see that Robert no I did
I think we just missed it he was in
disbelief he was shaking his head at
night before he definitely didn't miss
Knight D4 I think he might have missed
it after the night is captured this
check from the black Bishop as you
pointed out Tanya as you spotted uh
otherwise the black Bishop would have
been captured along the way by the white
Pawn it must have been something down
the variation nobody at this top level I
think would miss Knight D4 as a one
mover but you might miss something
further down the variation well
sometimes top players Miss Checkmate in
one and sometimes we don't know what he
missed but I agree with you David I do
think it was further down the line but
what I will say is that this isn't so
bad for ikaru and he is very resourceful
it's not going to be fun but at least he
has a pawn and a knight for a rook
that's not a too little material and
Black's Pawn structure is not very
healthy so I think that Fabi has the
leading the clock his lead on the board
but Hikaru certainly is not out of it
I'm going to say one thing if that's a
line that he intended to go for and that
was his first intention he would have
played it by now if he wanted to go for
that end game David I think you're on
point that it is very possible that that
Bishop B4 into meso after white captures
the Knight could very well have been the
move that was missed here but Hikaru
Nakamura currently in big trouble and we
are going to be heading into that end
game where Fabiano Carana will have the
extra exchange but is this closer to a
draw or a Fabi win
oh that one's a tough one to call I
would say if it was anyone else in the
world that black has a winning Advantage
but we know Hikaru nakamura's defensive
skills it's going to be hard to break
him down here white is still relatively
solid for now he's using his Rook to
defend his Knight the pawns are kind of
holding together for now but if Fabby
can strike before which Bishop White's
King get to the optimal posts then uh
yeah then he'll have to go for it you
said before he could do something and
then maybe think of the move B4 so thank
you very much for that listening to your
words very uh internally and I think
black has the move B4 and the point of
this move is that you're trying to open
up a second wave of attack where it
currently stands is black has pressure
on the f file but hikar's last move
defends his Knight he is not moving that
Knight because the F2 Pawn will be
snagged by Fabiano so I think B4 is a
very nice choice for Fabiano to open a
second wave attack he said moves his
Rook over to eight that's as natural as
it gets but at some point he needs to
make progress on the queen side yep he's
trying to invade using the open file
trying to create this really nasty pin
also very logical we've got to say
similar to your idea Roberts switching
focus and you've got kind of this
two-pronged attack right now and looking
very good for black uh yeah against
anyone else I would say this one's over
but Hikaru can he find a resource here
he needs something magical in order to
hold off Fabi and okay steps forward
with his King but still what is the
answer to the black book coming the
whole way down the board and starting to
attack this white Bishop yeah that's
that's tough because I mean once you
attack the bishop then I can move you
know you're gonna you're gonna move it
or defend it but then B2 is going to be
loose right so if you have some extra
Pawn you're banking on or you're saying
yeah I have Pawn Islands but yeah you
have a weak second Rank and you can
barely even defend this b-pawn I grab
that one the B3 Pawn Falls C3 is
probably gonna fall to I have a pass B
Pawn we're pushing it all the way to the
house right it's going to be a problem
here I have an exchange The Rook on G3
is doing what just defending the Knight
on F3 which you still can't even move
right now because of Rook F2 so it is a
very very ugly position for Hikaru at
this point so many times get so many
weaknesses maybe his idea after The Rook
infiltrates is to just slide back with
his own Rook now that his King is
protecting his Knight but it's hanging
by a thread here for white just it's the
type of position if the wind blows it
might just blow over the position might
just uh uh be destroyed and uh okay can
Fabi knock him out here Hikaru Nakamura
he's thinking Fabi you've got to bring
that rook in or maybe that B4 move that
you mentioned Robert before it's too
late well also part of it is remember in
the earlier tactical position B4 was
somehow the moves that starfish suggests
so I'm gonna keep throwing out that move
hoping that stockfish agrees with me but
in this position white can hardly move
trades not going to be helpful because
the queen side those pawns are
vulnerable to Black's rook and I feel
like if hikaru's response to Rook A1 is
bringing his own Rook back his Rook was
there before which actually shows that
he made an inaccuracy and Fabi does push
the pawn ah you called it before he
suggested that move it and uh still
looking good for black
and it's on the board wow
in trouble for the second time in this
match but we saw what he's capable
capable of in game one it is not over
till it's over when it is against Hikaru
but right now Fabi also up on the clock
dominating position but he still needs
to convert this
I'm going to make a prediction I think
Fabi will strike back in this one with
the black pieces he's up in exchange I
don't see the Harmony in White's
position this is going to be your uphill
task for Hikaru this is a huge
opportunity for Fabi and the clock
that's a huge difference from game one
remember that Fabiano was in time
trouble when he started making those
mistakes here he's up a couple of
minutes hikaru's position is more
difficult but look at the evaluation bar
it's suddenly creeping back towards the
center and before it looked very logical
White's Pawn structure is ugly that pawn
on E5 the Knight looks like he can jump
but take it but not yet and hikara's
moves are very difficult so I do think
that 500 will ultimately win this game
but I just never count Hikaru Nakamura
out that's impossible Bishop trade has
been offered David what do you think
should Fabi keep that Bishop the dark
Squad Bishop it looks like a strong
beast in his position it does however
the white Bishop might become very
strong if you avoid this trade it is a
dilemma for Fabi you want to keep your
peace especially when your material up
this bishop as we mentioned earlier for
example it would Target this Pawn
totally tie down the White Knight AI
however White's Bishop now will plant
itself on the C3 to go out maybe not in
this exact move maybe next move and uh
not only does it attack this weak Pawn
but it also holds together these pawns
on the queen side it defends everything
it's on an anchored Outpost and uh
Nakamura here would live to fight
another day if you do trade however then
it's the white knight that will become a
strong piece the White Knight is
actually gonna sit on this C4 Square for
example now if you try to attack these
pawns white has a nice square with which
to defend them but also counter-attack
later in the center so some level of
stability for Nakamura the bishop trade
was declined and here we do have this
position can Fabi strike that is the
question otherwise the pawns might start
falling and we might well see another
turnaround later in the game
I think he can bring his Rook up right
that Bishop was covering an important
square if that black Rook jumps into
White's Camp the E4 Pawn that one is
hanging so I do feel like there we go oh
there it is it keeps happening right I
say a move and it ends up being played
by Fabi but Rook at 4 makes very a
natural sense you're hitting this Pawn
on e4 you're getting active you can
double on the f-file as well so this is
a good decision Fabiano akara's position
is just not easy to play yeah that's the
problem for Hikaru maybe on a better day
if you had a bit more time he would be
able to cling on that a bit longer but
you just make one slip as he has just
done allow that black rook in he played
a very natural move it's the move I
wanted to play as well moving that
Whitefish boy but now things are falling
apart those black Brooks have got active
and luckily for Fabi this Rook isn't
trapped there's a couple of safe squares
to use you can go over to B4 or you can
use the G4 Square offer a trade of Rooks
he's going for the pawns give me the
pawns right I'm just about to take
everything right I mean there's lots of
problem I mean look at The Rook still on
G3 right it's hard to move anything
right now very bad position 40 car with
display any double pawns on the B file I
can double there as well I have
everything under control looks good now
C7 is something to maybe worry about
slightly but it probably has this one in
the bag as long as he doesn't get in
some serious time trouble yeah that's
going to be absolutely key we've seen
enough players mess it up against Hikaru
when there's no time on the clock but
currently absolutely dominating Fabi
he's not only hitting the king side
pawns but he's only hitting the queen
side bonds I was gonna say but that
Bishop on C5 is also targeting the F2
Pawn where do you see Hikaru is going to
try and create something in this where
are his chances here his chance are the
next game
keeps making great moves and you can see
he's locked in he's got his hands on his
head his focused just strictly on the
board he's also focusing those B pawns
they're doubled their I said Pawn's best
friend is another Pawn because if you
connect the pawns and you could put that
B2 part one square over and keep them
defended then white would have some
chances but without that all of White's
pawns are hanging from Black's pieces I
just don't see how a car can survive
this
you want when you can block the app
activity from your opponent's Rooks but
I don't see that happening in this one
yeah by analogy yesterday Robert
mentioned it earlier Hikaru Nakamura was
the exchange up against Magnus Carlson
but wasn't able to break through there
despite his Rook for Bishop Advantage
because White's pieces contained the
Rooks now the black Rooks they've just
been let loose they have just been told
that they're free to roam and they will
break through win this game Hikaru using
his King as a Defender here but it
shouldn't hold the two black Brooks at
some point will line up and double up
against some of these white pawns all
the white pawns are weak that's the
issue as well if you have some level of
stability maybe you should save this
game but not here I think this one
should be quite straightforward for
black yeah he can do that now double
them up hit that beat three Pawn
yeah that he can play Rook B7 I was like
I think he was set in a trap but Rick
double the roach Bishop C7 you play Rook
B7 and not do anything else Rook takes
B3 check might be some type of trick but
maybe you could just take it anyway then
play Rook B7 yeah that's the idea yeah
just enough anything here you attack the
bishop next move you gobble up this pawn
and everything starts falling and he has
played this move the problem for white
is the only way to defend here to drop
back your knight to hold on to this Pawn
this will be okay it's on the board this
will be refuted by Bishop takes Rook uh
Bishop takes one attacking the rook and
when The Rook moves you create a nasty
pin you pin and this time you definitely
win so I think this is the killer blue
this will force resignation over the
next few moves Hikaru looking away from
the camera he knows Bishop takes porn
now Bishop diving to the bottom of the
board that's it the White Knight will be
eliminated and the defenses collapse
let me try one last trig we're on Rook
D7 you know like come on can I get some
ground can I have some counter play yeah
nothing to happen yeah yeah he didn't
let it happen no it's a good point
though because sometimes you let your
eyes off the prize and you let all of us
your opponent get back in the game but
every move thought man was playing his
with purpose so James was looking at
that pawn in front of the black king
that's why father gonna kicked their
Bishop out of there and said no attack
for you are you expecting a guy to try
and fight this out or are we expecting a
resignation from him soon it just looks
like there are no chances for white in
this position
yeah I don't think he should resign it's
not a good example to younger players to
newer players to resign games early uh
only when you know your opponent's
guaranteed to Checkmate you or
guaranteed to win the game then do you
press that resign button then do you
give up you should fight till the end he
learned his defensive skills Hikaru by
playing onto The Bitter End uh
especially online you never ever resign
unless you really have to so uh he's
fighting but it should be in vain here
Black's King coming adding a third piece
to the party this one looking good for
luck and good news for Fabi that he's
still up on the clock the moment you
said David that he needs to fight on
Hikaru just leaned into the camera
almost like yes David I hear you
I'm gonna fight this out till the end
but it looks like it's going to be a
better end for Hikaru wow that would
mean if Fabi is able to close down this
game he would level the score and two
wins with the black pieces well it's not
so far it's the chest with Masters
that's what we've seen all event long as
players are winning somehow with the
black pieces they don't do this in
classical chess but here the chess of
Masters in this rapid tournament we have
seen the player with the black pieces
win in many different games in this game
it's just White's pieces are tied down
if you're gonna try to survive down some
material you need activity that white
rope it's saddled defending both pawns
on B3 and H4 and look at Fabiano go
bring his Rook to more active squares
his King can get involved if he wants to
but just taking away all opportunities
all four jumps from that white knight
yeah dominate The White Knight and you
dominate the game nice play and hikaru's
reduced to waiting moves here he just
has to yoyo back and forth with the
white king sooner or later that black
Central Pawn the E Pawn is going to
start running racing down the board
material count is still Rook for night
but White's two pawns on the queen side
doubled pawns don't make a great
impression whereas black has the most
valuable commodity here that passport
push it and there we go he does uh this
one this one he's getting closer step by
step he just need to watch this time
that's it of course because it is
getting a little lower now of course he
is still up time but that's the only
thing that they would you know be a
factor here of in boxing maybe you know
watch out for forks and also you know
watch out for your time and don't Mouse
slip
too soon oh sorry sorry Magnus yeah I
don't expect any Mouse lips here but uh
that is one way to ruin these games or
to spoil your chances okay they're not
going back and forth back and forth the
black king nicely centralized now I
would try and activate that black Rook
over on B5 potentially just slide it
towards the center
nice Square there
white is stuck there we go and there it
comes he could look at potentially
hitting that Knight on T4 as well is it
time to start pushing that e-pawn
forward next
fully ready now he's mobilized he's
pretty pieces on perfect squares Fabiano
all defended no Forks here and ready to
push B3 looks good Rook D4 yeah he's
gonna push them well okay he's moving
quicker definitely gotta move fast you
get the three second increment
he says why not give me a free Pawn now
he's got a pass Pawn so he's got two
different pass mods he can bring his
Rook towards the center he just doesn't
want to give white any hope he's not
giving away any material and now he can
push his Pawn where it's defended by not
one but two Rooks yeah that passport now
is basically tying down that white Rook
forever and tikaru breathes out he knows
he's just playing on uh inertia here but
okay he's going active with the King
instructed for everyone at home don't
give up there's always a little bit of
Hope even if it's a one percent chance
of saving the game you might save them
uh and imagine if he does that's pretty
much going to be a uh psychological blow
that Fabiano can't recover from but whoa
Knight takes porn that trick doesn't
work the Knight will just be captured
and Hikaru does resign yeah and David
you can just pick up the night and after
a rook check the Rook blocks the check
so you save your own drug and Hikaru
makes the final blunder realizes it
doesn't even wait for fabi's move and
with that Savvy makes a comeback in the
match immediately in game two momentum
is so important and I think it could not
have gone better for Fabi black Pieces
come back immediately no of course it
couldn't have gone better he won the
game at the end of the day dubs are what
matters he got a great opening is Hikaru
was going to decide to fight for a
victory I think a car is going to regret
playing so aggressively yeah that move
Rook G1 you've got to take it a little
slow when you're playing against a
player like Fabiano caruana but of
course Hikaru we're expecting more
aggression more Fighting Chess let's
take a look at our score line going into
game three it is level but it hasn't
been peaceful at all too decisive games
the first one Fabi wins the second game
with the black pieces that's just the
kind of action and chess and match that
we're gonna have today of course there's
a lot more left on the other side of the
switch break
foreign
[Music]
Champion our starting a new course here
for chessable a very special chessful
course master your chest with Judith
Bolger you know what I learned a lot
[Music]
my name is Andrew giri I'm a top
Grandmaster from the Netherlands the
alliance and the recommendations that I
give are well suited for players of all
levels so I really explained a lot of
Concepts but also a lot of basic things
now it's your move don't waste any time
hit that buy button
[Music]
[Applause]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book club
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
Go to meetup.com chess to find your
local chess community
and it is a big time for the chess
Community as defeated world championship
starts on Sunday we will have a new
world champion by the end of the month
it does feel like an end of the era of
the Magnus era at least for now as he
begins his next chess Journey we are
very excited to see what Magnus will
bring on with that but also it's been
very special his contribution to the
Next Generation
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
I think the most important thing that I
realized over the years is that people a
lot of people fear me once you realize
that your opponent is not like mentally
prepared to play for a win then you can
take a lot more chances it's good to to
get some some young players here trying
to I try and Inspire them we have good
trainers of course here who try to teach
them properly as well the main reason
why I came here because I wanted to know
how he thinks because in my opinion he's
a genius he relates more on his
intuitive thinking and lesson is
calculation which is very interesting
for me because I'm like the other way
around yeah it's just very interesting
to be here and see like how he prepares
for like the world championship and his
cycle his psychology in general I really
like how to force myself to say that you
have to you have to continue you have to
like you're not better by any means then
you have to continue to blame I've won
so many games that way over the years do
you feel yourself that this is the end
of an era
nah I mean I
don't think sort of the era is is over
quite yet he has already won so much
that I don't think he has so much
motivation now to win World Championship
again it's the first sad I think for
chess world that's that he gives away
the world championship title because
it's it's clear to everyone that he's uh
he's clearly the best player and he has
been so for the last 10 years like kind
of understand because
we have been fed up with
preparing for matches there have been
many many times even later in my career
where I was thinking where I've suffered
a bad loss and nothing like
yeah maybe I just lost it maybe I don't
have it anymore
who do you think will be the next world
champion
did you hope will be the next one I
don't care
I haven't got any plans right now to
follow the world championship whether I
mean I will probably follow but I don't
think I'll go out of my way towards the
game's life but I'll I mean I will check
out the games for sure Peter heino also
in his talk he showed us how much work
it is how many months in advance you
have to prepare for a match so yeah I
can understand it but I hope to be back
that he will be back I've said several
times that I'm not completely ruling out
coming back to the world championship
especially under a different format but
as a fan I wouldn't hold my breath
Magnus has been an inspiration for so
many players and especially the new
generation the next generation of Chess
but right now we are also expecting
inspired play at the world championship
round one is set to begin on Sunday and
we've got our very own senior journalist
from chesscom Mike Klein he's joining us
from Astana hey Mike
hey Tanya great to see you I was with
you in person in Dubai but I'm happy to
talk to you here remotely yeah wow it's
so nice to have you there and here with
us what's the atmosphere like in Astana
right now
well it was very warm the last couple of
days it just got very cold today now I
was with both of the Players yesterday
for about an hour I was sort of part of
their live photo session basically I was
just holding the lighting gear but I got
to see their mood up close and personal
even make jokes a couple of the players
I have to be honest with you Tanya
neither of them are that comfortable
during a photo session but I would say
at least an apartment she's been down
this road before I think he got a little
bit looser as things went on uh I
wouldn't say ding was any more
uncomfortable than usual but it just
wasn't his scene acting out in different
poses that the photographer wanted but
uh that's just all part of being a world
championship Challenger yeah wow that's
so cool so the players seemed very
comfortable just days before the world
championship that's not very common Mike
yeah it really isn't and in fact
something else is not very common Tanya
not since 2014 have both players been
staying at the same Hotel I talked to
some of the organizers and it would be
very disadvantageous for either player
to not be here so there's actually even
a chance that they could run into each
other at breakfast in fact my first
morning here Tanya I saw Richard report
at breakfast I invited him over he
declined and then five minutes later
ding joined him and well it was pretty
clear what was happening so we can
pretty much confirm Richard report is on
team ding he is second ding if you can
apologize for the pun there but uh
that's one of the first uh major
Revelations is that the seconds aren't
as secretive as they used to be wow
this is really X
and interesting news and have you have
you been to any other players that you
might feel are part of the teams for the
two challenges
in fact I have I ran into Nikita
vitsukov in the elevator and uh as a way
of confirming some of the rumors I said
to him good luck to you and your team
and he accepted my my udachi practicing
my Russian here so I think that pretty
much confirms that he's on team
neponishi they've been long time friends
so so we have no at least one second
known for each team yeah and we also
hear there are a lot of other activities
and events planned around the matches
around the world championship how pumped
is the city of istana for this big event
uh well they almost got the president of
Kazakhstan to come to the opening
ceremony tonight that didn't quite
happen instead somebody read a letter on
his behalf but
um I was walking around Astana yesterday
filming lots of different scenes and
most of the locals that I talked to in
my broken Russian were at least aware
that the event was going on in fact I
randomly ran into several uh chess
academies uh so this is a chess mad
country I mean that in a positive way
and I think that there's going to be a
lot of nationalism uh you know sort of
built around this tournament so I'm
expecting some pretty big attendance and
uh and by the way Tanya I just got back
from the opening ceremony which was
partly in Russian partly in the Kazakh
language and partly in English
um so they're you know they're very
prideful of their local traditions wow
you're one of the opening ceremony
you've got to tell us about that do we
know which player starts with the white
pieces
in fact we do it I know you've been in
the studio watching this fantastic match
but on my Twitter I revealed a video
they actually had a robot choose the
pieces I think you have to go to my
Twitter to see exactly what we're
talking about here but the robot had a
bowl of white and black ponds it
accidentally picked up a white and a
black Bond at first
um but anyway once they had a second
attempt the robot picked up a white on
and that was on behalf of nepom this
year so Jan will play White in game one
on April the 9th I know as far as the
chessable Masters is going right now
white is not an advantage but in
classical chess I think you know Jan's
gonna try to take advantage of those
white pieces on uh on the first game
thank you so much Mike for all these
amazing
it's directly from estan
out for joining us and enjoy your time
there
thanks so much Tanya
yeah
starts game one with the white pieces we
will be bringing you exclusive coverage
and the action for the world
championship match and it will be Jan
taking on ding exciting exciting match
between two tremendous tremendous
Fighters Robin is it Advantage Yan to
start with white
that is a great question and I feel like
the last bunch of World Championships at
least before the previous one they were
tied they went to tie breaks in Rapid
play in the last one well the first
decisive result was until game six so I
don't think that the first game the
color you have there is necessarily an
advantage
I actually think it is sort of some type
of Advantage having white but also uh
just the experience and we talk about
this a lot you know even uh streaming
everywhere Twitter like just talking
about world championship biggest event
of the Year here right with white
actually you have to buy pieces so you
want to try to take advantage of that
but definitely nepo having that
experience of being at a world
championship before this is the second
one with nerves the psychology there
especially you know I think it'll favor
Nepal there yeah he's got the experience
but he also has the better head-to-head
score in classical rapid and Blitz
against sting so I think nepo's small
favorite ahead of that much
it is going to be a very fun match but
this one is it is all focused on this
extremely fun match as well two punches
by both of these players Hikaru starts
first Dan Fabi and Fabi sticks to the
Queen spawn opening he did get a good
position even though he lost the first
game I think sometimes we get distracted
by the results players included but
fabrina says I had a fantastic position
I won a pawn against a card Nakamura was
not the opening's fault so don't blame
it it was time trouble and
miscalculation deep into the game so I
think it's a good choice from Fabiano
we'll see how hikar improves because the
first game did not go his way even
though the results eventually did David
isn't this the exact same position from
game one almost in that game slightly
different move order Black's Bishop had
already come out to the F5 Square
White's Bishop also developed too so
clearly nakama has done his homework he
as black was the first one to change
switch things up and he's also thrown a
pawn forward in front of his own King
Knight's off the board now this one
chaotic position what do we think of
this James you know I love some chaos
here especially uh from either side but
of course G5 G4 is a very common idea
you see in this in the nimso Indian
especially the modern ninja these days
G5 G4 is very aggressive now you do
actually open up your king in many cases
so you have to be very very accurate
here but it's very um it works in fact
you have to put your king sometimes on
h8 and it goes to G8 and most likely
white will Castle kingside but it is
possible to council queenside um as well
so we'll see what happens I do like the
bishop F5 move here yeah and Bishop D3
blocks right so maybe King h8 at some
point Queen D7 the queen G5 too as well
these all these moves
um come out the reason for Queen G5
would be to actually go back to G6 as
well and defend some things so lots of
position positional ideas here but it's
also aggressive because G5 G4 so it's
very very crazy chaotic yeah just to put
some of the moves you mentioned on the
board okay I was going to say queen G5
one of them shuffling the king into the
corner very logical instead he drops his
Bishop back to a defended Square uh also
very logical way Nakamura but evaluation
part does not like it at all what is it
what do they want maybe it just loses a
move White NOW does have the opportunity
if he wants to start uh castling I'm not
sure which flank that's the big question
but Fabiano will have done his homework
what do we think Robert of this position
I think that white would love to make
the pawn to H3 to open up the rook and
launch an attack and fabiner makes the
move before I could say it Bishop F4
because if you played H3 first that
would have shadowed your own Pawn
structure that would have been terrible
you see the evaluation bar dropped
completely because White's Pawn
structure is often going to lose most of
your pawns there in the center so I
think the move Bishop 4 is excellent by
Fabiano caruana he can play H3 in the
future but Hikaru is holding nothing
back he throws that pawn forward with C5
we say it time and time again the best
way to defend your king if it's being
attacked is often to strike in the
center yeah really nice move so now this
little Pawn push would be met very
strongly I think by Pawn to C4 kicking
away this white Bishop you can't break
the tension along this diagonal really
you can't step out the way Black's
Bishop will eventually hit the White
Queen so after a trade suddenly We
compare pieces and I think black's
Bishop is the strongest piece of all
here looking at both sides of the board
Advantage Hikaru Nakamura still of
course not one-sided the black king a
bit open but uh this is his plan for C4
next move and Carolina does not react to
this immediately he instead castles now
this Pawn push may be less effective
because after a trade white will happily
just move the queen out the way maybe
slide across and start attacking some
loose pawns opposite color Bishops but
anything but drawish this position
wow I'm really liking it I've got to say
I'm surprised the car went into this
because he hadn't prepared it for the
first game he only had what was it a 10
minute break in between to study this
but uh yeah he's showing courage to
enter fabiana's uh preparation to
encourage every game and he's like
g-pawn and uh with white g-pawn with
black it doesn't matter like every game
I'm pushing his Jeep on CSI Karu and
he's doing it again all right now I do
like the center or at least the control
we have being able to play C4 but the
opposite called the Bishops I mean it
does kind of deter me a little bit here
not the biggest fan I'm kind of of it
there maybe we play something like f62
to try to do something about that maybe
Queen takes F6 but I have no pawns
around the king I do need to develop
still as well Rook C8 I mean these
positions are very difficult to play um
for black with with accuracy you guys go
for C4 and it looks like we're gonna
have opposite called the bishop game yep
and that Knight has been eliminated
opposite color Bishops but whose King is
safer normally with heavy pieces on the
board Queen's Rooks opposite color
Bishops they do favor the side who can
attack who has targets here if black is
able to attack on the light squares
white won't have a reply on that color
complex and likewise if white can
initiate an attack on the dark squares
black will struggle but uh for now it's
hard to imagine either side delivering a
Checkmate Black's King more open but the
white piece is unable to kind of profit
from that for now watch out for later
yeah David with opposite color Bishops
attack like you mentioned is absolutely
key if the heavy pieces get traded off
this will end in a draw but Hikaru has
to do everything to make sure that
White's Queen and Rook doesn't get
active because then it's the black king
I'll come under Fire absolutely no you
could take it it's your seventh position
I'm looking at Queen H4 right I wanna
well this is what you want you want to
play Queen H4 and you want to get this
Rook to H6 you haven't even seen lines
from honestly uh surya's course just
remembering he also has tons of games I
think the one is uh it's one of the
greatest courses on chessable like just
period for uh nimso Indian work right
Queen H4 but uh Rook G6 and and trying
to go for May here but he there's a
reference chapter that he has in his
book Bros like 100 plus games all from
the black side of the nimso India so you
can get lots of ideas from there it's
important to have ideas but Queen H4 is
very strong we do want to and obviously
he's plays Queen E2 here or he plays
Queen D7 but you do want to go for some
type of King side attack I mean the
bishop is Amy at G2 if we're able to get
in there then you know obviously we'll
have some white will have some problems
but Queen D7 I mean this is getting kind
of boring now there's a big threat on
the board though James Black is
threatening to secure the queen with the
bishop jumping in one square ahead on D3
so Fabi needs to take care of that right
now he does we could see an exchange
sacrifice because this position is about
the safety of the king and if you
sacrifice your Rook for a bishop and
pawn that could be enough compensation I
don't love the thought of it because
that gives black an open file to work
with if we do in fact take this bishop
here you'll see the C file become open
what do Rooks need open file miles the
black king is not that unsafe where I'm
already being checkmated right away but
if that white Rook on F1 somehow gets
into the game maybe Pawn to F3 even to
open up that Rook there could be an
attack but I just don't see it working
out I don't think fabana wants to go for
this kind of position I don't think it's
quite double-edged enough I think it's
actually one-sided in hikara's favorite
either he goes on to win that type of
position or he makes a draw yeah this is
the type of thing you play in a Blitz
game if you really want to risk it if
you're in a must-win situation for white
sacrifice and then open lines towards
this black king but here for Fabi it
does feel a bit Reckless so I do expect
him to actually move the other Rook here
maybe move this Rook out the way for
example and now Bishop D3 can come but
at least it won't win material now you
can just move your queen out of the way
again not sure which Square uh maybe
just reposition her in the center and
the game goes on it looks very balanced
to me but that doesn't mean a draw that
just means chances for both sides he has
indeed moved his rook and uh no threats
no breakthrough just who can outmaneuver
the opponent over the next few moves D3
hitting yeah and you call this David now
a big question to Fabi he needs to find
a way to get that Queen into activity of
course Hikaru is not going to make that
easy the score is currently level but
the feeling is that it was Fabi who was
also pushing in game one with the action
that we've been seeing today so far does
it just feel like Fabi is perhaps played
better in this match today
uh you know he's playing all right I
don't like how he's playing in this game
so you picked the wrong moment to ask me
the question because I think hikar was
the one who has all the chances that
that black king even though there are no
Pawns in front of it there's no g-pawn
that one's run up the board how are you
gonna get at it that Bishop on D3 for
black stops any progress for the white
Rooks and oftentimes you need multiple
pieces not just one Queen maybe not even
just a queen and Bishop you need the
Rooks to get in the game as well so I
think Hikaru he had a bad game one and
then he had a he won that game and then
he had a very bad game too but here in
game three I think it's a different
version of him yeah Hikaru here James
following your idea The Rook lift on the
board he wants to try and create some
chances against the white King David
this is such an interesting position
because aesthetic leader is looking at
it it looks like it's the blacking that
should be under Fire it is the white
king also feeling the heat a little bit
Yeah your king is only weak if the
opponent's pieces are active enough to
take advantage of that and look how
passive White's pieces are White's Queen
is blocked whites Ruckus blocks all by a
single black Bishop so uh yeah for now
there's no chances it's a distant dream
that white can attack uh whereas
Nakamura his pieces they have potential
um yeah that black Bishop it's like a
small little plug blocking up a whole
river and uh White's Pieces Just Can't
Break past it I just love nakamura's
position also if we look at both sides
of the board if we look at the queen
side which we've been neglecting black
has a poor majority there I wouldn't be
surprised if the black Rook uh do you
even lift that Rook it's going to slide
actually over to the other side of the
board and the black pawns are going to
start running forward I don't see any
productive plan for for Fabiano I've got
to say both Rook stuck the White Queen
stuck the position looking a bit rough
right now of course as we say do you
even Rook lift right I mean at home do
you even Rook lift right Rook to E6 I
know this is a very nice real Cliff uh
we uh the bishop on D3 is very strong
but I'm very annoyed by the bishop on F4
as well I mean if I can get Queen H4 and
Rook H6 there's huge problems right but
there also is is the problem of this
bishop on F4 really we can probably play
B5 and A5 as you mentioned and maybe
play Rook B6 try to push the pawns
that's where the pawn majority is The
Rook live looks nice we may even see
because how strong the bishop is
doubling the Rooks and Rook takes E5
maybe just we do our own and exchange
sacrifice and then go back around and
actually be able to uh to do some type
of key side attack where like your Rooks
don't help in fact especially if we get
the bishop we reroute it back to E4 we
set up the Rook to H6 and we actually go
with the queen to E7 over to H4 there's
like not like lots of nice plans for
black um and as you mentioned again I
mean white really kind of has nothing
we're kind of just sitting and waiting
we need to break this open they might be
trying for maybe B3 now but that doesn't
even do anything like we don't have to
take it we can also play B5 here so I
think chances are definitely all in
Black's favor right now yeah push those
pawns maybe even swing The Rook in this
direction and uh try to pile up against
this backward Pawn this weakness long
term I'm liking black I've got to say
but uh still early days in the
evaluation bar roughly in the center so
Fabi may be solid enough to stem the
tide to hold the balance but the
position is very clogged but only for
one side white Rooks staring into
Black's pieces Black's Rooks have more
space in front of them the grass is
definitely greener on that side of the
board and I feel like Hikaru can start
pushing his pawns forward the one thing
he can't lose sight of well if he puts
all his attention on the queen side the
king could be open and don't count out
Fabiano sacrifice some material maybe
that exchange sacrifice later in the
game can give him enough play but his
position is passive he doesn't have any
sort of active ideas there's no strategy
to employ here I think he has to shuffle
yeah and uh we actually heard Mike Klein
talking about seconds for the world
championship match I just want to shout
out to Hikaru second who was clearly
doing the work clearly studying this
opening between games and he was the one
who must have fed Hikaru the opening
knowledge to get this type of position
because game one he was pretty much
busted out of the opening he was losing
now it's black he has an advantage out
of the same exact opening and he
definitely didn't have time in the break
to study it himself someone his second
I'm expecting was uh doing this work for
him and clearly it's paid off Chris
Littlejohn is his name right Chris
Littlejohn that's such a cool name
Little John yeah important job at the
top level that's a great Point David
that you make because game one started
very similar to what we're seeing right
now but it was Fabiano caruana who had
the big Advantage out of the opening and
then Hikaru coming with the same opening
just a little twist a little change
which was prepared during the break and
now it is with the black pieces Hikaru
pushing this still the opposite color
Bishop how much poison is there really
in this position there is a lot and I
think a car is trying to find a way to
keep this game going and he just like
Rook to G6 maybe there are some attacks
on the king side on the agenda for black
uh but I just don't see the clearest
plan for hikara either and that's what
he is trying to come up with he's
looking Left Right Center where does it
come from but for now I think that
Fabiano can Shuffle and if black goes
too far there could be that exchange
sacrifice that Rook taking that Bishop
on D3 at some moment opening up lines
that could be useful for White's pieces
now you've been advocating that
sacrifice well that Bishop is very
strong David is there our potential for
the h-bond marching forward to try and
break the king side is that what Hikaru
wants yeah I think he's preparing it I
think you're completely right Tanya if
white just does nothing let's say what
makes a just useless passive move it's
hard to find anything productive
anything better than this to be honest
then black will simply March this Pawn
down the board again if white weights
the pawn comes the pawn comes even
further and you can't really keep it
locked up anymore if you try and bypass
if you try and block this Pawn then
suddenly The Black Queen has a root in
this is why opposite color Bishop
positions are so treacherous here at the
white uh White pieces cannot guard
against an infiltration on the light
squares so definitely a long-term plan
he's at least floating that idea in
Fabiano's mind he's saying okay you have
to worry about this Pawn stepping the
whole way forward if it gets there your
king is in big trouble so Fabiano needs
something over the next two or three
moves of course he won't just waste time
by time and pass the move to Hikaru
he'll try and do something maybe just
move his Queen forward as Robert's
indicating at least floating the idea
again of sacrificing The Exchange here
opening things up it's uh yeah
definitely I would choose black because
white plans are less intuitive
looking good James you'll be happy to
see H5 on the board absolutely I mean H5
H4 that's the whole plan there h5h4 play
H3 Queen F5 it looks good there you can
also take on G2 I mean how do you even
stop the plan H5 I mean I don't think
you can stop that plan either H5 H4 your
shuffling is white already and you have
to do something now wow this would a
positional domination it feels like I
mean the Bishops yes they're opposite
color but you can tell the difference in
the Bishops the bishop won't have fours
just almost feels like a pawn it is okay
stopping a rook from coming to H6 but
we're not even going to use it I mean in
fact what black is funny how black has
literally everything on the light
squares besides the A7 font uh and also
and vice versa and at one position you
show after H5 H4 and then they end up
going G3 and shuffling everything was on
the dark squares right so it's kind of
funny how uh how these obviously call
the Bishops here in these type of
positions everything's online
everything's on dark and look at this
like this is a crazy position right but
white is just I mean black is completely
winning at least strategic from a
strategic standpoint it was like why is
is 100 winning or black sorry black is
winning and white has nothing to do
queen C3 actually is now played with
looks like he's probably gonna sacrifice
on D3 yeah
definitely in the air but I'm not sure
if it's a threat right now and if it
isn't a threat Hikaru will get on with
his own business start pushing his Pawn
forward you can maybe guard against the
idea of a queen of an exchange sacrifice
Sorry by bringing the queen forward just
defending the square one more time again
passing the move back to Fabi saying you
can't sacrifice now so your pieces are
clogged up these two two white Rooks
just impotently staring actually unable
to contribute to this position not fun
it's really not fun for Fabiano when you
ask me the question and I was like you
asked me at the wrong time I'm looking
at this game and I'm just like if I
can't do anything he is trying to bring
his Queen to the center maybe he can
poke and prod try to stare at some Pawns
in Black's position but you see Hikaru
constantly bringing his Queen forward
he's also well ahead in the clock at
this point there's going to come a
moment where five of them may only have
one move to survive and it's not going
to be easy to find yeah when there are
direct threats on the board it's easier
to handle in chess you've often only got
only moves but here Fabi has to face a
big plan that Hikaru is planning to
execute creating more weaknesses on the
light Square Fabi trying to create a
break on the other side of the board
strikes with the pawn is there something
that Hikaru can just ignore I think so
what's the threat after all to trade a
set of Pawns is that so scary for Hikaru
no and okay he jumps in with his Queen
what is the idea here is he gonna try
and Checkmate white somehow
and and it's just the moment that white
tries to offer a queen trade with
perhaps capturing on C4 and then placing
the queen on the center of the board is
that something that Fabi should be
thinking about right now David normally
I would say yes I would love to get the
Queens off but actually after White's
last Pawn push black is guaranteed to
have at least one past Pawn if the
Queens disappear let's go in and examine
this uh if now we do see that very
obvious move Pawn takes Pawn black will
recapture with his own Pawn watch out
for this one uh promoting later a queen
trade here
think he might just say yes sir Hikaru
and after The Rook slides across the
black the white Bishop now is tied down
black is going to start pushing these
pawns and I don't really see a way to
fight against this again this one Bishop
is holding up two whole white Rooks this
Rook can actually swing the other way
now go for this learn learn porn
feels like one-way traffic this end game
miserable stuff yes you were suffering
in the middle game but do you want to
suffer in the end game as well big
question for Fabiano but that's what I
really like Fabiano's last move he
brought his Rook up to the second right
you need to use the dark squares so that
now if he captures on C4 his Rook inside
from D2 to B2 using a newly created open
file you need something to do if you're
Fabiano and black is still going to be
better pretty much no matter what but at
least there is some sort of plan yeah
and you've got like three moves to do it
because Hikaru is coming H4 H3 made on
G2 he's got a very clear Target on that
G2 Square in front of White's King to
deliver Checkmate there at some point
Fabi has to offer that Queen trade at
some point but he'll hope to delay it
until a moment that helps white or
whether it suits white meanwhile Hikaru
I have a feeling he's going to play on
both sides of the board first he
activates his only uh bystander that
Rook was doing nothing in the corner why
not bring it to the party invited in and
okay Hikaru reacted not very happily
there maybe he thinks he could more
accurate but still looks pretty good for
black to me
looks uh like he's playing very logical
chess Hikaru Nakamura it looks fine here
I mean I even like to work H6 so you can
just try to you know increase what you
want us to do here but maybe
maybe yeah work H6 is nice maybe he'll
go in there now because now E5 will be
hanging if you do something like Bishop
H4 Rook H6 is just threatening to play
H4 here yeah I mean he's just you're
just defending with white this is very
cool to see you know position like this
where you know it's almost like kind of
same material but we have opposite color
Bishops and black is just the one
dominating in this game
yep and meanwhile Fabi at least tries to
get one piece active as Robert pointed
out uh not capturing pawns yet but that
white Rook is about to find an open file
or semi-open file Hikaru I think it's
going to push one of his pawns to set to
a safe Square on that Queen side and
then he'll switch Focus back towards the
white king patience yes our patience is
definitely what hikara needs but the
problem is uh for Hikaru is that Bobby's
not gonna sit and do nothing he's gonna
keep pushing pawns try to open files he
desperately needs to do that so when he
car pushes upon him the queen side
Bobby's gonna do the same he wants Pawns
in contact with one another so he can
trade them and open lines for his Rooks
because that pawn on C4 that Bishop on
D3 blacks pieces are just dominating
White's Rooks and Bishop is a less
valuable piece than a rook so I think
that for Hikaru he's doing the right
thing he's taking his time right now it
is a critical moment he wants to figure
out how to properly defend this Pawn on
B7 that The Rook has in its sights yeah
it's still fascinating that pattern you
pointed out James I can't stop looking
at it nearly everything for black is on
light squares everything for white on
dark squares and apart from a couple of
Pawns which might well move it's just
classic opposite color Bishop strategy
just put all your pieces on one color
complex and they call it like ships in
the night just passing each other but
here if Black's the one breaking through
on light squares which it looks likely
at the moment then uh Fabiana can't
react there won't be a defense just move
upon I think Hikaru needs to just stay
patient he's looking for a breakthrough
you can tell right now on the camera
he's been a bit of time he's looking for
something direct but maybe that director
breakthrough doesn't exist so why Rush
you've got all the time in the world
right now Fabi still doesn't have too
many direct threats
and um yeah looking good for black still
Rook H6 just seems right right I mean
doesn't it can't you just play it let's
see what happens Dave let's let's hop
into the board here what happens on The
Rook H6 right yeah it goes up a little
bit but I mean it's it's a practical
move it's threatening H4 right yeah and
if you do want to take it in between
move Pawn takes C4 I can take it back
with the pawn first defending B7 so The
Rook move I don't even care about your
little work move on B2 it doesn't do
anything right because I'm defending and
then you have to respond to H4 once
again so Bishop at force with Tempo I'm
a big fan of tempo so okay Bishop at
four but then I can just back up work
eight seven maybe you can go H4 anyway
do you really want to care about that
later Tanya that's how you feel
I love the idea the execution will only
take a car as king's head off so I think
the problems are H4 is you can take the
Rook on H6 and after HC you play F3 you
solve your problems along the second
Rank and unfortunately too much material
sacrificed yep so uh black does have to
time the attack correctly but I like the
ideas yeah and uh James I would love it
for uh Hikaru right now to go for the
attack
I think he will at some point in the
next couple of moves I mean he spending
a lot of time on this as he should it's
a critical moment you spend your time in
critical moments when you need to right
and it looks like he's gonna make a move
here as he reaches for the mouse he's
been on a in the think tank for about
three minutes right now right big time
investment he's blown all of his clock
advantage in this one position so it
must be something special that he's
planning Hikaru if he takes the time out
now and just plays an innocent little
porn move on the queen side as we're
expecting then he will regret having
just tanked for three minutes having
thrown away uh all of that time that
could be useful later
I think Fabiano kind of gaining in
confidence as well in his defensive
efforts if Hikaru doesn't find anything
your idea is on the board
take Fabiano unfazed that was a very
quick capture on C4 he brings the bishop
up rook G6 so if the bishop goes back to
G3 are they gonna just rinse and repeat
I don't think so if you're a car no I I
would be so disappointed if we got a
repetition here because this position is
about to blow up once the bishop falls
back but it has to right James otherwise
finally the H Pawn advances if the
bishop falls back do you think a car was
just gonna go for a repetition well you
repeat once right like the the strong
Russians whoa you tripping he lost his
absolute on National Television what is
this E6 is not a move just thrown away a
pawn I'm just gonna grab it easy look at
Hikaru Perka up there like bro what is
this is this a pawn it can be captured
in four different ways and not a single
white piece is defending it so I I think
we're all shocked but what piece you
capture it with that's a good question
activate his Rook on the fifth rank I
guess oh look at this okay the point is
captured and White's Rook is going up
now and actually is white the one trying
to attack I this must be the only way
you would throw away a pawn for free
okay he's gone for it big big threat on
the board Rook takes pawn and suddenly
if the Rook gets there this would be a
Checkmate the black king would come
under Fire
whoa what an idea from Fabi and okay
Hikaru just like he did in the first
game today through his white uh through
his Pawn forward to F5 and look how weak
this king is suddenly really nice idea
from Fabi but he needs justification he
needs compensation he did throw away a
pawn he's a pawn down any end game now
is clearly winning for black Fabi needs
to Checkmate Hikaru otherwise he's going
to lose this game he needs his Rook to
move like a knight he needs his B5 Rook
to get up to the seventh rank that's
where you need to cause some damage but
it is a bit slow black will react
accordingly but what an idea you give up
your Pawn where four different black
pieces can take it you did not have the
square defended he desperately wants
activity and that's what top players do
they would rather be down material for
ACT to play and he plays Rook C5 he
wants that Rook up into C7 where he'll
threaten checkmate
yeah I think Robert that's a great point
that it is about activity and a
practical decision there by Fabi in a
very passive position just trying to
create a mess the eval bar hits it but
who cares about the eval bar Hikaru
offering a rook trade and we immediately
see the eval bar say that things are
getting more complicated in this
position yeah this is not one-way
traffic anymore earlier we were saying
okay it's black who's slowly advancing
at will at his own Leisure at his own
pace now at least there are counter
chances if Hikaru slips he might be the
one getting checkmated so from a
practical point of view that's what we
talk about it's ease of play whose plans
are easier actually the stakes are just
as high for black as they are for white
right now so I think from a practical
point of view great move by Fabi yes
he's pulling down though so uh he needs
to keep that type of energy in his next
few moves remember did you received at
his own Leisure
yeah there you go I was like what oh
Leisure oh okay that's what he calling
me out James
every time and I'm here trying to think
like James I want to try to sacrifice
all the white pieces go for an attack
I'm thinking can white push this Pawn to
F3 to open up the G file at some moment
come on James I'm trying to you know I'm
trying to do you a solid here I'm trying
to look for checkmate that is the goal
of the game so for example if you trade
Rooks on anyway whoa F3 the Eva Martin
budge okay okay
swinging I was gonna try to trade Rooks
because I can't allow you to Rook to hit
the check you take back with your queen
so your palm structure intact and I was
just trying to take back on F3 and if
you take with your queen my queen gets
into F6 and I was thinking I might just
have enough play dang whoa whoa wow love
it Robert whose King is weaker it's
unclear probably it's just a mutually uh
well it's just a balanced position
because there might be some Perpetual
check ideas in the air okay he doesn't
go for this he tries to get his Queen in
anyway also eyeing up this Pawn in the
corner and uh watch out for this one
later I love it Robert just giving away
pawns pawns don't matter in this
position it's coming yeah
put us on camera don't we look like like
brothers don't we yeah see you see the
resemblance you see it
that's crazy man it's crazy one week
sitting next to each other and uh yeah
just osmosis
that's my brother wow but right now it's
a really big moment for Fabi because
Hikaru has a massive threat and perhaps
the only way to counter it you can't
allow more light Square weaknesses you
will get checkmated Fabi goes for H3
eval bar is saying Black's doing great
hair how dangerous is this for white and
does black capture on H3 how do you
react with black well I think you have
to capture if you don't then what else
uh hikaru's shaking his head he doesn't
like his position
but the evaluation bar disagrees it says
black is almost winning yeah I think you
have to take this point I mean you have
to I mean I wonder why he's shaking his
hair like you you just take the pawn you
threaten me first off right threaten me
and then we do something like Rook E6
just to swing The Rook over I mean it
defends the the sixth rank there takes
like first of all you have to defend it
so maybe we do Rook E6 is there
something wrong with this what about the
check on d8 so suddenly the queen goes
up and steals yeah that's a critical
Pawn to drop can you do James idea but
just sidestep the king to eight seven
instead and bring the Rook to G8 or F7
as you're pointing out beautiful yeah
that's beautiful beautiful stuff there's
no checks for against the black king so
it's actually Black's turn to attack
maybe this is what Hikaru hasn't spotted
so far that's why he's leaning in now
he's realized he can move the black king
out into the open to actually make room
for the black Rook to go for the white
king and uh crazy complicated position
it's so incredibly unclear because when
you're visualizing this in your head
even if you continue just two moves
Bishop G5 to block the file Rook G8 and
pond F4 your queen is stuck on C6
because your queen leaves that White
Queen infiltrates so suddenly both sides
have chances that car is looking at this
like how do I win this position my Pawn
on H4 is in a dark Square it's under
attack and is my king really any safer
than whites this is a really a Mad Dash
for each other's King it's chaos yeah
total chaos the reason I believe black
is better is because simply black can
play with a rook whereas White's Rook is
just unable to enter the action but uh
yeah Hikaru still has to work out this
variation still very complicated despite
the evaluation Buzz uh assessment there
still Anything could happen so super
critical position and the players have
got two and a half minutes to figure it
out and the line is on the board Rook G8
is a big threat uh Robert's idea of
blocking that line with the bishop and
then reinforcing the defenses with the
pawn will we see that it's kind of hard
to imagine an alternative here you've
got to find a way to close down to shut
down the G file Sabi goes for a king
side step wow so Checkmate threatened on
the board the black queen is threatening
to slide down on the diagonal to G2 next
to the white king Checkmate there's only
two ways to guard against that you
either bring your own Rook across as
white and offer that Rook trade but
endgame's favor black or you throw a
pawn forward the white Pawn can go to F3
I was like what's the other way like you
can't be another way like what do you
have on F3 I don't think you can take it
if the black queen ever moves just as
Robert pointed out earlier the White
Queen is going to go give some nasty
checks to that black king so there we go
don't pick up the minor girl the heat
Queen D7 would be a Big Jack
poisoned one you cannot capture this one
the black queen is stuck where she is
actually as a Defender so nice creative
defense there from Fabiano
man this is crazy oh my goodness chaos
here and there's not enough time this is
like we don't gotta pay to play this
position here man this is crazy you
don't know it takes check check check
check I don't think I'm mating
yeah I'm not even made it Bishop E2 nice
move yeah beautiful play from both sides
I've got to say two Geniuses here uh
meanwhile the black Bishop does jump in
attacking that lone white porn if you
put pawns on light squares they'll be
eaten up by this black Bishop now Fabi
needs something how does he get that
Rook into the game that's the question
no checks the black king is safe for now
that's the big problem for Fabiano
I don't see it I don't see what white
can try yeah to start targeting the F5
Bond perhaps Robert is that an idea he
did it the engine didn't like it but I
was thinking the same thing going after
this Pawn it's that difficult to a
position to play because if 500 trades
pieces he's already down one Pawn likely
going to be down two so he goes after
the F5 pawn and Hikaru trying to figure
out where his Queen goes back to D7 and
it might slide all the way up the board
to D2 this is scary stuff for both
again evaluation bar reacts this is
crazy they're playing very natural moves
very logical moves but it's so hard to
handle with only a couple of minutes on
the clock mistakes are guaranteed it's
just about who makes the final mistake
at this point if you make a slip you
will get checkmated and that's true for
either side right now how does Fabi keep
up the pressure probably about to go
under a minute and as the time gets
lower Fabi honestly gets worse it's not
it's like I mean it's hard I mean that's
just funny but like many players of
course are Timmy f grishek is different
right they get stronger when the time
gets lower but not for Fabi as we've
seen this has been proven in this
tournament when he gets low on time he
makes more mistakes so he is lower on
time we know how much of a bully Beast
Hikaru is and it's scary you know when
you are low on time like this especially
against someone as strong as Hikaru is a
mistakes are around the corner for both
sides but really fabi's under some
pressure can you see like a move he's
down to 30 seconds and the position is
really starting to heat up you will need
to find some critical defensive
resources and to be able to do that in
seconds will be very tough 20 seconds of
Fabi what is he doing
he covers eyes were darting away from
the board he was looking at the clock he
knows fabi's ticking down now he's going
to try and hustle him on the clock now
for sure it's just you just take the
Palmer yeah there's one Pawn hanging and
final definitely wants to trade Queens
because without the Queens on the board
his King feels safer but not that safe
the white king will have no legal moves
if the bishop takes his Pawn F3 this is
bad news for Fabiano Maybe
this is desperation this is absolute
desperation
one too he's trying to open up lines for
his Rook that white Rook but this Pawn
can be captured three-point advantages
for black but he's probably eyeing that
D2 square but there are sacrifices
everywhere on the board even if the Rook
slides down to attack the queen Hikaru
can potentially look at a queen's
sacrifice in that position and sliding
up with The Rook to G2 yeah there are
too many operands for black here you can
just move his Queen away he can
sacrifice the queen pick up a rook and
Bishop for his troubles and we see that
the bishop can capture but is tired of
saying Queen takes D2 Bishop takes back
Rook G2 check the king can only slide in
the corner and it's still better for
black you can take this bishop with
check and black has what a bishop a rook
and three pawns for the queen that's too
much material yeah eventually it feels
like this Pawn should promote this looks
very strong for black but maybe he wants
something safer maybe he doesn't want to
give up the queen here it looks forced
Rook D2 you not this square but you have
to move your queen I'm wondering whether
you can run away to this side one of
these squares I'm not sure where you go
you are three pawns up it feels like you
with a few accurate moves you win this
game if you're Hikaru but uh Fabiano he
is trying and this on the board now
black queen attacked where does she find
safety but her car also doesn't have
that much time right so both players are
about to get a scramble oh nice block
yeah blocked there Rook comes on to line
up against hikaru's King and now the
level the clocks are level as well this
could go anywhere even though the eval
Bar says it's completely winning for
black it is a three result game yeah
yeah three extra reports for black but
that means nothing when you've only got
15 seconds left with such an open King
okay he hits the White Queen kicks her
back but still no way to safety for
black yet and uh if Fabi can keep
harassing that black queen maybe swing
the white Rook back where it came from
there we go still asking questions
Hikaru frustrated Fabi is not lying down
he's not going down to defeaton now the
white Rook can swing back to the G2
Square massive threat and can you trade
off the Rooks and bring your queen in
for the attack dude there are many
checks that the queen can give and
fabino does it yeah how do you dodge all
the checks that are incoming oh I'm
sorry he's just relieved with the
position this is the best position he's
had all game now and now it is Hikaru
who is on the defense on the board and
on the clock yeah I don't think you can
escape all the tracks evaluation Bar
says pretty much level now Fabi can
start grabbing pawns even if he wants to
and where's the black king gonna hide
yeah
be careful it goes right in the open I
mean that just gives white so many
checks at this point but a car is trying
to be tricky he's gonna run his King go
Merry-Go-Round and eventually will head
to the H7 Square so I think hakara he's
trying to force Fabi into even more time
trouble and he then he moves off with
just seconds on his clock yep diagonal
checks are always a good way to start
the game and Fabi made that last move
with two seconds left he gives another
check but safety the safety for the
black king no more tracks no it's losing
oh that's gonna hurt that's gonna hurt
counter check where's the bishop yeah no
oh the way here Bishop B3 though right
oh and check and then Bishop D5 yeah
Queen G3 is amazing
wow guys Nakamura is the one who
checkmates Fabiano caruana he wins the
game oh wow after another big Hustle
takes the lead in his
in his fantastic way to end this game
three that was absolutely insane we see
Hikaru there he can't believe it he
throws his hand but he's done what
needed to be done he takes the lead in
the match I still don't understand that
expression I mean he should be
celebrating right now it's typical chess
player Behavior when they don't play the
optimal moves they almost don't care
about the result anymore they're just so
in their head about how could I play
better the next game oh
the next game will be coming up but what
a round we've had David you've got to
show us the big moment yeah it turned
around so quickly we thought Fabi was
just getting back in the game black was
three pawns up in this position but
actually White's counter-attacking
chances are sufficient for the draw
Fabiano here forgot about his own King
he forgot that he had this weak King too
here with an accurate move Bishop to E5
he blocks any potential checks kicks
away the black queen and it's actually
White's attack which will force a draw
will force a repetition there but
instead he went for a different move
trying to drop back with a checking
Motif here against the black king he had
forgotten a simple check though from the
opponent uh Nakamura pounced Queen B2
check the white king stepped back a
double attack hitting the white bishop
and hitting the white king when the
white Bishop steps back now
The Black Queen Retreats and the
difference here the white Bishop has
been forced to a bad Square no matter
where you put the king this check is
going to be deadly in fact here it is
Checkmate what a ton of events what a
counter-attack by Hikaru Nakamura
amazing stuff there hey guys gets his
chance and he takes it it looks like the
players woke up today and chose violence
they chose violence and they chose to
win with black every single time this
has been the chessel Masters in a
nutshell wow this is incredible stuff
three wins by the black pieces Hikaru
Nakamura leads that match two to one
Fabiano caruana has to win on demand to
take it to playoffs or we will have a
grand final reset all of that on the
other side of this twitch break
[Music]
it might be as simple as Robert saying
just check right in three yeah one two
three bang and Carlos played perfect
chess he's got that Evil Genius look I'm
just uh wondering how should I uh play
with my food here he's going for blood
in this one so Hikaru needs to make a
maximum of 99 moves from a few moves ago
and go behind save the day well these
players are so good I've got to say drop
that Rook down Hikaru and you will not
lose this game he does it yeah but it's
all about the white d-pawn if he kicks
the central point of life he might
oh my god oh you should be not blunder
Shaq being in one and then a car
immediately does you can't potatoes
curse
is going to cost Hikaru the whole match
oh and what's happened there what
happened we see a reaction
oh no Magnus Mouse left blundering into
that Queen
what an end
wow and this is their updated Head to
Head after the action that we've seen
today in this big Grand Final Hikaru
Nakamura has to beat Fabiano caruana
twice today to win The chessable Masters
Fabi needs to win one of the two matches
but right now we are in set one and it
is Advantage as he leads Sabi has to win
the next game on demand and I never
thought I'd say this but the good news
is that Fabi is black yeah that's the
nature of the chessful Masters all
players seeming to win with the black
pieces that is not typical of high-level
chess but it is what it is here at the
chessful Masters of course at the high
level what they say you know um one with
white draw with black but it's more like
win with black and hold with white you
know what I mean it's very strange here
of course like you said it's a story
accessible Masters and hopefully Bobby
is able to strike back with the black
pieces the one thing that's for certain
Hikaru will not be playing any moves
like Rook G1 that he did with his last
white uh his last white game he will not
take any any risks at all it's all about
drawing for Hikaru he's going to be
super solid in this next game wow the
clocks are ticking Hikaru a is going to
shut down the action while he does start
with the white pieces so will follow
be able to create a mess try and get the
chaos that he needs to strike if not we
will have a grand final reset what are
we expecting David you said no more Rook
G ones no more of those g-pawns pushing
down the board aggressive play by Hikaru
while it has paid off so far what will
he choose this time I still think it's
going to be a King's Pawn opening the
players don't want to switch too far
away from their usual repertoires but
this time he will choose more solid
variation in the Spanish or in whichever
uh opening Heat he elects and uh yeah
Fabi I think the owner the onus is on
him the pressure is on him to really
imbalance it I don't think he should
play one E5 there we go Sicilian country
attacking opening
action okay chessable course Mark
esterman okay there's like okay there's
like four guys on like there's like four
or five of them on on chessable right
now but the Smith more by actually
assuming is probably the greatest one
it's very thick and it's very dense I
actually recommend it in your settings
on the side you actually put it on all
moves instead of the one that's regular
because all moves there's so many moves
and it's a lot of things that you are
gonna forget so make sure you change it
from you know um the moves that they
give you to all moves that's on the side
on the options tab for you people that
actually know inside of the course what
I'm talking about but you know what's
interesting about this opening yeah of
course it's sacrifice a pawn for white
you get compensation but Faba did not
make the main reply his move A6 on his
previous turn it had a car thinking
because it's not the number one choice
and Fabiano has said this in many
interviews that sometimes it's better to
play the fourth choice of the engine as
long as it doesn't completely collapse
your position because that means your
opponent is less likely to expect it and
to prepare for it so Fabiano he's up a
pawn in a must win game we're not saying
his position is better but I think think
this is the type of position the type of
opening you want when you need to score
a victory yeah I think if you gave me a
hundred guesses how would Hikaru
Nakamura face the Sicilian in a
situation where he only needs a draw I
would not have guessed the Smith Maura
Gambit yeah and uh wow why it's just a
pawn down but in return you do have very
quick development James and uh nice
access to squares absolutely uh the more
aggressive lines are obviously Bishops
to C4 and you go back to B3 and you
Castle you just don't want D5 to happen
but Bishop B2 I'm curious to see what he
does as strong as he Kara is Bishop E2
is uh it's not the main main stuff but
you also play a game you actually castle
and play Queen E2 and Rook D1 very
quickly but he's actually playing at a
completely different way I've never seen
it played this way uh Smith Memorial but
I mean hey Hikaru is like you know 27
bit hey 2800 right 27 28 on it right so
we uh have to see how he's going to play
this queen B3 yeah he off to hit he's
straight off the head here and it's
probably cool to see how he does this
here he's going to put pressure on the
D6 Pawn With The Rook D1 but by actually
kind of sidesteps this very easily by
Queens of C7 and just saying literally I
am up a pawn right you didn't play this
right I'm up a pawn and we're going to
take this to the house yeah for example
uh White might attack this point the
black queen will just sidestep any
potential pressure along the D file and
I guess the question is whether white is
in time with a move like uh Rook to C1
if white if Black cast was then to jump
in this type of tactic just to show uh
there is some pressure along the C file
it's all about time here it's all about
Tempe if black is in time to consolidate
he's just going to be a pawn up if white
is in time to strike you gain the pawn
back sometimes with interest later on so
white very active here but Hikaru he's
asking big questions to Fabi at such an
early stage Fabiano despite the fact
he's played quite quickly up to this
point he will still be reeling from that
shock of the last game and this opening
yeah I still think though the opening is
a success the type of opening for
Fabiano because a draw is the same as a
loss at this point he needs to win and
now he has a position he is up upon this
isn't just some easy position for a car
to play where any move
keeps the position level you see that
the eval bar remains about 50 50 at this
point but I do think that a car at some
point might need to prove that there's
enough compensation for that pawn he's
doing a great job thus far but as far as
openings go you can't ask for better
from Fabiano caruana's perspective this
isn't just symmetrical it isn't dry the
Queens are still on the board there are
chances here yeah that's why I'm so
shocked by hikaru's choice there are
dozens of ways you can get a safe
position out of the opening with white
in any line but uh this one you are
pulling down the stakes are pretty high
now you must back yourself you must have
so much self-confidence in order to
enter a line like this in this match
situation with uh yeah the title on the
line but yeah if anyone can it is Hikaru
Nakamura now I'm expecting him to bring
his Rooks to the center first he can
attack this black queen there is one
Escape Square
always happy gonna counter-attack nope
he does escape and the white Rooks now
will centralize with some pressure light
squared Bishop especially unhappy about
these last couple of moves these
developments sounds like very difficult
um for I mean the engine says it's equal
here but I think this is just with
precise I mean Super precise engine type
play right and the thing is you can't
move the knight from C3 because E4 is
actually hanging in many lines I mean
actually maybe you could go Knight D5
now and with the idea of Knight C7 but
after we trade on D5 you really don't
want the pawn there as much I mean it
could it does make it does have some
Merit like Knight D5 Knight takes D5
Pawn takes D5 right so takes takes and
then obviously when the Knight moves
then we could go Rook C1 and you get the
C file and there's some pressure there
and there's something you know yeah Rook
C1 and then like we have some pressure
it's really annoying here but we are
down this pawn and the thing about the
Smith more is you have to keep up the
pressure quickly and you have to be
aggressive I mean anything that is
passive moves like H3 A3 I mean you can
play them but you you are gonna have to
rely on a mistake from black hair giving
the pawn back because Black's just up a
pawn and if you're playing passive it's
not going to work and black will convert
this Pawn some somewhere down the line I
really I really like it James just throw
the knight in why not create some
threats uh the alternative would be just
to shuffle The Rook across and hope to
create threats later on the next few
turns but uh that's what Hikaru is
plundering right now he has a few
tempting moves a few candidate moves and
he's got a lot of time on the clock but
still up on down and that's the key
factor if nothing happens over the next
few turns he's been playing so
aggressively from the start of this
Grand Final camera just throwing down
his pieces towards the king he hasn't
cared about material he hasn't cared as
much about development in the first two
games but here the compensation is very
clear do you think this is part of his
match strategy just going for it from
the very start maximizing his chances in
every single game yeah but I don't think
that's wise when all you need is a draw
but at the same time he does it for the
fans he was saying yesterday when he
beat Magnus he's like it's content you
know it's going to be good talking
points but I do think his position is
fine here I just don't necessarily
understand why he chose this style of
play against Fabiano because look what's
happening hikar is the one in the think
tank he is down a minute and a half on
the clock he's down a Pawn on the board
he doesn't have the clearest plus yes
you could put a rook on D1 you could put
a rook on C1 black is going to Castle
then try to kick this bishop out of B6
at some point maybe move the queen out
the way so I just feel like the
long-term plan isn't that
straightforward for Hikaru he is down
material he's not now doubt time so I
don't quite comprehend what he's doing
when you sacrifice
that is really our
day off he needs to do so do something
immediately and the idea is that James
and David
they're talking about jump
jump that night to that Central Square
and a big questions to Fabi I'm
surprised that he's taken about three
minutes right now what is the
alternative that he's thinking about is
he thinking about just getting the Rooks
to the center getting them into the game
before he strikes with the Knight yeah
normally the best players in the world
they do spend the most time on the clock
when it is either calculation or
planning so either that's a long-term
plan starting with this move starting
with lining up the white Rook with the
black queen or he was calculating that
more direct attempt maybe he was spent
all his time looking for the Knight
jumping into the center realized
actually black had decent answers there
Pieces come off the board it wasn't
enough to justify the pawn deficit and
he decided okay a slower approach is
needed but still it is a part of a
bigger plan and often you see these top
players they spend three four minutes on
one move and then the next few come in a
quick flurry so uh yeah nice moves by
Hikaru black is still tied up so black
needs to unravel before the pawn becomes
relevant the queen and Bishop that Fabi
has it should be the other way around
you want that light squared Bishop into
the game you wanted on that Central E6
Square targeting White's Queen but that
is the biggest development problem here
right for black that misplaced Queen on
D7 James how does Fabi proceed to
connect and find the Harmony in his
pieces I'm actually looking at I was
trying to get Queen E6 to work or even
Queen E8 um as some in some way I mean
it's very uh it is kind of ugly I don't
like the the moves here Queenie six
maybe Knight D5 there uh it's very
possible here the engine goes up right
95 looks kind of annoying I can't take
so Queen EA was the other alternative
but then Knight D5 anyway
um turning Knight C7 so I have to take
the Knight and then I have to like move
the Knight which we kind of looked at
this briefly of uh in the C files open
we have to move the Knight maybe the ba
correct and yeah you have the seventh
rank but what do you do with it in fact
that's cool and all all you got the
seventh rank but I can kick you away and
I'm actually my next threat actually in
fact I can do something like you know
King's Indian like but look at first off
look at the pieces all in the background
it looks very strange but I can play F5
F4 and then I can actually play a knight
D7 Knight F6 right and my queen is
actually set up in a Dutch type uh setup
so now my queen can now go over to the H
file I order the G file at some point
and actually start attacking you with
this nice attack so Queen E8 actually is
an ID I think whoa Knight H4 yeah
speaking of an attack there are big
threats on the board already David yeah
big threats not only can you jump your
knight into F5 where it most likely will
Thrive sometimes you can even consider
jumping into another Square the G6
Square for example if black were to play
a uh slow move you could consider
jumping in here attacking this black
Rook the Knight is not up for capture
because of a pin along this diagonal so
a couple of things to worry about there
but either way a dual purpose move a
nice idea from Hikaru to jump in and
sometimes here in the position there are
tactics this Knight is slightly loose
but if black tries to jump out the way
for example attacking this Knight then
it just ends up in a bunch of exchanges
and this Pawn suddenly would be taken
I'm not sure by the White Knight or by
the white rook and white is very very
active so complicated position what do
we think of this one yeah I don't think
that Fabiano wants those series of
Trades it's too forcing it allows a car
to have an easy plan I like to move
Bishop d8 I'm not sure if it works right
at this moment but I'm trying to flush
that Bishop out of B6 it's really
bothering me over there and these Knight
F5 ideas that would Thrive if not for
the fact that the Knight might be a
little bit loose on that square there
could be tactics revolve around Knight
takes E4 for black removing the guard of
this Knight it's dangerous but this is
the type of play you need for Fabiano
you need to live on the edge of it if
you're trying to score a win yeah I love
this move Robert from a strategic point
of view as well just uh if these two
Bishops disappeared the Black Knight has
access to a beautiful Outpost in the
center of the board so a nice way to
unravel you go back in order to go
forward later but uh will Fabi choose
that move that's the question and how
critical is that because it does look
like a Fabi gives Hikaru just a couple
of moves the attack on the king side
could be quite dangerous with the Knight
jumping in so is this the moment that
Fabi needs to neutralize that pressure
by offering trades yeah big big moments
and uh I wouldn't be surprised if he
does spend three four minutes he's
already spent two minutes on this one
turn uh yeah the top players again they
know how to apportion their time they
know when to pause when to tank and when
to speed up and this feels like a good
moment I chat once an Armageddon a
little clearly I don't blame them but
what do you guys think I mean do you
think that means Fabi has to win this
game to take it to Armageddon uh do I
think he's going to win this game at the
moment no but do I think that the fans
won't arm again yeah that's pretty clear
to sikaru absolutely nuts you're going
against your streamer what are you doing
Chad I guess that's what all chats do
right they like pretend to be on the
streamer's side but they really are
trying to rile them up and troll them
that's how it works
and James you have to answer that one
well
um first off okay that was just about to
say queen eight was the move first queen
eight was going to be the movie if
Knight G6 yeah Bishop E6 little in
between move there so very nice we did
get out of the way here and I think
Armageddon is very possible I think
Armageddon is a very possible Chad wants
it I think it's nice and hey we do it or
we are a pawn here but it does it does
take like you have to win he has to win
here and it does I mean this is if it's
gonna be any game it's definitely going
to be this one it's a lot going on
um Sicilian is the way to go for these
sharp positions he's up a pawn right
here this is a sharp game and uh he car
was going to try to you know take it to
him here but Bishop E6 is definitely
coming here maybe I can even move the
knight in many cases too as well hit the
Knight on H4 so there's some stuff yeah
there's some some ideas chat shouldn't
forget as well we could still have an
arm again later even if Hikaru wins this
game so plenty of action still ahead and
that's true uh James you're a streamer
how kind of important is that audience
playing to the crowd it feels like
Nakamura he's doing that in this game
yeah in fact a lot of times the uh the
energy right in fact right now in
hikaru's chat I'm sure they're saying
right spam this Prime spam your Prime to
get hecarulo on time or probably low on
time right that's what they say he's
going for it anyway Bishop E6 Knight
takes E7 has to be the move here unless
he got something about to play something
crazy here no there's nothing you have
to take on these Saturday night maybe
block with Bishop C4 block with the
light Square
this is ridiculous Bishop C4 what the
heck is this super strong David Bishop
C4 valuation boss says level but at
least it's on the radar um of course we
should point out safety first move you
take this bishop with check and you
don't lose your knight but okay he did
jump in with the bishop this is all
Force yeah this is all Force this would
have been a pin and a win for white
because now this Rook is actually
trapped would have been grabbed next
move by the White Knight he had to allow
the bishop pair to disappear
hikaranakamura and while a flurry of
quick moves here the White Knight
jumping in white has the bishop pair
beautiful Bishops here but Black's still
a pawn up big threat though Knight to C7
how does Fabi deal with this one and you
guys have been talking about exchange
sacrifices
actually captured that pawn on e4 or is
the queen running out of squares so many
questions here yeah that black queen
just doesn't have enough squares in this
variation it's going to have to go into
the corner and that's not good news for
Fabiano so even if he's able to get some
material for the sacrifice Rook it's
just not a pleasant position to look at
so I think it's much more likely in the
live position 5.0 drops that Bishop back
at long last to d8 there are
complications here the D6 pawn it needed
that Bishop's defense maybe there are
some trades that white can have but I I
like the type of position that we're
seeing here unless it Fizzles out
immediately and I'll regret my words a
little bit I think that the dynamic play
continues and that gives Fabiano some
chance he might lose the game and he
plays Bishop d8 but he still has chance
I keep saying this it doesn't matter if
he loses because if he draws the
alternative that's the same as the loss
yeah great defensive move and again
black piece is retreating to the back
rank Black's Queen Black's Bishop in the
last few moves they have stepped back
but that is because it's necessary
you've done the hard work your upper
material so you just need to solidify
your position and that's a tip for
everyone on at home I see so many
players grab pawns and then just forget
to kind of take a step back and Shore up
their defenses they keep going forward
keep going forward and they get hit by
the enemy pieces and Fabi he knows that
the material is where it counts that's
what he's banking on later in the game
so he's happy to just Stave off the
threats and here we do see the engines
suggesting only one move for white to
keep the balance
the margins are getting smaller and
smaller here at the margin for error
from Hikaru and Knight takes Knight
Knight takes F6 check is the only move
that's not obvious that's not a move he
wants to play and I feel like the
engine's misleading here because with
proper play very precise play White can
hold and remain relatively balanced but
David you talked about this a long time
ago that if the dark Square bishops get
traded that Knight on C6 it will have a
landing spot on D4 and that's a big
problem because you can't kick out a
knight on a dark square with your light
Square Bishop so what Hikaru has just
done by the way is he's avoided this he
does not want to see that night Lane on
D4 he brought his Bishop to D5 and he's
putting pressure maybe he'll capture
that Knight on C6 and maybe that's his
hope but I think black is first you can
trade Bishops and then jump to D4 with
your knight yeah beautiful Square for
the Black Knight and suddenly yes you're
giving back a point yes this Pawn might
drop but you have the superior minor
piece and look how dangerous this Knight
might be if it continues jumping in that
would be a check and Fork I think
momentum Fabi and great chances to win
this game still not over of course still
Hikaru with sufficient resources if he's
accurate but that's the key white is the
one uh maybe on the back foot in that
variation I love it just trade off these
these Bishops and get access to those
Dart squares absolutely he needs to uh
and also watches time too as well he has
a lot of time right now they both do but
definitely have to watch the time I am
up the pawn he wants to be accurate here
we have an open app file and we have
stuff stuff here why why you can end up
playing something like F3 to make sure
everything's nice and stable later but I
mean what a game here I am down I am up
a pond as black here but it's now
doubled which is uh kind of annoying and
we have a backup on D6 so we do have to
be accurate but we have to lots of moves
and again Rook B8 though that one is not
on the radar
today is a very strange move by Fabi in
a very critical moment and immediately
Hikaru says no more trades you don't get
access to that Central Square for the
night Retreats with the bishop hikaru's
got the bishop pair an open position and
this is proper con compensation for that
extra Pawn yeah also big threat on the
board that uh Hikaru set up here Bishop
takes Knight now the light Square Bishop
capturing that night would be a winning
move because the black Rook that did
just move on to B8 would be undefended
if black tries to recapture the White
Queen that Black Brook too much tension
there I don't like it I think missed
opportunity for Fabi and wonderful
retreating move from Hikaru it's not
easy to find these types of Retreats or
bringing the bishop back was a great
choice by her car and I do want to say
if the colors were reversed I am sure
that hikar would have taken the bishop
and put his Knight on D4 I think you've
done so quickly as well his intuition is
just at the top of the game and for
Fabiano I think he's overthinking it
that he was like can I protect this Pawn
keep my material need that'll give me
better chances it was one of those
moments and it's weird to say this as a
chess instructor he should have thought
less and just played just do it you
mentioned hikaru's intuition as being
one of his strong points is also one of
the reasons that he's so good when he's
playing on seconds because he can really
rely on his intuition more than
calculation yeah he also knows he can
make bad moves if they're tricky right
like he knows when to take those chances
sometimes players are perfectionist and
that backfires for them and I think with
that last move by Fabiano he should just
take in that Bishop brought his Knight
in the game and it would have given him
better chances than he has now yeah and
how quickly he just made that move it
was on his radar gave him the option and
he will come back with the bishop and
Fabi meanwhile has also stepped up with
the bishop to E7 but it just looks like
now it's more difficult for black to
create some play that night it's not
moving forward anytime soon yeah black
is a pawn up but also remember the X
report is also a double Pawn on the G
file now yes the black king is safe
behind that wall of Pawns but black long
term is never creating a past one so how
do you win this game it's difficult like
Tanya says if you can't jump forward
with the Black Knight what is your plan
white just has the luxury of doubling up
the Rooks putting pressure on slowly
improving black is a bit stuck very
strong improvements and James he's just
going to double up and start targeting
that Knight on C6 there is a very clear
threat that Fabi has to deal with next
looking at 94 and now it doesn't work it
takes the queen 92 King F1 oh that's
hurts
yikes
man this is a tough position yeah if you
jump in with the Knight yes the tension
between the Queens but the Queens do
disappear and there's not enough time
for that check that you mentioned
because of Kings F1 when you take the
White Queen the Black Knight Falls as
well white ends up with an extra bishop
and uh if for example in this position
you have to take the queen back Hikaru
remember he only needs to draw very
minimum he can eliminate this Knight and
uh we go down to an opposite color
Bishop Ben game white is going to Feast
on a bunch of Pawns and it's actually
black fighting for the draw so Fabi
cannot entertain the thought of opposite
color Bishops yes it was opposite color
Bishops in the last game but that was
with heavy pieces on here the Queens
would come off Rooks would come off and
uh to point out Tanya's threat there
this is monstrous this threat otherwise
black would simply be losing that end
game if we do see a bunch of Trades
blacks pieces
can't coordinate looks great now
suddenly for Hikaru just that one Bishop
trade missed opportunity and things have
turned look at the time I mean he's
getting lower so three minutes now and
you think for another two minutes he's
in drastic time trouble yeah but he
could have an r in this position and
it's still pretty bad to handle this how
do you get out of these pins along the C
file and The Queen 98 without avoiding
any trades that's going to be a tough
one and more trades the better for
Hikaru yeah no it looks like Hikaru is
not going to lose this game and the good
news the only good news right now for
Fabiano is even if he loses this game or
if he doesn't win it's a draw he gets a
reset there will be a two-game match
between these two players if Hikaru wins
this best of four so for Fabiano I'm
already thinking do I just give up this
match and then try to gather my bearings
to get ready for the next one I don't
think he should do so in this position
but at some moment you just don't want
to stare at this position anymore and
get yourself set for the reset
yeah if he goes this
we do
do rapid games and the Fabi that shaking
his head that is a desperate move on the
king's side it really doesn't improve
his position David yeah what an ugly
move now that black dark Square Bishop
is basically a big Pawn it's never going
to break out onto any active diagonal
Black's Bishop is just locked behind its
own pieces the reason he played this
Fabiano is to bring the black queen out
actually James you mentioned this
earlier the black queen as in a lot of
openings you mentioned the Dutch defense
does come out on the light Square
diagonal but it is desperate suddenly
black is just busted on the light
squares and white can continue with this
plan I think Hikaru won't hesitate much
longer he would slide his Rooks up uh
double them up on the C file and I don't
see any counter play at all white King
Super safe Black's pieces can't attack
it simply
it's very very hard to play this
position here I'm up a pawn but then I
have a backward pawn and a double pawn
and white has all the play all his
pieces are great and then if Bobby's
just trying the best that he can make
some complications which is totally
understandable G4 now what's the plan
maybe Queen H5 and then hope for the
best like what else do you even do I'm
not even attacking anything after that I
can't get the Rook into play it can't go
to H6 you can look at some Rook F3
possibilities that's cool but like it's
a cool looking move it doesn't actually
even attack anything if I go work F3
maybe a queen H5 abandoned the whole
Queen side after he gets his Pawn back
on C6 maybe even go up upon taking on A6
and then doubling the Rooks on the f
file that's all I can see here as you
say James uh Queen H5 could happen but
unfortunately Queen H5 I know not alive
because there's simply nothing to attack
no they don't attack white can just
gobble up pawns and look at these guys
they'll start marching very shortly to
make a new Queen uh one-way traffic here
maybe the best hope is to go into an end
game but if you need to win that one is
pretty full as well okay wow Fabiano he
was hoping for that capture perhaps and
Hikaru says no I'm not even going to
take you yet I'm going to create some
threats instead just uh I guess black is
tied up why Rush yeah but I think I like
takara's ability to trade the pieces off
now the black queen can slide out to G6
and if you start trying to swap
everything off on C6 I'll bring my Rook
towards the king side maybe Rook to f8
at the end I know it doesn't look good
for black it objectively is not that
good for black but it's not that bad and
E4 is loose maybe I can attack a
sacrifice at some moment so black needs
to win this game keeping the pieces on
the board should help that Quest yeah
keeping the Queens on is a good first
step so maybe a small missed opportunity
for Hikaru as well to uh find the most
decisive uh reply find the most decisive
way to win but uh okay five minutes 40
against three minutes still Fabian is
the one under pressure
and it's just
a bad piece you really really try and
get a trade the white Bishop so that you
can create some threats on the king side
but that's a far away dream he does go
for the idea of a trying to double up on
the file just avoiding as many trades as
possible to keep his chances alive but
currently Hikaru Nakamura up on the
clock and with a dominating position
he's down upon but all the pieces
compare each and every piece that white
has with the black pieces and you know
who stands better here
yep domination you have a bind on the
central squares especially the light
squares I think that's why Hikaru was
reluctant to part with his lights going
Bishop even if he wins the pawn back
because it's such a beautiful piece
so yeah what now that's the question
James yeah that's this is rough this is
where I'm actually just trying to create
something on the king side uh with this
queen and Rook over here but like I'm
just looking at I'm running on through
all the lines double the Rooks Rook F3
but then what do you do after that maybe
like Rook F3 Rook Ace three Queen H5 but
that is just way too far away and it's
also very desperate and like you don't I
mean it doesn't even all the way work
like it's too many things it so many
moves that are available to Hikaru for
this it's very difficult I also I'm also
in time trouble and it's definitely hard
for fobby right now yeah in the meantime
as well Hikaru it's his move how does he
up the pressure how does he do something
productive while Fabi struggles for a
plan that's a good question G3 is too
weak it could just take you know she
sleeps with our whole thing was about
just trade everything down he's gonna go
Rook f8
yeah Robert you said you didn't like
what white was doing I'm stunned to
agree yes I think her car is starting to
agree the fact that he's spending all
this time means that he's like well why
did I make this Choice he could have
swapped off pieces there is no black
attack without pieces on the board but
if that second Rook lands on f8 and
especially if the dark Square bishops
get traded if you could imagine Black's
dark Square Bishop jumping over the Rook
to G5 swapping off these Bishops that is
bad news for white with the second Rook
coming over to f8 so at least there is
some chance here for Fabiano and if the
E4 Pawn Falls if somehow hikar loses
sight of that then black will start
rolling his pawns up the board and will
have some serious chances so you could
tell his car is spending a lot of time
here over two minutes spent on this turn
he may actually finish this move down on
the clock yeah wow hunt about that
missed opportunity for Fabi trading off
those dot Square Bishops at a opportune
moment suddenly it is Hikaru spending
that time and he decides to go for the
trade so actually a variation we showed
quite a while ago on the board which
didn't expect this one to be as
profitable for Hikaru as we thought now
Dodge The Rook trade Fabi you need piece
pieces on if you want to attack if you
want to win
to Hikaru he has conquered the queen
side that's for sure Fabi needs to
switch his focus and there we go on the
other flank now now the question is what
do we even do okay cool perfect
everything's here we got it like yeah
great job but now like what do we even
do for the attack is the hard part now I
mean the main thing that you've got to
do is try and trade off those dark Squad
Bishop that's the only way that you get
the attack going on that but how do you
do that you need that Bishop on the G5
Square to offer a trade maybe step back
with the rook and open up that diagonal
so that the bishop can move forward or
Rook have three Bishops
nice let's show it and uh here there is
a threat on the Central Pawn so one move
I would expect from Hikaru would be
perhaps to drop the queen back and yeah
I was looking at this direction maybe
pushing this Pawn when in doubt push
Harry the H Pawn okay this move on the
board but James you're mentioning Rook
to F3 yeah I think he runs away into D2
believe it or not the king's Just Gonna
Run from Run to the Hills get up out of
there have a nice day right such a nice
idea though I love it it's such a nice
idea right but he just runs away he just
runs but the idea Tanya mentioned just
dropped the Rook back and the idea is to
trade off these dark Square Bishops I
like this one too he might not have
enough time right David because white
can start offering a rook trade on on
that last rank you have to be careful
about the central e-born which holds the
position together though yeah
born right now and
tabiano very quickly decided Harry to
the rescue he's going to push both of
these pawns just to try and create some
type of nuisance against the white king
way to do it takes a while but might
work here it comes it's coming it's
coming and clocks are Level now so again
a complete mess on the board that's the
good news for Fabi Hikaru trying to get
activity on the seventh rank but I don't
see the queen joining The Party The Rook
can't step back and keep everything
under control defend that Bishop
it has to unless you're feeling very
very brave and so it's important forward
towards the white king and there we go
The Rook steps back but now is black in
time to attack that white king can
Hikaru somehow shut down all action
towards that side of the board it's
unclear to be honest I would be nervous
if I'm Hikaru right now partly because
of the clock but partly because momentum
wise again it's turned it looked like
one-way traffic now suddenly he's
looking at his King he's sweating yeah
and black is just trying to push that
pawn in front of the queen in front of
the white king like just open up that
flank so hikara right now is thinking do
I stab black from doing that by pushing
my own Pawn but that could create some
vulnerable light squares a big moment
for Hikaru he is now down under two
minutes they're Queens Rooks all sorts
of pieces staring at the white king this
is actually quite dangerous territory
yeah so the attack just came out of
nowhere we were struggling to find a
plan for Fabi but Fabi doing fabulous
things here and now it is Hikaru who is
down on the clock still worried about
the pawn storm on the king side which
actually could be very dangerous when
you're playing on seconds yeah when you
have no time that's how you get
checkmated even if your position is
objectively good you fall for some
tricks you see ghosts you get scared so
right now you can see hit card knock
where he's leaning in he's thinking do I
push my Jeep on up one square no he
brings his Queen over that allows black
to push his Pawn Yeah it allows the pawn
to push on also the pawn in the center
of the board no longer defended by the
White Queen uh maybe he has some ideas
there but this one super complicated
Fabby how will you react you need to
attack you need to do it now and he just
pushes the pawn G3 got it you gotta push
it yeah you don't even have a choice and
he's running out of time here but he's
still calculating obviously okay G3 but
he shouldn't be calculated no I know
calculation over everything this is one
of those moments where you just have to
go and trust your intuition yep you're
correct it's coming I can feel it G3
will be on the board
let's bring it up one to stockfish what
does the computer say is it only one
move here will he find it black needs to
keep the game going in okay you can also
take the pawn in the center but he goes
for the best move suddenly wait
questions to answer how does Hikaru save
his King this is the best move for the
match if you take that pawn the center
the White Queen would have slid over and
forced the queen trade Bobby needs the
Queens on the board to win and right now
her car is about to go under a minute on
the clock his King is the one that's
more open those Rooks are staring down
the F line I'm getting worried for akara
Nakamura yeah when Edgar was shaking his
head he likes his position but when he's
this serious you know that things are
not going according to his according to
his plan and he tries to block down the
king side but it's three put the other
Pawn forward
both of them look at them Pawns of
pharaoh H3 you see the little palm box
there go with the floors push those
pawns don't think Fabi this is Instinct
all of us have the same instincts throw
points towards the enemy King fabby's
too much in his own head one minute you
can't do this against Hikaru okay he
takes support but now the white king
might actually find safety in the corner
there we go that black pawn is a double
agent it actually helps keep the white
king safe but you gotta get h3n David
Now or Never you have to make that move
to try and create a weakness on the king
side yeah again should not hesitate Fabi
what else is there go for checkmate you
have to yeah the big problem is that
white Rook on the seventh rank is tying
the black Rook down that Rook were to
leave the bishop is loose he plays H3 he
spent too long and looking at Carl he
just quickly brings his own Rook up the
board and I guess trades on G2 Queen's
coming off that only helps hit Carl's
chance he only needs a draw to win the
match nothing wow okay look at that
absolutely nothing
the clocks 25 seconds
but that is not the only problem the
bishop on E7 is hanging he he moves the
queen defends that Bishop
but now no more Checkmate no more attack
that black queen is on the wrong circuit
it's deflected away and white has a move
or two to consolidate around his King
still not easy Let's ignore the
evaluation bar still difficult from a
human point of view but Kyrie blocks it
good decision what do we think
whatever approves and that's the amazing
thing about her car replays these moves
on seconds and it turns out they
absolutely work for him yeah
incredible stuff there yeah defensive
Wizard and like again when you get down
on time I mean it's just like it's so
bad it's ridiculous you get down on time
he's these defense is impeccable then
the calculations start coming out you
blunder because you're in time trouble
it's really hard playing a cardboard and
that Bishop the dog Squad Bishop in
White's position is such a key defender
in these positions because otherwise
black could have snapped up that F Bond
but the bishop keeping everything under
control and wow this is game over now
yeah you said trade it all off yeah look
at Fabi devastated all the pieces off
the board maybe you can hold this one
with a draw if he's on if he's having a
very lucky day but no you're facing
Hikaru and a draw is enough anyway game
over we're going down to that reset
we're getting more chess guys wow well
the best Fabi can do is a draw in this
position and hikai was the one who
forces it with checks along the diagonal
and with that Hikaru would take set one
in today the grand final he does win it
but that levels the match and that means
we're gonna have a great and final reset
with two games it's going to be a best
of two wow what a performance that was
by Hikaru Nakamura there David some very
critical moments in this one some very
critical moments a really high quality
game between these two great Fighters
and I just want to say Fabiano maybe the
one slip he had after conducting a
pretty impressive attack was here he
captured this Pawn allowing the white
king to hide safely in the center in the
corner If instead he had pushed this
Pawn forward it would have been total
chaos a big mess and he would have had
more than his fair share of the chances
however later it was Nakamura who
finished this one off in nice style if
we fast forward to this position a bit
later on the white King still super safe
in the corner it was this blue this
tactic that traded off all the pieces
and won the game Rook takes Bishop a
temporary sacrifice relying on this
skewer at the end after everything
disappeared we saw Nakamura several
pawns up and he won the queen end game
fantastic alertness there by Hikaru at
the very end just wrapping things up and
with that he wins the first match of the
Grand Final what a score line we've got
four decisive games incredible chess and
action this means that we get a grand
final reset will be which will be a best
afternoon I know for the fans the
Armageddon didn't happen in this one but
it might happen in the best of two that
is coming up on the other side of the
switch break
[Music]
introducing World quad the partner of
the Champions chess tour and chess.com
[Music]
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists that sounds very exciting
you put your skills in practice in a
case competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up World Quant is
seeking new talent and new energy and
it's looking at the world of Chess to
help because nobody knows how to analyze
a position better than a chess player
right no Quan experience no problem so
do you think you have what it takes to
compete in the international Quant
championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
[Music]
on Sunday it is going to be time for the
feed a world championship it will be
round one between
is the first Chinese player to fight for
the world championship earlier in the
week I spoke to Deng about his journey
to the world championship
has been a long journey since last July
when I first heard I will play the world
championship Le
an uh well I have played with against
him many times results in pretty much
the equal because I was trying to be
worse yeah I think he had changed a
little bit of his brain style in recent
years because before he's a very
aggressive players but now he's more
well-rounded with the with a very good
preparation
the last World Championship
so it has the experience
also he had win two candidates
and his teams are pretty
big a fixed or I can choose another
words he'll vary on well-round player I
can say we will see each other during
the whole month
have you been able to find time to just
enjoy the moment to have some fun to
unwind I started to spend weekends I
started to have some rest days because
before I think for chess players
arrested and worked there wouldn't be
too much difference between reverse
their work day but now I try to rest on
the rest day on weekends just mentally
preparing yourself for these different
situations during a match is that an
important part of the preparation yeah
because the preparation uh the chest
population is easy to do because you
know
how to prepare the opening and what will
be in reply after my move but the
preparation out of the boards it's not
so easy or it's hard to say how to do it
and you can do it many different ways
you can read a book you can take a walk
or even packaging someone
yeah but
yeah but my way
to prepare mentally is what I said
before
into
take a rest on the weekends are you
excited thing to start on this
very big very new chapter of fighting
for the world championship match yes
we're so excited to see sorry go on I
hope I can
rest of myself in during the tournament
so now I cannot imagine it
what happens if I become the world
champion I only
imagine if I win the world champion then
my my picture will be honed on many
testcraft
it will be a big pleasure for me what do
you feel will be the key factors in a
matchup between Jana Pharmacy and doing
what is the most important aspect of
this match for you I think it's uh to
see the chances as a critical moment
because from the last tournament
especially in the sixth game we can see
the young corporalized in
and then comprised
and it becomes crucial
so I guess during the World
Championships there will be some
especially in time control or time
travel
the prayers will be very nervous
and sometimes the heart rate will reach
very high so you can keep calm and
to see the chances
it appears then I think you will have a
pretty good results and we wish you all
the very best
thank you thank you
such a big moment in dangerous chess
career and there we see his
accomplishments he finished runners-up
in defeated 2022 candidates and with
Magnus Carlsen deciding not to fight for
the world championship title thing
Lauren will be playing against Jana
bombushi it is the fight between wall
number two Yan against wall number three
ding Robert what are the strands here
for for doing what does he need to do to
get by in this one I feel like ding is
subtly aggressive as a chess player you
often see him play pretty solid lines he
can outplay his pawns like he did
against the card Nakamura and the last
one the candidates but if you provoke
him he will definitely strike so he has
much more bite to his chest and
immediately meets the eye yeah I think
he's very Universal as a player I mean
he's played many different openings
actually I remember looking at a lot of
his games because he played King's
Indian a lot of lines that I was like oh
wow ding played this line I would check
it because he was playing it you know so
then he's also uh one of the few people
to hit 2800 people forget that people
forget that dang is was 2 800 right so
only a few people ever hit that right so
he's definitely a very strong and
underrated player to people just kind of
brush off and don't realize how strong
he actually really is yeah ding also had
a 100 game unbeaten streak so uh if you
can bring that phone to the table it's
gonna be hard for never yeah it's gonna
be a very exciting match and at the end
of the month we will have a new world
champion well today we will also have a
new accessible Masters champion this is
the fourth edition of the chessable
Masters traditionally a player hasn't
won it twice in 2020 the first year it
was Magnus Carlsen who took it in 21. it
was Wesley so and it's the current
reigning trustable Masters champion is
dingler and who won it in 2022. today
it's either gonna be
or Fabiano caruana they will play a best
of two just two rapid games if it's a
tie then we will have the Armageddon but
with Hikaru taking that first match is
it Advantage Hikaru with the momentum
well as five in a carwana sweatshirt
says never too much there's never too
much Hikaru and all of his fans out
there are hoping that his win in that
Grand Final he'll be able to reset and
come back with a win by I feel like
Fabiano can take as an entirely new
match even though that one just happened
yeah I mean look at our players it
definitely looks like Hikaru is feeling
a lot more chill and in control right
now we've got a body language expert
James you're with us tell us in fact uh
you can see you can that was funny
actually I do study a lot about the body
language but actually uh um Bobby biting
his nails there is uh showing he's a
little bit nervous he's a little bit
nervous but I think he is he's he's
comfortable but I can tell he's under a
little bit of pressure I mean he just
lost the match there it's a two-game
match and short time controls and these
two two game matches I mean Kara was
very good with this you this is now or
never you have to do this right now the
car was comfortable he's feeling good
you can tell you just you can see that
your car was very comfortable bopping a
little bit looking up doing his usual
stuff as he's very comfortable here Fabi
just has to get it together here and
maybe he'll be able to win a match wow
and it is go time both players will just
have one white Fabby starts with his
white he chooses the English opening
David what do you you make of this
opening Choice by Fabi yeah decent start
solid start this is very topical very
popular among the top players right now
it's a branch of the four nights uh
variation here and white does give away
this Square in the center this Outpost
the D4 square that black has hopped into
immediately but white also has the very
strong but vinix set up uh in the center
so it's very difficult for Hikaru to go
for Pawn breaks and if Fabi can contain
any activity then white does of course
have a space Advantage with all of those
far Advantage pawns very balanced stuff
I personally slightly prefer White's
chances in this opening but black of
course Rock Solid for now definitely
love the space I mean it's the space
thing I mean of course I'm a Kings
Indian player I like playing King's
Indian so we do give up space to be able
to you know strike and do and be
aggressive here which you can still do
that I mean yes you have space but black
has cornbreak C5 A5 right C6 D5 at some
point more than I play F5 so lots of
Pawn breaks but also white has one too
especially if we take with the pawn here
we can actually open up the f file and
play D4 at some point maybe Bishop E2
and open the app file big fan of taking
with a pawn in this situation yeah he's
clearly weighing it up Fabi now okay he
takes with the Queen instead not
damaging his structure ticking with the
pawn would have given great central
control right James right but uh instead
more flexible and white if he gets time
to move his Bishop Castle then he he can
actually choose from some Pawn breaks
himself but we see a new style from
Fabiano caruana the last match was a
roller coaster both sides had their
chances but it was hectic from the very
start here we see a composition all
eight pawns are on the boards for each
side so I feel like for Fabiano he's
reeling a little bit from that last
match he's saying let's just keep this
calm maybe I'll get a slight plus if
hikara plays Super well makes a drop so
be it I'll get the black pieces the two
game match and maybe we will see
Armageddon yeah what a treat that would
be how am I getting uh meanwhile Fabi
just pushing upon getting ready to
fianca so his Bishop uh very solid stuff
and uh James you mentioned some Pawn
breaks some ideas of Pawn pushes for
black but how effective are they in
reality
correct in reality they are not that
effective right now the problem is uh I
mean the pawns are all strong every one
of them are all defended by another Pawn
so if you you know happen to capture or
we get a pawn break in I think probably
the biggest one would be D5 but we have
that really unlocked especially after
the bishop comes to G2 which looks like
an intention of Bobby's here by playing
G3 wants to think cattle the bishop play
F4 at some point maybe even Castle F4 F5
and launch a very big king side attack
by G4 and G5 as well um sort of like a
Kings Inn in Reverse here but definitely
very slow very slow game lots of
maneuvering I mean Etc here yeah I've
got to say I don't see it immediately
for Nakamura for example uh okay he
pushes his C Pawn forward this Pawn
break can be locked down as you
mentioned there James now indirectly
control the square too many times that
square is covered by four white pieces
if you include pawns it's only defended
three times four black I don't think you
have time to prepare it properly either
if the bishop comes out white castles if
you break in the center this will drop
the Central Pawn this one opens up but
where anytime this opens up I do like
the prospect of this white Bishop on the
long diagonal he offers a trade of
Queens instead of breaking with pawns
and the question Alpha Fabi to take or
not to take that is the question to take
or not okay that is the question
um no I'm just not trading Queens here
what about you Robert well if I've ever
answered it and he is in the same way as
you so we have Katie caruana over here
by Queen the D2 I like it he is saying
let's keep the queens of the monthly a
little bit more life in the position
there's no reason to liquidate just yet
and with all the ideas that James was
highlighting with Pawn to F4 now
castling King said get your king to H2
things like that white can strike later
yeah I really like it and actually this
black queen isn't necessarily well
placed yes she offered a queen trade but
she might have to step back Retreat
later on anyway so the loss of time that
was incurred by Fabi there not too
important uh Hikaru trying to strike out
and Fabi says no I'm gonna block it up
your black rook in the corner is not
breaking free no open files for you nice
play by Fabiano here he's giving away
the dark squares however that's the one
downside long term behind White's
strategy and whoa a capture
anti-positional you've got to think
Robert yeah you pause and looked at me
because I was just raising my eyebrows
this is a very shocking move from Hikaru
because he is permanently handed Fabiano
key squares there will be no Pawn breaks
coming from black side and that pawn on
B7 that is a target that white is going
to go after you put a rook on B1 in line
with the queen there and the pawn behind
it and D5 ideas out the window you no
longer repawn on C6 and white has this
clamp on C4 and E4 saying no Pawn breaks
for you I really did not like that move
it may be okay objectively but I think
practically speaking it gives white a
free hand to have all the fun
completely agree I'm not really sure
what hikara is trying here maybe he'll
plant his Bishop on this square and
relocate his Knight round to a decent
Outpost we've got to say okay this has
actually happened on the board but it's
all about Fabiano here he's going to
have access to the semi-open B file
putting pressure there forever we should
reiterate and meanwhile these Pawn
breaks especially the F4 Pawn break will
be in the air later so yes Black's gonna
have a decent piece for example if we
whiz ahead to a position like this one
but one strong piece here the Black
Knight isn't really enough you would
think to balance the position it feels
like white all the way here absolutely
lots of space I love it b-file open
um of course we actually put can we can
move our King off of this diagonal of
course she's hitting the a pawn right
now so that's actually very annoying and
one thing that one thing that Hikaru
knows how to do is be very annoying
right so Queen takes A3 is a thing and
if you play A4 there might be a knight
B6 in some cases and now we're just
hitting the Palm once again making you
defend it it's very annoying to face him
right there's a weakness maybe just go
A1 but then it's not the move I want to
play I don't want to play A4 either
because Knight B6 does attack the pawn I
have to defend it once again so yeah
there's some questions here that need to
be answered yeah big questions and it's
all about a simple Pawn that lonely Pawn
on A3 is uh causing Carolina a headache
right now I think he's gonna defend it
with his Queen oh wow he defends it with
the Rook instead e-084 Rook B4 that's
cute that's cute yeah now the black
queen will move in the next couple of
turns and the Black Knight will replace
it on the Square gaining time against
White's Rook but solid stuff from
Fabiano do we think Hikaru will lash out
at some points as well on the other side
of the board maybe with F5 himself it
looks unlikely but otherwise black is
just going to be passive for the rest of
the game there are some players who are
really good at just defending passively
and it's not fun but some players just
know that objectively the position is
fine they just have to do pretty much
nothing if you play that F5 move that
David asked about that is going through
hikaru's head he's like can I actually
gain some space for myself push my Pawn
down 5 but white I think can immediately
snap that off and then you see the
bishops come in contact with each other
the Knight for white has D5 and E4 to
look at the pawn on B7 still a Target in
the position and I feel like black isn't
really getting an attack and they have
compromised some key Square so F5 I know
why you want to play it I just think
that it might make Black's defensive
task even harder yep I agree now it
definitely isn't the moments and Hikaru
okay head in hands what else is he going
to come up with the queen is occupying
the square the Knight wants to use but
if you slide her back forward then she
will end up on a very passive square and
we will see for sure at some point in
the next few turns the white king move
and this Pawn starter motor down the
board okay he just gets ready for
anything to open up in the center but
now notice how black has no Pawn breaks
The Rook will no longer support that
move yes and with that move
also also does threaten to fall back
with the Knight Retreat only to go
forward we have been talking about dark
Squad weaknesses and Hikaru finds
another path to the center of the board
a little night maneuver there as you
were pointing out this is such an
important match for Fabiano caruana
especially game for him because he
starts with the white pieces he can't
let it go out of control he says let
alone out of control I'm going for an
attack
hinting at an F4 break will Hikaru be in
time with that Knight maneuver or will
Fabi strike first in the center
I like fabi's choice he's at least
hinting he's not necessarily going to
strike out but he's hinting uh that he
will push pawns and Fabio will be
reeling he'll be angry he wants to push
forward of course but uh yeah Tanya
you're right will Nakamura just calmly
maneuver around I wouldn't be capable
here I would be laughing out I would be
wanting to do something create threats
for black but maybe you're right maybe
we show this night maneuver on the board
yeah very sophisticated F4 oh yeah
definitely looking like F4 is going to
be nice here for um for Fabi so if you
go Knight f8 then F4 96 F5 Knight D4 F6
Knight takes Queen G5
and Checkmate coming James and we live
baby boy absolutely getting off the
board please correct so there's a May
here so I'm just about to push this Pawn
all the way through because we don't
care about anything else right mate ends
the game so F4 five F6 is the plan yeah
uh you've basically uh showed off very
instructively what White's plan is just
one two three Checkmate that's it there
you go very simple very simple guys but
calculation over everything you showed
it though come on man and uh yeah
Nakamura is going to be calculating that
variation realizing that actually black
is in a bit of a hurry right now you
kind of allow this Pawn to step forward
too much further otherwise uh the black
king will start to sweat nice move by
Fabiano ah he's looking at all of that
because that is the plan to get the
Knight to the center of the game but as
James you pointed out the attack just
seems faster all you need is a pawn and
a queen to give Checkmate who cares
about a rook and it looks like wow
Hikaru burning the clock there a little
bit getting close to two minutes Sabi I
see the value bar it says it's pretty
level but hey Carlos says I'm ready for
the attack Bring It On falls back with
the Knight how is he countering F4 I
think he's gonna play F6 after I mean
fine go be tripping there absolutely
never play F6 right but F4 F6 actually
and then but then there's an F5 and
maybe G4 G5 there so we still have this
attack that we can do but F4 I think is
still very playable here and F6 is kind
of annoying but then okay you want 96
cool so we'll lock it up play F5 no more
96 now we want G4 G5 I mean I have Rook
G1 coming Bishop Roberts not a Jew I'm
just looking in this position because I
agree with you I'm like look at this if
this is a Blitz game we say white wins
there's like 80. correct because the
attack plays itself you just throw your
pawns at the board bring that Rook lift
and you go so James I'm loving the look
of this for Fabi it reminds me of game
one in the Grand Final he ended up
losing that game right but he was in
control he stole a pawn I think Fabi
he's just in Command right now
definitely he just needs to play F4 and
pass the move back to Hikaru saying the
pressure's on you I'm coming for for you
I'm coming for your king I'm gonna
attack whatever you do and uh yeah he's
in his own head Fabiano do you remember
the last game where he had some very
natural attacking moves he had pretty
much no options yes it was a difficult
position but he didn't trust this
Instinct he spent one two minutes on
moves and it kind of came back to bite
him later on you might go through this
actually so F4 right F4 take it I mean
that's kind of tough maybe we go embed
to know you know in between the move
doesn't work so he takes on F4 right
after F4 takes the G takes then 96 the
idea here is now after F5 I check first
King back
now F6 G5 doesn't work anymore so now I
can go Knight D4 and then Rook move
somewhere and then like it's different
then I can play F6 I mean this is still
there if I get the knight at least I get
the Knight to D4 yeah I can move the
Rook back but at least I can get the
knights D4 and it's it kind of
neutralizes you a little bit I got some
squares here but he went F6 yeah he went
F6 and now you'll move James I love it
not just to start a pawn storm not just
to kind of throw these pawns forward but
also just to just completely kill this
Black Knight where's this Knight coming
out to now and it's on the board the
night has to go back hanging its head in
shame back where it came from he's lost
two moves two very important moves
Nakamura and
very simple play throw this Pawn forward
he's done it Fabi he's coming for that
King and you've got to say love White's
position I don't love White's Bishop but
the rest of his position perfect usually
when you get a position like this black
has some sort of counter play either a
pawn break on the flank or in the center
black has neither of those options from
a very early stage of this game when
Hikaru took that pawn on B5 there were
several moves ago so we're looking at
this position we see white with a free
hand on the king side and Hikaru he's
staring at this position it's good that
he has nine minutes on the clock because
if he had say three minutes on the clock
I think he just gets steamrolled on the
king side White's pawns just start
pushing there's a real clip that Rook on
B3 May slide backwards and then towards
the king side and deliver then the death
nail so I just feel like this is a big
problem for Hikaru he needs some sort of
active plan and where is that going to
come from yeah Hikaru in the last two
moves has done nothing meanwhile fabi's
spawn storm has started on the king side
with the clear threat towards that black
king this is going to be a big trouble
for Hikaru he still needs to find time
to get that Knight into the game by now
it should have arrived to that Central
Square far away from that are we
expecting the H Pawn as well to go down
the board open up the G file is it
really that simple open up the G file
double up the rook and queen go for the
G7 Square yeah you said it Tanya simple
and I'm not saying it's a simple win far
from it I'm saying the plan is simple
and in Rapid chess that's what you want
right from a human point of view Let's
ignore the evaluation bar it's clear
what Fabi wants what does Hikaru want
we're really uncertain here in the
studio and that's why he spent a long
time okay he moves his Rook up yes
but I like it James because he wants to
shine trade David the Rooks on B6 that
white Rook defends the entire Queen side
get rid of it so Fabi creating his
chances there
uh yeah Hikaru uh trying to trade off
those Rooks actually exchanges
definitely helped because white is the
one trying to attack if you know your
opponent is coming for you get pieces
off the board it will make your king
safer long term so nice move from Hikaru
it's a very good move in fact a lot of
these plans you guys love to give
everyone in the chat accessible courses
to actually go and grab actually from
these authors here Simon Williams
actually this position is literally
looks exactly like a bavenic English the
Knight on C3 the pawns on C4 D3 E4
Bishop on G2 in fact there's many plans
that they cover in the model game
sections of that scores that's called
The Bop a nickname English actually star
is called iron English by Simon Williams
you actually do have a lot of these
plans are very similar right you do put
the bishop or you play you you play at
four or five you play G5 you want to go
for this King side of tie but after this
Rook A6 move with Rook B6 coming here it
is kind of annoying I'm not even gonna
lie I do actually I'm thinking about
sacking the A3 Pawn by like actually
just removing the Rook from B3 and going
back around because I do want to keep it
but the fact is he does have a past Pawn
so like I want to go Rook B1 and after
Rook BC or Rook B1 and after he takes it
yeah engine goes the eval bar is like
yeah you're giving up this Pawn but now
I just want to go Rook G1 and I'm just
going for an all-out mate here Bishop F3
go G5 right yeah you're gonna have the
pawn but I mean you stole the pawn here
you had to not waste time but you had to
take it it cost time you had to take it
your queen is away from the King side so
I actually do have some real chances
here for checkmate yeah I love it James
and uh here Fabiano rightly is spending
a lot of time if he does decide to
sacrifice a pawn just to keep Rooks on
the board then he has to be sure move by
move that it is worth it uh for example
if he starts the attack now if he plays
Rook to G1 this is hikara's idea he will
trade these Rooks off after a rook
capture I'm not sure which way he'll
take let's say with the Knight and
suddenly the attack might be less potent
yes you can push this Pawn forward but
Black's Rook will be ready to defend and
you have to again be sure that you're
breaking through so okay actually he's
gone for a night retreat Rook trade
imminent there we go they're off the
board and is this Knight going this
direction perhaps towards the black king
nice exactly where he's going yeah
bringing another piece into the attack
is Fabiano caruana it may backfire he
may lose his Queen side and that could
cost him but he wants to bring that
Knight right over to the king side bring
it as an attacker rather than sitting
idly by on the queen side so I think
practically speaking it makes a lot of
sense but at Carl he's perked up a bit
here he's saying you're not going to
Checkmate me and if you don't I actually
have some chances down on the left hand
side of the board yeah he could not
start bringing the queen and the Knight
to that square targeting not only the A3
weakness but also the D3 weakness that
white has to deal with well hecaro is
creating a lot of threats surprisingly
goes back with the queen doesn't enter
towards a fabby's side of the board
Queen C5 this is a move that surprises
you yes if you wanted your queen on the
Square why didn't you capture with the
Black Knight on the last move very
strange stuff you've got to say but
maybe his ideas to open up lines does he
want to push the black B Pawn forward of
course he's attacking whites Pawn in the
corner there as well I'm surprised I've
got to say by nakamura's calmness I
would be panicking I would be freaking
out looking at all those white pawns
marching towards the black king but uh
he's a great defender we all know that
and he believes in Black's defensive
resources he's gonna have to show it
though he has to show I mean he's an
excellent Defender one of the greatest
we've ever seen sometimes like how did
you defend that because Hikaru he just
does right so I think he does believe in
his defensive chances here which I kind
of believe it too as well because there
is a rook E7 and you kind of can even go
King f8 in some cases even you know
petrogen king walk to C7 in some time so
it is possible but I mean man it's very
difficult and also time I mean we have
time so it's not like we're low on time
um but yeah he's going for it and here
we go and here we go we will go into the
jungle Rob are you ready you ready here
I I'm ready you're ready I'm not sure if
five and a car one is ready he's just
throwing all his pieces up the board
here but I I was saying it could
backfire and I think Fabiano's gonna
regret not closing down the queen side
he gave up a pawn I think he has an
attack but earlier on he probably could
have kept his Pawn kept his Knight in
the game but instead he shifted gears
and he really wants to win but I don't
know about this and the eval Bar says no
no no this is all good for Hikaru you've
got to jump up with the Knight now right
you have a big threat with the Knight
coming to H5 Hikaru has one move to try
and get his pieces into defense how are
you fighting the idea of the Knight and
queen joining the attack Knight coming
in trade on G5 attack on the G5 I love
it I love that idea
kind of aesthetic point of view for
Hikaru yeah Carolina here will not trade
he's going to run away with his Queen
but where that's the question this
game's gonna end in one or two ways
either Black's gonna win the end game
he's got an extra Pawn he's got the kind
of long-term advantages with better
pieces or what's going to Checkmate it's
one of those two it's not gonna end in a
draw this one and David the Queens are
coming it is coming to the king side
either on the G5 lining up with the king
or one step ahead attacking that EA
truck so the attack on the king side
it's building up how dangerous is it
gonna be very surely Black's Queen now
heading back does she want to go the
whole way around takes her two or three
moves to go and defend her King the
knights are coming the pawns are rolling
this one looks so scary it's definitely
scary here but I still don't see the
kill shot this is so hard like yeah he
gets back like he gets back unbelievable
defense it's it's like ridiculous like
somebody checking how does he do this
right the difference is really really
impeccable and just that intuition as
well he's took that pawn on A3 without
thinking too long about it then
immediately brings his Queen back he
made like six Queen moves in a row and
they're all good moves so what Fabiano
needs to do is blast open the king
sudden attack but as we see based on the
evaluation bar and Hikaru Nakamura
locked in and reading this position
black is actually objectively better
because you don't have that many pieces
for white to deliver a Checkmate yeah
you were talking about six Queen moves
on the way that Queen picked up a pawn
and then went back to defense so some
really nice Queen play that by Hikaru
Bobby again taking a lot of time in this
critical moment while he's taken about a
minute right now he needs to bring the
rook and the queen to join that night
with the attack he starts with The Rook
are we expecting the queen to jump as
well on the g-file the White Queen needs
to join at some point I think the reason
White's Advantage oh sorry White's
attack is not breaking through is
because look at the white Bishop it
cannot break through past its own pawns
it cannot join the attack in any way so
white is essentially playing without
that piece if White had a dark squared
Bishop instead of light Square Bishop I
think actually this attack would be
decisive but unfortunately for Fabi his
own piece gets in the way you want to
pick up this white bishop and kind of
throw it off the board at this point but
uh yeah it just takes too long and
remember that black apron potential game
winner if he survives the next few moves
Nakamura he's going to win this game
oh yeah it just looks like fabi's attack
is a few moves to shot you want to pick
up that Bishop as James is saying as
David is saying and put it on that E6
square if you can and that would be
great compensation Hikaru mean while
keeping everything defended speaking of
the bishop is it eyeing to get to that
square where the Knight is or does he
just simply want to double up the queen
and the Rook on the G file on the next
move
it was a little bit of both in fact I
actually was wanted to actually put the
bishop where the Knight is I actually
wanted to go Bishop H5 but I was trying
to get it to work a calculation is tough
you need a lot of time to actually work
these things out I wanted to go Bishop
H5 Bishop G6
exactly exactly right Knight takes G7
something like that in there but it's
just like my pieces are trampling over
each other the bishop Knight and the
queen just don't coordinate the way that
we want it to right now and we're having
problems with that so it's very
difficult and it's Rook G8 on the board
wow he played Rook G8 and then Queen D2
played so what's the idea here I don't
think there is one for white sadly no I
mean you just don't have a breakthrough
because if you're let's say black pushes
the a pawn and white plays G6 just to
show what this looks like Black's not
taking that pawn that opens up your own
King you could even potentially leave
the pawn there in some variations or
push it forward to H6 and there's no
breakthrough if that Bishop was on E3
rather than F3 white wins instantly we
just go sack the bishop for the pawn we
deliver Checkmate but you can't bring
more pieces in to the attack of that
pawn and that means that black has
closed the king side for good attention
goes to the queen side that would be
game yeah I just love the fact that
Carter is so calm he puts his Rook on a
terrible square but it's a necessary
Square he's completely defended his King
and if there's no breakthrough then this
Pawn of course will win the game long
term
uh he knows when to kind of switch Pace
switch gears I can't even go so strong
he's going to try Knight G3 Bishop H5
Bishop G6 but then I have to go 90s I
have so many moves to make Knight G3
like Queen D Play Bishop D1 here but
Knight G3 Queen D1 then Bishop H5 then
Bishop G6 then Queen H5 that's like five
you may not make it that much that long
here it feels like he's in defense mode
yeah when you're trying to attack and
you have to make a retreating move with
the bishop like that you know the attack
has gone wrong yeah Bishop D1 isn't
headed towards black king
yeah Bishop D1 is no fun that's the Run
and uh yeah Hikaru it's not clear how he
actually goes and wins this game yet he
doesn't want to rush with the black a
pawn because it might just fall off the
board it doesn't want to advance on its
own you first need to bring your pieces
out I think maybe that's the hurdle for
Hikaru to overcome how to combine the
pushing of that pawn with his defense he
needs to keep kind of one eye on the
king one eye on that pawn and that could
be uh the potential practical issue for
Hikaru here meanwhile Fabi he might just
put that Bishop he's going to maneuver
it kind of zigzag it round to the A2
Square in front of that black pass Pawn
that Bishop wool act as a blocker and
watch out for the diagonal opening up
first he improves the queen Hikaru
Nakamura no how is he so calm how does
he just go on this little Queen dance
picks up upon places his Rook on the
right Square for the defense Hikaru an
incredible attacker as well as a
Defender he's just doing everything
right in today's match where do you beat
this guy how do you beat this guy well I
think for Fabiano it was game one in the
Grand Final he was up a pawn there was
not really any compensation for ikaru
then in the time trouble it got away
from him so for Fabiano he had his
chances and Hikaru just started playing
better and better since that game and in
games three and four well uh Fabiano you
know he lost those in the Grand Final
here in the first game of the reset he
has chance to survive so let's not count
Fabiano out because the a pawn isn't
moving so quickly we actually see the
eval bar it's hovering back towards the
middle of course black with the
advantage but it's going a little bit
back towards the middle and how is the
car actually going to promote that pawn
because his Rook is tied down to the
defense on the king side
yeah the thing is uh Carolina might just
be reduced to waiting at some point okay
I know just as I call it he leaps
forward with his Queen but uh what is
that threatening I don't see It'll have
the exact same expression he's like I
don't see it either David what is that
what are you doing it feels like the
wrong side of the board yeah it doesn't
threaten anything I mean this doesn't do
anything maybe just he's trying to scare
the opponent that's where over the board
an online chest differ this is kind of a
long move and over the board chest you
push your queen over to your opponent's
side you look at them in the eye you see
okay that's a scary move for you to face
online chess you look around you're like
wait what are you doing nothing right
well I mean he actually is hitting the
pond I guess that's the only thing he's
doing maybe he wants to take the pawn
here but can you actually take this Pawn
I mean I also have nice C5 like with
tempo right it's gonna happen I think
James
that black knight is going to start
hopping forward at some point in the
near future that might be what he's
doing 95 May backfire because we mean it
to analyzes the bit because that night
whoa yeah I know she's six he pushes the
part in front of his own King yeah I
don't care about nothing it's the best
move what the heck he's so good he's so
good at thinking on the Fly things
change this was never on his radar last
move while the White Queen was in the
center as soon as the opponent plays an
odd looking move his uh yeah his radar
he's immediately sensing okay I've got
to punish you and suddenly he's playing
on the opposite flank to where that
White Queen is just run to nice move
he's been on the defense David how many
players in the elite world would have
this move even on their radar where your
king is weak it's under attack for the
last 10 moves and you're the one who's
opening up that side because you
immediately realize that one of White's
key pieces has gone to the other side
the queen side and is it Hikaru Now
who's on the attack yeah you ask how
many players in the elite world it's
only the players in the elite part that
come up with that one and now look at
the White Knight it's been forced to
retreat or not a move Fabiano wants to
play and actually the black queen is
coming towards that white king white has
lost a second Pawn
oh my God Queen H4 it's coming in this
one is brutal I'm surprised the
evaluation bar is still saying still not
saying it's winning I think that the
white king can slide over right now
before it's checked and then the white
Rook will slide to its starting Square
this is actually to turn around the car
made that move with emphasis you saw him
kind of sit up in his chair bro it's a
king slides and The Rook gets H1 that
black king could actually be in some
danger so I'm not so sure about that
last move he played it quite quickly but
Hikaru he is filling the position
although Fabi did bring the king over
great move suddenly yeah three result
game still uh in store for us if Hikaru
doesn't switch up he needs to go from
defense to attack and now back to
defense he's won two pawns but is it
enough white still has threats and also
watch out for this queen dropping back
switching Focus switching angles and in
towards the black king
and we saw Hikaru there I think he just
realized that the smooth King G2 by
Fabiano is such a strong move and now
again he has to switch up the girl and
look at a way to hide his own King this
is becoming a bit of a race to each
other saying no one would have thought
that that would be the turn that this
game would take well what do you do do
you bring up your own King right now do
you hide it on the G file how do you how
do you counter look H1 I'm just happy
that Hikaru and Fabiano are playing this
because I don't know because that King
both Kings look like they're in grave
danger wide open so finding the correct
move here when they're both about to dip
under three minutes it's not easy I
think we're gonna see that eval bar
seesaw a bit Yeah The Players don't have
access to that evaluation bar so they
have no idea what the evaluation is and
actually Hikaru after this last move
maybe he's panicking his side suddenly
he's down around two and a half minutes
as well
we know that he's a favorite if it if
the clock ticks down but this is not the
type of position you can play on
Instinct it's pure calculation and this
is anybody's game it's very precise very
Precision is required here I mean I can
take on G6 and if I do that then my
knight gets to F5 pieces get active
working go to H1 Queen comes back to D2
there are really really big problems
actually for both sides I mean my Kings
week two on G2 so I mean there's a
problem but I think black's a little bit
weaker even though the eval bar
practical chances definitely are for
both sides while taking Rook H1 what is
he gonna play Rick G5 or H4 so brave
definitely not H4 wow he can 95 Ace
three can't you think what is going on
bro calculator
what's happening
playing with fire picks up the H5 Pawn
Fabi in return also picks it up with his
Knight the H file is open are we
expecting for Abby's Queen to actually
come back to the D2 square and enter the
attack from the other side of the board
ah yes we are and I think at this
position we're now hikar down to two
minutes this is scary there may only be
a move or two that keep black better I
wonder if we could bring up the
suggestion because this is looking quite
worrisome for the black king in the
corner and Rook H1 being the threat we
see Queen D and queen G5 both give black
a huge Advantage but the third best move
actually cuts into that edge and that
would give white some chances wow the
first move we've got to say queen to d8
I don't think that's gonna be played
yeah exactly exactly feels like it's
forcing the White Queen back where it
came from and back to threaten Checkmate
in one move but the idea here is to
swing The Black Queen back with Tempo
any Queen traits favor Black extremely
difficult there the second move I could
imagine being played by Hikaru Nakamura
but the idea after this Rook slide Maybe
that is more difficult it looks like a
deadly move here A Deadly check but okay
he goes for something else he goes for
another option moving his Rook instead
and suddenly this is turning evaluation
bar back to the center Black's King
coming under Fire also watch out for
this Pawn dropping in the near future
that was a bad move according to our
eval bar and Fabi calmly and Cooley just
Retreats with the Knight first the A4
Pawn hanging on one side of the board
The Rook threatening to give a check on
the other side of the board yeah
multiple flanks you have to worry about
here black slides his Queen back but
again are you going to be able to keep
your king safe who's going to be able to
keep their King safe so many questions
to answer this one's in the balance
Anything Could Happen Fabi with 30
seconds more that could be vital later
on oh Knight F5 is a huge blunder yeah
huge blender on the spot getting off the
board 9-5 Queen takes F5 instant win
maybe you have Rook if one then Knight
F5 or Rook check I mean but you have to
you gotta move and it has to be soon
here yeah Fabiano he has let his clock
run too low on several occasions and he
just has to play with the flow of the
position his position is objectively
worse I think he feels that but he's
just trying to give himself some counter
play he gives a quick check the king
slides over and what's the follow-up
yeah not easy suddenly the White Queen
is stuck in limbo she kind of wants to
retreat switch sides but she also needs
to keep an eye on that black apron which
could decide the game later
Fabi it's actually hard for him right
now I like nakamura's Rook that black
Rook is ready it's flexible it can jump
across to trade off any time and Fabi
just setting up just posting up his
pieces in the black half but a
mysterious one no threat that I can see
he's taking control of the F5 Square we
were just talking about how the Knight
can't jump there David and he's just
reinforced the defense so he really
wants to get the Knight or The Rook to
that F5 square and now Hikaru uses this
chance to defend his own a pawn bringing
the Knight into the attack are we
expecting a jump on that F5 uh square
that we've been pointing out that's a
big threat Knight takes Pawn that black
knight is attacking the white Depot on
the base of White's Pawn chain and then
the Black Knight is hopping over towards
the white king I don't know if you have
time to jump forward with white pieces
Fabi needs to step back maybe start
retreating yeah oh okay he hits the
black queen first forces the queen away
you have one check but is that just a
check with no follow-up yeah the White
Queen can step up to the top of the
board to the top corner and hit the
black king but I think that can be
blocked by Black's bishop or queen yeah
looks like certainly hikaru's everything
under control the A4 Pawn is defended
white could have taken that before all
of Black's Palms are defended and white
has his weakness on D3 that's about to
be captured Fabiano he makes a move to
protect that part but he is down under
30 seconds and look at how quickly
Hikaru plays yeah he's really stepped up
another gear he's upped his speed and
that black knight is hopping towards
that white king a check is incoming
still two pawns up as well for black I
think Hikaru has this one almost in the
bag and the white king shifts the night
is coming it's coming we've been talking
about the Black Knight landing on the
dark squares and it has found its way
the ponds also still live night before
hitting that Rook hitting that Bishop on
E2 the attack is on Fabi in big trouble
it looked like white was getting the
attacking chances but Hikaru again turns
things in his favor he's the one
attacking now and surely it feels like
there's a breakthrough the white king
defenseless the White Queen too far away
she was distracted and it never got back
in the game what is the next step for
Hikaru right now
that's a great question right oh he
played Bishop D7 wow what a move oh
strange man very strange I mean what was
better than that I mean very bad
anything or feel like anything queen f8
queen F6 500 just doesn't have time so
he had to react instantly but Bishop D1
not a bad move because it's not clear
where Black's attack is going to come
from let's not forget about the eighth
rank that if the black queen gives a
check and leaps forward there will be a
last ranked check against the black kid
so he steps up with his King there and
that's a great move yeah nice move once
you spot the opponent's plans you can
react in advance take away their threats
uh before they even happen and Fabi will
be disappointed by that one the black
king is super safe now and he Knight
checks the white can flick in will just
be captured off the board and Fabi does
the same just getting out of the line of
checks before they happen preemptively
what was that cute
but the bishop can slide back home and
The Rook is going to team up but wow the
car was just zigzagging with his pieces
whoa broken in the night has broken
through that white Rook attacked horns
attacked stepping backwards yeah and one
there's no check Knight of two okay oh
it takes but then Queen the eighth oh
gosh
where is the Checkmate it feels like
black is winning
The Rook uh side steps goodness this is
crazy
nice yeah shutting down the attack
offering a queen trade you can't take it
the end game is Dead lost Knight F2
check the Rook is pinned on H2 that
means that white can't take it and after
the trades it's over you see the piece
comes off the board after Queen F2 check
I think Fabio is resigning and he has he
does and the fist pump from Hikaru
Hikaru celebrates that what a game what
moves in time scramble that was some
amazing chess we saw in the last few
seconds it was just unbelievable skill
from Hikaru Nakamura he breathed the
sigh of relief he is pumped and he just
did such amazing work with such little
time on his clock yeah and he should be
pumped because he needs just a draw in
the next game to win The chassisable
Masters what around this was so much
attack so much to learn from David take
it away yeah and Hikari he kept control
when it mattered and he deserved to take
the win in the end this position we were
talking about twists and turns Fabiano
had set up some defenses around the king
but those were simply an illusion here
Hikaru jumped forward with the black
queen remember black is also a pawn up
so any Queen traits will favor him for
example these pawns stepping forward
winning the game but after Fabi dodged
the queen trade this was the killer blue
Knight in with a check making full use
of this pin the king had to move a rook
trade and the final quiet killer move
Knight takes Bishop making use of the
fact that Queen takes Knight deflects
away the White Queen from the defense
and this check wins the White Knight the
king steps back black gets greedy and
wins the game Hikaru takes the point
that is next level defense are you
kidding me I mean with that time right
he had no time basically I mean every
time father got in time trouble too he
was still so accurate defended like an
absolute beast and now he's won half a
point away from clinching the whole
thing
knows when to go on the attack he knows
when to go on the defense and he does it
has to strike and he has to strike big
he needs to win the next game with the
black pieces to level the score to take
it to the Armageddon this is a big
moment in the chaserable Masters the
game that's coming up do not miss that
we'll be right back
foreign
carwana famously had a 7 out of seven
start in the 2014 sinkhole cup he also
challenged Magnus Carlson for the 2018
World Chess Championship title how does
a player get there you might ask for
five out of carwana it is feared opening
preparation he is a theoretician like no
other in this 2016 game from the London
chess classic Fabiana Carr won a
demonstrate how deep his opening
preparation can go with the white piece
against Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru
sacrifices a knight temporarily with
Knight takes G4 after Fabiano takes this
Knight on G4 with his Bishop hikara
looks to win back the piece with E5
hitting the queen and the Knight with
his Pawn but Fabiano caruana was a man
on a mission he says you're not going to
get your piece back I'm going to
sacrifice my queen on F6 and after the
bishop took the queen he puts his Knight
on D5 the queen slides back because
under attack as the bishop to d8 and he
plays Knight F5 getting two pieces for
the queen but with a dominant positional
Advantage he went out to win this nice
game and just a great demonstration of
his excellent and deep opening
preparation
[Music]
I'll mine on a mission that is what Fabi
is right now these are the most played
openings in the chessable Masters and we
see
the Sicilian and Royal Affairs at the
top there wow well these are the most
played openings but Robert are you
expecting any one of them in the next
game I think we will not see the Spanish
in this game we will have to see a
sicilian that's what Fabiano played when
he needed a victory in the fourth game
of the Grand Final so I think you'll
have to do more of the same but I do not
expect hikar Nakamura to repeat the
Smith more that was a little bit too
adventurous
yeah I completely agree you cannot go
for anything too solid if you're Fabiano
caruana no Roy Lopez you have to gamble
has to be a sicilian how will Nakamura
react to the Smith Mora was a brave
Choice fortune favors the brave but he
doesn't need to be brave anymore half a
point will clinch it with everybody give
us an exciting chess I mean he has to
win so he's going to bring out you know
you got to take risks you have to at
this point for me to send this to
Armageddon we're going to have to to
take some risk here and see what Bobby
does
and there is the golden ticket to the
Champions chest or final hikaru's won
four games I don't even know how many of
them have been with the black pieces
crazy the white with four Fabi in the
next one he does start with the black
pieces as well what are we expecting you
know it sounds like it's a good thing
just based on the history but I think
we're just experiencing some recency
bias having the white pieces is the
advantage here I know it doesn't seem
that way but for Hikaru Nakamura he just
has to play solo chess not play for a
draw that's how you often get in bad
positions but I think he should play
something a little more solid than a
pawn sacrifice
looks like Hikaru Nakamura has been on
top of his game today he came into the
Grand Final having to beat Fabi twice he
did it once and now he does lead in the
final the Grand Final reset Hikaru
Nakamura starts with the white pieces
and he needs just a draw to win The
chessable Masters we've got another
Sicilian on the board and the key moment
he goes for again giving up a point
again the Smith Mora James
well this hey look we gonna put in the
words of you Carl he literally don't
care he just don't care I mean he needs
to play salad he went for a Smith Maura
here with the bishop B2 line again
repeating the same line that was
hilarious to me I'm not even gonna lie
yeah fabi's the first one to switch it
up we did not see this last time the
Black Knight landing on this E7 Square
it looks a bit clumsy but it will move
again to free the black dot Square
Bishop black is a pawn up top after all
so uh good start for the game for Fabi
yeah in the first game Fabi used his
Queen side Rook Pawn just put that up a
square instead of developing his pieces
now he's prioritizing the minor piece
development as David just said that
night on E7 it sits in front of the
bishop the Queen the king it looks
awkward and wow a car trying to put the
car is playing like he's the one who
needs to win it's not good I was just
gonna say who needs to play for a win in
this match right now what is going on
yeah he's four is a nice move because
the idea here is Knight to G6 a lot of
times Bishop G5 and F6 is Theory then
when you move the bishop it's Knight G6
but H4 he understands the theory which
is very nice when you understand a
theory or not even just a theory which
it wants to do then where's the Knight
want to go the G6 so you actually do
want to you know be annoying to it but I
think black can maybe even just play D5
yeah I think that would be the
principled move it would follow
conventional chess wisdom white is
playing on the flank so black should
Strike Back in the center and I'm sure
picar has studied that before otherwise
he wouldn't play such a move so quickly
H4 but uh what could be wrong here maybe
the recent Fabiano is hesitating is we
could see a bunch of exchanges in the
center and maybe white has a way to win
the pawn back I don't see it yet but uh
trades might end in a draw eventually
really really creative stuff from Hikaru
must be engine approved Alpha zero would
love it but uh yeah to us
is it too brave that's the question I
think Favi should love it I I know I
keep saying this but he needs to win the
game so he may lose it but it's the same
as a draw so for Fabiano caruana you see
this kind of awkward play on the king
side strike in the center and try to
play from there but what Fabio doesn't
want is to trade too many pieces so
that's what he's undoubtedly worried
about if he plays D5 will we see some
trades there will it make White's life
easier I don't think so because that
pawn on H4 maybe in some variations
would hope that it could be pushed back
yeah it sticks out like a sore thumb
this uh this Pawn if we do see exchanges
so wow Fabi just steps one square
instead
I am not so sure about that one it looks
a bit timid and doesn't deal with the
issue of that black knight sitting in
front of the black king you need to get
it out the way somehow that's why I
wanted to open up the center create some
squares for that night but this move
feels a bit Here There and Everywhere
feels like it's just a step in the wrong
direction correct the problem is like
where do I put my pieces is when I'm
asking like where do I put the pieces or
at least it's Knight on E7 I mean or
didn't I have to figure out where I put
the bishop as well I mean it was
actually actually uh Hikaru had a
situation like this against uh Wesley so
in the cgc and I mean your girl got
crushed it was he played a modern and it
was a very very very bad mom I think you
might remember that game as right where
he just got crossed here but he was just
playing just trying to you know his
pieces never got out and Wesley was able
to just have a excellent position here
this reminds me of that because the
Knight on E7 has nowhere I mean you
can't go to G6 and E5 but that's going
to be a trade I also grab a lot of space
after H5 and maybe even play H6 and it's
a very fun position as white here Queen
B3 I'm going to play Bishop E3 or F4
maybe even of G5 to provoke a weakness
and Castle Queen side believe it or not
here and just really playing like I'm
the one that needs to win at all costs
wow just to show that James really
creative stuff I'm not really sure what
black wants to do here but if white does
get time move the bishop Castle Queen
side put the white king actually over
here on the B1 Square where you're super
safe and uh yeah big attack for white I
really don't like the positioning sorry
not that one of this Knight and uh Fabi
that's why I don't like his last move
here if it were black to play if you
just showed me this position for the
first time I might even play D5 but of
course he won't do that he's lost a move
he's lost a Tempo with that pawn uh
maybe he has to go round this way into
the center as you mentioned but that's
provocative stuff and wow we do see this
position on the board James the prophet
he called it cost of quintite hey I
understand aggressive positions shout
out to my grandfather Tao and Uncle NES
Medina absolutely of course that's
Rashid NES Medina which was tau's
trainer of course if you don't know what
that is there's a great book The
Greatest attacker in Chester talks about
Russia and esmer Dino who was Taos
trainer so very strong server of Chess
after 95 which could be played
especially what I want to do here with
wise play H5 force you to play 95 trade
on E5 play F4 and then really just go at
you aggressive chest here play F5 play
E5 play Everything five right all my
pieces are coming at you it's a very
very ugly position I think for black
already my pawns look at my Bishops if
it's black here they both hit brick
walls I have not developed and white has
connected the Rooks already I'm taking
white in every position it looks like
Black's down like four turns yeah you're
up a pawn but you've developed none of
your pieces White's already Castle the
queen is out all four minor pieces are
working together for Hikaru Nakamura so
I know I was critical of the opening but
something that Fabiano has done last few
moves has already changed my mind I love
Hikaru nakamura's position and I feel
like Bobby doesn't have a plan yeah and
that could be because Fabiano carono
hasn't been expecting the Smith Mora
from Hikaru going into this opening from
the Sicilian sacrificing upon do you
think that has been a factor just the
shock factor of Hikaru going for this 2D
Force sacrificing the pawn and going for
the king Fabi probably just prepared
something completely different from that
yeah but they say fool me once shame on
you fool me twice shame on me right this
is the second time he's played it so for
Fabiano I know he didn't have a lot of
time during the breaks but he's come to
expect it and he's doing fine right the
evaluation bar suggests that black is
hanging right in there but it feels like
he's a little bit slow he's playing a
little bit timidly but maybe that's just
the way he needs to play in order to
give himself some winning chances he
does not want to trade he does not want
to find his King being checkmated so he
hasn't commit his King to either side
but I do like hikara's position for sure
this is all happening I mean Knight
takes C5 he took it he played F4 you can
even play G4 bro you can play Everything
four and everything five you can just do
this blindfolded I mean this is a very
very aggressive and big position for
white there might even be E5 and after
D5 sacking possibilities you may not
even be able to do it now but after E5
then D5 you could play F5 I mean this is
ridiculous there's so many ideas here
right now Fabi is in a lot of trouble
yeah even though the developer says that
Bobby is doing fine this is a nightmare
when you're in a must-win situation and
your opponent is coming in with the pawn
star and the attack you've got to deal
with that often in these formats the
hardest thing to do is to defend unless
of course you're Hikaru Nakamura Ah
that's true that's true yeah now I
wouldn't be surprised if Hikaru does
take a time out and Defender just put
his King closer to the corner they do
say when you Castle queenside on the
long side your king is slightly more
vulnerable so why not tuck it away to
safety but of course in the spirit of
the position would it be would be
James's ideas of uh pushing one of these
points I trust you more than I trust
myself here James just throw pawns
forward I'm just looking at it I'm like
okay I can count black support up but uh
of course that is less relevant than
White's activity all of White's pieces
of playing a role all of these black
pieces still asleep and of course the
black would be reluctant to Castle long
term because lines will open up he did
yeah so can't be winning he just Castle
I'm just about to play G4 and I'm a
pre-move G5 I'm gonna pre-movie I don't
care what you play I think I understand
David's playing bullet over here I do
think I understand what Fabiano is doing
he's castled and he's actually welcoming
the attack he doesn't want to get
checkmated but he's saying if you push
your pawns too far maybe I will have a
chance to strike back I like this move
from Karu he shut down black from
playing that same move that light Square
Bishop is stuck at home but that said
the evaluation bar took a little bit of
a dip here suggesting that Fabiano
should not be too unhappy to see it
played yeah he's going to block it up
Fabiano lines were opening in White's
favor so he locks down the position and
here comes the pawn storm I would be
terrified in Fabiano's shoes look at
that black king it's a Target Knights
and queens are a king's best friend but
there are no knights in Queens on that
half of the board they're never going to
be so you need counter play quickly you
need to distract Hikaru before it's too
late how you do that that's another
question can we get the engine I just
want to see what does the engine play
okay it was Bishop D7 I just wanted to
know what it was what do you do here
okay so you just play business because I
mean why is she coming at you this is a
very very strong attack for white it's
very scary and the the margin of error
is very very small here for black it
only one slight inaccuracy and you're
probably being mated right especially
after white can play Rook G1 I mean wait
for choice if F5 if so many moves here
it just seems so nice for white now
black and maybe I don't know B5 you
might just throw it out there literally
Even though three pieces can take it B5
might be a move just because you're
you're being aggressive P5 if you take
it with anything I play Rook B8 I don't
care what you take it with I'm gonna
play Rook B8 yeah well he's gonna do all
he can because Fabiano Carana is in a
must-win situation here B5 coming up is
it time for Hikaru to actually strike on
the other side G5 it looks like a pawn
sacrifice but can he start thinking
about these ideas to open up the H and
the g file immediately it's certainly on
his radar it's just about how much you
finesse it how much do you kind of
prepare this Advance here black I think
has to take you otherwise lines will
open up towards the black king the
question is if you continue pushing can
black lock things down this would be a
typical uh kind of sacrifice you want to
push your Pawn forward but at the very
end Black's King is the blockader itself
and there are still no fully open lines
towards it so I don't see any Checkmate
yet but so tempting it looks like this
attack is very promising the one
downside I would say for Hikaru is his
Queen is on the wrong side of the board
the Queen would love to be kind of over
here on the G3 Square for example on the
right side attacking and uh here it's
just badly placed I was going to say the
same exact thing as you David and it
also gives black a Tempo because right
now black is in danger of getting
checkmated but your idea to jokingly
against James's pre-move to bring that
Knight over to A5 I think that's
actually a viable option here because
then you bring your Rook to C8 you bring
your knight into C4 and something blacks
pieces are in the attack and you may
have to take if you're a Hikaru take
that Knight off of C4 if it gets there
and that removes one of your important
attacking pieces so I think that Fabiano
oh you have lost your absolute what is
he doing hikara doesn't need to win he
just needs to draw and he's driving from
his own King yeah he want to Armageddon
he just it's for Content that's for
Content he throwing for Content that's
what he say I'm throwing for Content yet
that's the run for Content 100 he's just
helping black 100 this open Line helps
black get to that white king yeah this
is not a human move you don't take on B7
this makes absolutely no sense the eval
bar hits it Queen B7 your king is on the
B file how do you pick up the pawn
that's playing the defense role for your
king Tonya said it's not human it's
everything else exactly she's right he
is half human right the other half we
don't know yet especially after this
move what the heck is that what is that
what is that Queen what's up everyone
shocked in the studio
yeah Queen B7 like flexing really hard
here yeah I played it yeah I played it
you've done something you don't
sacrifice a Pawn on move two only to
grab this Pawn like 15 moves later right
this just looks horrible it looks so
inconsistent you're playing for the
attack with white suddenly you switch to
get greedy it's level material but the
white king is a bigger Target than the
black thing now this makes no sense hey
man this is great you're going
historical right now I mean I just don't
understand it you're about to win The
chessable Masters right this is the
championship game you're playing with
the white pieces your upper game and you
pick up the poison Pawn it's great
content yeah
for you you know that's what you're
gonna do in his recap you know YouTube
yeah I did it for Content chat it's for
you guys but I think over the board he
just wasn't feeling his position because
he was thinking about pushing his Jeep
on he realized he couldn't do it just
yet he saw that Fabi would be able to
counter on the queen side but this is
just really a surprising move and I
think for Fabiano he's looking it's like
are you serious like I didn't even
calculate this possibility because it
looked impossible and Bobby can just
shift his Rook one square over like
bring your Rook over then go after the
queen and then bring your pieces to the
B file go for checkmate of your own he's
surprised to have his option but after
Rook V8 the White Queen is one square to
A6 I'm already looking at Rook B4 and
I'm just trying to bring my queen to B8
I have D5 four Pawn push to Fork your
pieces over here I don't know about this
just feels straightforward for black in
so many different ways you also have
night before in many ways and then Queen
A5 threatening stuff like almost Knight
A2 there like Knight B4 where does the
Queen even go first off where you even
put the queen queen A7 you gotta then I
can play Rook A8 what is this you've
lost your mind but White's winning yeah
you're kidding me Queen B6 okay then I
go Queen C8 maybe Queen something still
looks scary I mean this is very scary
Bishop d a we're K2 I mean this is
exactly what you want in every Cecilia
yeah this looks so scary this position
is on the board I love Robert's Rook
before multi-purpose move night before
also extremely attempting gaining time
against the White Queen opening up even
more lines if she takes the pawn but
maybe there's something even stronger
what is Fabi uh thinking about here the
good news is he has eight and a half
minutes and so many tempting options and
you could think about this bishop move
maybe even open up lines I want to get
my Bishop on this diagonal
all the moves are there F6 night before
choose one pick one they all are great I
think it's one gonna be one of these two
just so natural just attacking creating
threats on every turn and he needs he
needs that now for the momentum Fabi
well what did he just do how did he just
pick up that B7 Pawn we weren't even
looking at it it's more shocking than
that meat and one that he just walked
into you know that is a blind side you
missed something like that this is
voluntarily going into a position where
you're just gonna be fighting for your
life now I think it's because these half
men have zombie he came back from the
dead in the losers bracket now he's here
so you can't kill me because I've
already lost my life but this he might
have lost his mind because I can't get
over Queen takes B7 that's just not a
move that like 99.99 of GM's would play
and if he gets away with it I mean what
can't he get away with at this point
right yeah he either won't Armageddon
and he throwing for Content he want all
of that I mean this is just you you
handed the attack right back to black
here blackish for Choice here maybe he
wants to do this and give you know he
wants Bobby to think I mean because he
is thinking I mean he's down two minutes
here right but of course I mean this is
a this is a deadly attack it's very
scary you've been doing this in the
classical game ever right so I hate to
before I mean Rook B4 F6 all these moves
are are great moves here but Fabi is
losing a lot of time I do see him eating
up clock right now James you don't do
this in any game ever
go rapidly it doesn't matter I'm just
wondering is this coming from some sort
of an extra confidence that Hikaru is
feeling right now like any position he
can win no this is extraterrestrial in
fact this is what this is this is not
something's wrong something's definitely
he he is definitely uh going crazy here
for that move but I mean hey you know
Queen B7 he's like yo you're gonna have
to prove it and probably is definitely
in a position to prove it right now
there's so many moves that black can
make but he needs to make one of them
and he's going into a big think
everything looks good for black but Fabi
cannot afford to burn the clock if icaru
plays like this and wins it I mean I I
don't even know what to say it's just
it'll be insane yeah we have to ask him
hey bro what were you thinking I wasn't
oh okay all right cool I got it got it
appreciate it yeah if you gave this
position to Fabi at the beginning of the
day before any of these games started he
would have immediately found a way to
try and punish Hikaru but I think it's
the lack of confidence after Fabi he's
lost four of the last five games
he's actually trying to trap this White
Queen that White Queen struggling for
squares there's some big threats on the
board look there's look man look x-ray
vision of the Black Brook towards the
white king
how is white going to defend this looks
horrible big question but I'm just
wondering why is Fabi not looking more
excited about this opportunity that he
has you've got to be realizing with
black right now that this is your big
moment right you're not only eyeing the
white king but also the queen yeah look
at Fabi and do you think he he feels how
strong the position is
he knows he's playing a beast yeah he's
lost four of those last five games yes
it's the confidence issue right right
correct it's a confidence issue but he
does have a very good position I mean
there's some nasty threats here like
Rook A8 Queen D4 Rook A2 my guy then
Queen C2 and then bring the other Rook
over there and just like you know I mean
this is some nasty stuff here there are
some sick tactics that are about to
happen yeah for example let's say white
completely ignores the queen side I
don't think he should but let's say I
push upon what is the punishment how do
you either trap this queen or break
through to the white king rookie first
okay hit me I will quickly I gotta go
maybe Queen BC or any Rook a two James
Knight A2 Queen C2
Rook a get him off the board getting
more minimum bro
like I'm gone bro this is ridiculous you
know what I'm saying like come on bro
it's a Family Channel get that off the
screen David thank you let's get it off
the screen that's one of many threats
for Fabiana Carolina yeah no this
position is really difficult for a car
to play and now he's deep in the think
tank he was playing some of those moves
quickly he took on B7 took an A7 but
unfortunately when you grab pawns you
open files so it's not just a blunder
Bobby's not giving away pieces he was up
upon now he's down one but he's happy to
see those pawns gone there's a huge
attack brewing and for Hikaru he's
spending about two minutes on this turn
already I think he'll have to spend 20
more and he doesn't have that kind of
time just to survive he should have
spent time before he picked up the B7
Pawn now it is big trouble is it time
for Hikaru to sidestep with that Rook
get that Rook to defend the C file this
threat that James pointed out it looks
terrifying and once the road comes to
the a file it is going to be a reality
is Hikaru considering the move Rook C1
he must be he's thinking about something
he's calculating that's Hikaru
calculation phase three
and uh yeah he must be trying to work
out defense here maybe only now he's
realizing how dangerous it really is we
are talking about one of the best
defenders in the history of the game
though we've seen him do it so many
times every single game we complement
his calculation skills his defensive
skills sorry and uh can he do it again
that's the big question and he work his
magic and hold this one a golden
opportunity here for Fabiano caruana as
Hikaru voluntarily walks into a very
dangerous position on the queen side the
king Under Fire the Queen Under Fire and
we see Hikaru trying to work out a
defense here it's not going to be an
easy task but he's riding high on the
confidence what are we expecting from
Hikaru right now I don't know I have no
idea what does the engine say we're
gonna have to pull up the only way that
this is like what does it say because
this is this is insane to me yeah we
need those
Rook C1 Rook D2 and queen D4 immediately
a queen D4 immediately I definitely
consider because like you know that that
now I have to I need a temple with
rookiea but Rick C1 really yeah we'll
see one was the first move that came to
my mind once you came up with this
attack idea just bring that Rook to the
defense James so now we're K-8 is now uh
it's nothing huh radiate them whoa there
might be like a knight D5 or something
hitting the queen hitting this bishop
it's chaos but white is doing well yes
I can't play rookie so Rick C1 is a
nasty move huh that's annoying but David
you made this point earlier the white
Queen's almost trapped so black instead
of going forward can go back with the
Knight and where exactly is that Queen
going come on Robert good question great
question A6 is that the only square but
then you can even trade queens and play
D4 and win a piece come on Robert don't
do it to him Robert
this looks brutal this is what must be
forcing Hikaru to post right now maybe
he missed this a line because that is
the most natural defense if we go back
to the first position root C1 not only
is it the best move but it's also the
most natural the problem is if you lose
a piece
you stop calculating you look for
options and he finds the third best move
but it does give black a huge Advantage
after I think just before it disappeared
that the best move Queen to B7 the
computer said and lining up for
checkmate huge threats very logical
really very very loud
it's a free attack all right again right
we go on Armageddon normally you gotta
pay like like your salary to get an
attack this is 3.99 399 take that all
day and twice on Sundays baby wow Queen
B7 panel board right now Armageddon yes
or no 100 yeah 90 that's a conservative
estimate 100 Armageddon boys 100
about five minutes for Hikaru to defend
this look at the pressure on the white
king there's only one Defender really
for the white king that night and that
other black Rook is going to swing over
from f8 is doing nothing next to its
king swing it over sacrifice okay the
white Queen's now step back as a
Defender but there must be a
breakthrough yeah like what happens on
22 that's actually a very nice movie
that's a really annoying one maybe just
bring another piece like you said Arena
recover when in doubt move first think
later just bring another piece in Fabi
it looks like that is a logical
follow-up is there something more direct
maybe that's the question let's try to
get the photo work but he just takes the
bishop
there's nothing there nice defensive
move this last one from Hikaru just very
calm stepping the White Queen back she's
spent well wasted I should say so many
Tempe but uh at least she's holding
things together for now I like James's
suggestion he said D4 I love it so I
think this actually could be a kind of a
knockout blow really because what you
need is more pieces in the attack if you
are black uh James's point is under D4
you can't take with the Queen the queen
is needed to defend the B2 Pawn as black
already has the rook and queen teaming
up for checkmate if you take with the
bishop that light score Bishop that's
been blocked by its own pawns goes to C6
and I'm going Bishop E4 check oh that's
nasty hitting the Rook when I move whoa
how's he surviving this maybe you're not
surviving it I take your Bishop you take
back and uh if my king goes in the
corner we all know what's about to
happen there's going to be a devastating
discovered check on the board
I'm a Jedi for real sometimes I forget
that okay that was crazy D4 Bishop C6 on
the board
car crazy bro
Bishop E4 massive threat Rook hanging on
each one there's no way to fight against
both of them at the same time he's got
to either lose material or walk into a
mating attack
it's good right that's nasty and Hikaru
I'm just waiting for the head shake it
started there it's very even more uh in
the next few seconds when he realizes
the damage that's been done
double threat and you can you don't even
have to do anything as black because yes
you are down a couple pawns but you have
this vicious attack your next move can
be bring your Rook over to a d8 that
Rook next to your king to pin the bishop
to the Queen White has too much to look
out for and I feel like Fabi has many
different winning moves yeah this last
move was so instructive it pretty much
proves the point that we were talking
about earlier pawns mean nothing when
you're going for the attack opening up
lines throwing away pawns is actually
the best way forward and Fabi he gave
away two pawns the White Queen got
greedy taking them gave away another
pawn and yeah that's beautiful I mean he
started so well for you Carl I thought
this was just a clean sweep I mean
literally with the G5 I mean he had
everything everything in the position
and he gave it all the way to Queen B7
of course we're gonna hear about in the
recap here about why
um definitely why he went for it but
that man he gave him so much material he
just gave him so much just let's start
B3 immediately on the board but it looks
like there has to be a knockout blow
right now we were all looking I can see
us all I can feel us all like leaning in
just like his car is where is The
Knockout for black all of the black
pieces are working hard doing great
stuff and okay Bishop check the computer
confirms is a killer blow plus five for
black but maybe it's the follow-up
that's more difficult yeah correct
that's the follow-up so Bishop before
check where does he go
he can't afford to really recapture
before and allow the queen into the
attack because that would
that would solutely deadly if after
or you do trade the bishop the
queen jumps in with the check and then
you can just sacrifice on D4 let's say
King B2 hit that Bishop on D4 get that
Queen to C2 if that's not made nothing
is oh this is definitely me Tanya I can
confirm on the next move and uh yeah how
do you guard against this yes gross and
Bishop before on the board is King B2
there yes
so now do we I mean Knight A2 is
tempting bro I didn't mean to be played
but that Rook on H3 James that is a key
Defender that's why he played that wow
what a six yeah maybe it's something
else I'm looking in other directions is
it something to do with this being nice
C2 with Bishop A3 threats Knight C2 that
doesn't work either 94. whoa looks so
strong but there must be something what
is fabby's move here it's a winning
Advantage he's got three and a half
minutes it is okay huh what should be
some quiet man you know we're looking
for the direct Checkmate whoa he went
Bishop C2 that makes sense hitting this
road oh hitting B3 again yeah oh and now
and then just picks it up with the
bishop the root moves dang Knight takes
A2 as you say Tanya Knight takes and
then let's just take B3 is James
inside wow x-ray vision you will deliver
Checkmate in the next few moves there's
actually some really cool tactics here
we'll wait to see if it happens on the
board but while Hikaru Nakamura he will
have missed this last one it was not
obvious but nice spot by Fabian the
evaluation bar keeps going in Black's
directions c-o-e my guy calculation over
everything my mess is calculating the
human calculator giving these type of
positions he finds the Right Moves
Bishop C2 is a very very strong move so
many options and he made that move quite
quickly too as well to show you the
power of how strong Fabi really is in
calculation but Bishop C2 there's a lot
of other moves you probably could have
made or wanted to make bishop C2 was a
very nice one yeah that's a hard move to
play correct because every other move
sacrifices were available they look good
but this was the best move and wow what
a shot and you see Hikaru Nakamura he's
taking his time here because he
recognized the next move will be a
sacrifice and his King will not be able
to withstand the pressure he won the
throw for Content he wanted to go to
Armageddon he wanted to this just feels
so self-inflicted
when you're playing against the world
number seven when you're playing against
Fabiano you don't play Queen B7 that is
Ultimate disrespect and there's so much
at stake it's not just this tournament
but whoever wins this qualifies for the
playoffs at the end of the year I mean
yeah he's putting everything at risk
just because of the greed that one Pawn
he grabbed and this is the result it's
all backfired yeah Queen B7 wheelchair
is very instructive to to know Bishop
three whoa oh yeah the queen okay God I
got it it's the queen so they're still
an attack you can't take on D1 you can't
take on A2 you still have to spend one
more move moving that Queen Robert where
do you place it I've got Queen A6 and
then I'm gonna sacrifice my queen yeah
exactly that's what I'm going for him
and I don't even know what you're gonna
do queen A3 sacrificing my queen and
then when that night goes to D3 it's
made oh my way that's right that's right
I mean you guys got to show us the man
come on boys we gotta show this one
David
too much fun right here I'm guessing
something like this night night before
nice
it's winning
but he's gonna go for this queen
sacrifice on the board is about to
happen Fabi just making sure it works
this is amazing stuff we're gonna have
it Hikaru spots it Fabby spots it any
seconds
you know what you know we didn't even
see the Checkmate as long as Bobby does
as long as Bobby's here
why you ain't taking it because Knight
D3 King A4 Rooks B4 and then Rook 8 was
Checkmate anymore man take the queen but
now it's over hey man
just moves into the corner you're
threatening a queen sacrifice anyway
yeah and Hikaru just nothing to do it's
going to be Checkmate you can resign oh
you should have taken the queen
that was gone he should have taken I
mean he wanted to make onto him right
Queen B7 was a Content move he wanted to
make content and he didn't take the
queen
but this one is just bulldozed right you
just bring it Rook to eight you're going
to try to sacrifice your queen for
checkmate and I don't think there's
anything Fabiano has to worry about but
I like that he's spending his time he
just takes the Rook he knows he's
winning but he is doing the right thing
he has plenty of time remaining stock
and he wins the game yeah hecarly
resigns wow
oh wow it is over for now because this
means that we will have an Armageddon
what a game this was but for the most
part absolutely self-inflicted that move
Queen B7 Robert what on Earth happened
there it was even before that I actually
did not like the opening played by
Hikaru and you see them both on screen
we keep talking about momentum Fabiano
so he smiled he played a queen sacrifice
he wins the game he should be feeling
quite good got me absolutely feeling
great there I mean that's exhilarating
to be able to play a game like that and
like wow thank you for the gift in a way
you got gifted that game Queen B7 I mean
it felt like white had a very good
attack here everything was going in
White's favor I mean he just felt like
you couldn't make a wrong move until he
played Queen to B7 and Bobby jumped all
over that right so now we're gonna have
an Armageddon and now I don't know
especially after that momentum the way
that he won that game hey it could be
anybody's game and it really is right
now yeah this is just Madness all day
long at the Chesterville Grand Final
reset that game by Hikaru Flawless after
a very mysterious move by Hikaru Fabi
just took it away David you take it away
and show us the critical moment yeah
Carolina struck he won the game and he
won it in style this would have been one
of the most satisfying moves of Fabiano
caruana's career it happened now it was
a queen sacrifice in this position of
course it's a dangerous attack for black
we mentioned this all sorts of
sacrifices in the air to open up this
white king Hikaru tried to event by
sliding his Bishop back attacking the
queen but boom Queen to A3 check putting
the queen on an undefended Square trying
to lure the white king out unfortunately
Hikaru Nakamura didn't take this
retreating his King and resigning after
Bishop takes Rook he's going down on
material and uh the game ended here but
if he had taken this queen a beautiful
Checkmate first the Knight jumps forward
and discovered to check from the bishop
the king steps forward another check
about to drop Rook B4 the King has to
continue its journey and in the end it's
the other Rook that does the work that
delivers the Checkmate you can throw a
bishop in the way but what a picturesque
position the King has gone on a journey
but it has been punished for doing so
Carolina stylish beautiful win
amazing stuff there well chat you asked
for it and you get it you don't want to
close your eyes you don't want to miss a
thing because Armageddon is coming up
after that comeback win by Fabiano
caruana Queen B7 I'm still thinking
about it why Hikaru did it you guys
think about it as well but be right back
after this switch break because we've
got Armageddon
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
it's another day another way for me too
open up to you
[Music]
not always
always
wake up all day
[Music]
with nothing more to say
it's adjustable masters Grand Final
reset has gone down to the wild we've
got an Armageddon coming up it is going
to be a bidding Armageddon the players
will bid for time the player who bids
the lower time wins a bit gets to choose
the color usually black because black
gets result odds which means if it's a
draw black wins the match in case of a
win white white has to win on demand to
take the match the players will start
with 15 minutes who gets white and there
is no increment a big bidding Armageddon
coming up the countdown has started it
has come down to these final moments to
decide the champion of the chessable
Masters
David
what happened in that last game
self-destruct by Hikaru yeah he just
felt invincible and I can't blame him
Hikaru had won four of the previous five
games he was on a roll he was on a hot
streak but if you play but move like
that if you get greedy you will be
punished by someone world-class like
Fabiano all I'll say is an Armageddon
it's about choosing black black is one
five of the six games today
so it is going to be about trying to get
the black pieces for that you have to be
the player with the lower bit how low
can you go in this one yeah that's uh
you know I've seen
9 29 you know something like that
because of course we've seen in the past
below nine and like below eight is very
bad it's been very bad it's been Pro I
think there was one or two games out of
the armageddon's that were actually that
won somebody won I think was Magnus or
something 758 something crazy like that
definitely probably like 9 29 917
somewhere around there in that range is
probably the perfect the perfect amount
are we expecting both players to bid
around the nine minute margin I think if
you're a car you can actually bid higher
than he used to because five minute
caruana is not the best bullet player
that we have in this field so if you're
a car you anticipate that Fabiano might
bid 10 and a half minutes himself he
doesn't feel like he can go below that
against akaro so if Hikaru says I don't
really care what color I have as long as
500 doesn't have that much time he may
bid 10 plus minutes himself and say five
are you really gonna bid that low I'm
gonna flag you it's very smart
we will be revealing the beds we're
waiting for the beds to come in a big
Armageddon coming up this match has gone
down to the wire David we were not
expecting that at the start of the day
the chairs are empty yeah the chairs are
empty these players doing their last
minute preparations they know this last
game is going to be fast and furious but
I just want to say it's lived up to
expectations I didn't know what to
expect coming into today I thought maybe
Fabi would clinch it in the first match
but Hikaru starting on fire what a game
that was and yeah what a game what a
finish we're gonna have to this
tournament yeah and Fabi winning that
last game has the momentum once again
shifted in this match I just feel like
an arm again there's no such thing as
momentum who knows what to do and you
see Fabi probably locking in his bid
there uh there's just never too much fun
here at the adjustable Masters and
Fabiano he's playing a large role in
that he is down to his last game as his
opponent hikara Nakamura
Fabiano garana has been in the winners
bracket from day one he's been
Unstoppable until Hikaru showed up today
it has been an intense match so much
action we're waiting for the bids to
come in any second now how critical is
it James to get the black pieces in this
world it's definitely critical I mean
it's never it's like you get two for one
in a way you're gonna play one game but
I get to I can if I draw I win that
never happens in jazz if I win I win I
mean that's great right so of course you
always have that double thing where like
you have to take black in that situation
you get less time but of course
especially if you play your repertoire
especially uh Fabiano being well
prepared a car being well prepared you
know your preparation very well right if
I can get this draw cool if I can find
you know a sacrifice that leads to a
absolute Perpetual I mean all kind of
things can happen in these games and
white has to go all out to win the game
Hikaru needed just a draw in that last
game he lost that one he was riding so
high on confidence David and this is
exactly what Fabi needed to go into the
Armageddon to win that one not just the
scoreline but for his own mindset yeah
he needed it for the tournament but of
course a bonus that uh for his mindset
he'll feel boosted now and okay we do
see the players do they know the colors
I do wonder will Fabi be able to carry
that confidence into this Armageddon
will he get the black pieces looks very
relaxed for someone who's just lost a
championship game on his own the clocks
are ticking in just a few moments we
will reveal the bids by these two
players what's going on and then there
we have it nine minutes you call the
James that it will be in that Martin and
it is Hikaru Nakamura who wins the bid
Savvy bit nine minutes 58 seconds Hikaru
nine minutes six seconds Hikaru will
take the black pieces of course he will
I'm not surprised by these bid to think
of a smart bidding by both Fabiano he
ventured under 10 minutes himself he's
showing that he can play with a Time
deficit but that won't matter he gets
the 15 minutes he gets a six minute
leaving the clock the white pieces but a
must-win game yeah
six extra minutes on the clock for
Fabiano he has to win it's must win for
Fabi he has to do it or else in case of
a draw Hikaru takes the chessable
Masters we are expecting the first moves
any second now he starts with the
English opening switching it up yeah
switching it up he has played this
before already today however not this
last move getting ready to fianchetto
the white light Square Bishop yesterday
Hikaru started with 9 minutes 17 against
Magnus today 11 seconds lower will that
make a difference okay pawns off in the
center already still a known position
it's basically a C3 Sicilian James with
colors reversed absolutely I can
definitely fill that here and then we
have the he has the tempo he has the
extra Tempo here so it is slightly
different you still can play stuff like
I think Knight and I don't know if you
know this is Theory I just know from C3
Sicilian wise yeah that's a move and
also Knight E6 was a move two as well
but I like the choice from actually
Hikaru taking on C4 there taking on C4
is more of like hoping that they take on
d8 and you're going to a game that maybe
could easily you know you have drawing
chances there for black which is exactly
what a car wants we draw we win we win
we win so he wants both of those I'm
sure probably wants to keep the Queens
on as he does Queen A4 yeah solid
position for both sides I will say
White's Queen has done a lot of work a
lot of dancing around already so fabi's
lost a bit of time and Hikaru is happy
to develop his pieces it's a nice quick
position for Hikaru lots of easy natural
moves and I think that is a plus for
black uh Fabi maybe would have hoped to
have forced hikara to think a bit more
early in the game both sides of Castle
though and attention shifts to this
middle game and there's no symmetry
that's the good news for Fabiano caruana
he needs to win this game so he doesn't
just want a symmetrical structure a
boring end game where Hikaru can play
moves quickly so that's the good news
for Fabi the bad news is that hikaru's
plan is also relatively straightforward
in the early stages pieces are
harmonious I think both sides have their
chances but Bobby's gonna have to pick
up the pace yep he really does he needs
to force Hikaru to sit it and think but
so far hikar has played all of these
moves in about well just over 30 seconds
now the white Rooks will centralized the
black rocks will centralize and neither
side really has reason to be too unhappy
but uh remember draw odds a huge huge uh
kind of Plus in hikaru's court here I
don't see any problems look at all those
back pieces perfect centralization yeah
it's tough it's definitely tough here
black has everything he needs I mean
everything is all developed and you we
really want some like some chaos
sometimes but there's like nothing we're
just gonna have to play this position as
best as we can black is totally fine in
every position right now yeah and quiet
move from Fabi he'll want to slow down
the pace of the game but okay Hikaru
reacts instantly pinning the White
Knight bit of a mysterious move but
maybe trying to provoke white to start
stepping forward with some pawns maybe
just forcing Fabiana to tank to think
what uh what are our feelings about this
position who would you choose here and
why I'm not bothered by the provocation
like if you start pushing your Pawns in
front of your king for Fabi that at
least mixes the game up you can't just
keep the status quo I do think that
right now Hikaru is doing well on the
clock he's doing well on the board and
Bobby he's thinking a lot here you know
he is trying to be perfect and perfect
at times the enemy of the good he's a
fantastic player he needs to trust
himself make a move like Pawn to H3 just
kick that Bishop out of there and then
save some time for later in the game
yeah and already the time Advantage is
started at almost six minutes it's down
to just over four making up time super
quickly here
right next speed yeah he moving
instantly Rook D2 perfect now we're
gonna double the Rooks here
I mean it's just equal bro it's just
equal equal those are some of the worst
positions when you like need to win like
you have to beat akaru in this position
from here this is tough it's very tough
James but it is the Armageddon it
doesn't matter if you create something
on the board as long as you can keep as
many pieces on the board and keep that
time Advantage you need to get Hikaru to
fall low on the clock but guess what
hikar was taken just one minute so far
don't trade keep those pieces on the
board every exchange guides black closer
to that desired draw and nice move from
Fabi just plunking his Bishop in the
center it looks like a statue here
supported by opponent now he'll be happy
to drop back look at that start Square
Bishop sidelined on the edge of the
board yeah it could get in some trouble
over there and I also like the newly
opened light Square diagonal that pawn
of C6 it was protected by another Pawn
now the bishop on G2 is a happy piece so
after C5 kicking the bishop out of there
protecting your Pawn A7 by attacking
move your Bishop back to the corner that
Knight on F3 can hop into E5 or H4 into
F5 that night on E2 will likely jump
forward to the F4 Square all of a sudden
White's pieces are aiming in correct
directions and that Bishop on A3 it's a
wayward piece yeah really bad piece here
and Fabi even contemplating maybe
trading off his beautiful Bishop I'm
biased here okay he does step it back
whoa he does trade it off I thought he
would trade it off for a night suddenly
this feels very safe for black again and
uh black has a rock solid structure a
Black's problem piece that Bishop
swapped off what was that uh what was
that from Fabi simply I don't understand
like at all you don't want to trade
pieces when you need to win the game and
he just trades Bishops makes Black's
life easier that was extremely
surprising he could be tired it's been a
long day for him uh but Bishop B2 was
clearly wrong I was gonna say the same
thing I think he's probably maybe some
fatigue or like you know just lots of
emotions and it's the last game you know
psychology right I mean maybe yes it
just didn't make it real soon Bishop it
wouldn't make a lot of sense the bishop
was actually very bad on A3 you actually
keep it on a very long diagonal there
but I mean yeah
well yeah surprising stuff now black has
no problems at all yeah
if anything I would pick black here just
because of the queen side majority uh
you look at the three versus two on the
left side of the board and long term
actually black can make a passport there
it's harder for white to deal with
because the kings are further away this
is later in the end game
I don't see any reason for Fabiana to be
optimistic simply they're gaining on the
clock as well as a Fabi goes a tank and
then
another trade we often talk about how in
the Armageddon you need to keep more
pieces on to force your player into a
thing and the Knights facing off what
are we expecting White Knight to jump to
the center of the board or accept the
trade got to be careful if you accept
the trade suddenly things might open up
in Black's favor there's tension between
the two Bishops but if you imagine the
two Bishops being plucked off the board
if they ever get traded White's King
will start to feel slightly
uncomfortable so Fabi you need to be
careful if he does simplify this
position I don't like the pace for Fabi
he had a six minute lead on the clock
now would sound under three you can just
see Hikaru playing with confidence his
moves are very good and he's not being
challenged some of those trades that
Fabi made we already criticized them a
bit but I feel like he's just making a
car's task easier I would just maybe
move my knight to H5 and hope that a car
blunters Checkmate in one for a second
time uh no it sounds like a joke but
like you just gotta create some threats
and try to keep pieces on the board and
then try to make a car think
yeah and okay he brings a knight to the
edge of the board but maybe not the
night that you were expecting Robert
there is a small threat of the White
Knight jumping into F5 that dream square
that we talk about but it can be easily
rub off here it can be easily covered
that post the knights all look on like
they're on weird squares I've got to say
but uh the Black Knights do have an
element of control so how do we think uh
yeah Hikaru is going to neutralize any
activity for white
yeah it's a bit scary with Bobby's night
jumping onto that F5 square and
threatening a meeting one and let's not
forget there is a potential pin on the
long diagonal the Knight on e4 with the
bishop on B7 things can get a bit tricky
is this a moment that Hikaru needs to
slow down and be precise while he just
stops it nicely done bit weakening but
it makes sense stopping the white
knights from jumping forward James your
instincts don't like that one and
immediately I was looking at obviously
Knight H5 Knight F5 or reversing Knight
of five nights five they both don't work
but you do have to know that the idea is
there I just don't have enough pieces so
I in fact if I can't do anything about
it it's Justified it makes sense I can't
go Knight at five I can't go Knight H5
sacking doesn't make any sense I mean I
don't The Rook is not activated enough I
only have the queen there the bishop is
not activated enough yeah I mean but
weirdly as crazy as that is it just
works and look at that and the engine is
like you have lost your absolute that's
GG what is this is this a blunder from
Fabiano he's abandoned his first rank
the black Rook can come down now drop
down with a check hitting the white king
maybe there's something even stronger
the engine confirms it and black has a
knockout blow wow giving up his night
whatever it was Hikaru doesn't find it
what was it maybe I don't know a
sacrifice on G3 so many ideas in the air
oh it was Nike three yeah it was my
goodness we have to show this on the
board there was a winning blow for
hikara difficult and understandable that
he didn't try to do this
King moves and I guess the killer blow
is The Rook coming down trap Checkmate
this King not obviously Rook F2
Rook F2 you're right James very
difficult difficult to calculate I man
it's crazy she takes bishop and there's
some tricks here I don't know it goes on
but this would have been very strong for
black catching up with the game position
the black king has now parked itself in
the corner I like this evading any
potential checks and watch out for this
to happen again the black Rook could get
active later in the game on the first
rank hikara is just playing Safety First
chess though this is good practical play
he's not spending three four minutes
calculating that move because if it
didn't win he would have burned all his
remaining time but uh now the game goes
on there's also no increment yikes bro
that's not a nice looking move at all
that is not a square where your Rook
belongs yeah look at hikara's face he's
like what is that this is honestly it
looks like Fabiano hasn't been in this
game from the start I mean he played
this English all of a sudden he had some
chance to keep peace in the board he
didn't that goes against the spirit of
the position but look F3 and Hikaru is
mad at himself elf because he just
allowed the pawn to push forward and
that Black Knight has to drop back and
suddenly white can expand whoa not just
expand Robert maybe sacrifice as well
suddenly this Knight is kicked away as
you mentioned if it steps back to the
wrong Square I'm not sure which
direction you should go but suddenly
there's ideas such as Knight takes porn
boom breaking open towards the black
king this was so sneaky from Fabiano and
suddenly the White Queen Springs forward
everything is falling for black and the
King drops back you take this Pawn
you've got three pawns multiple threats
in the air maybe winning for white even
and Fabian is getting excited how does
Nakamura react to this okay I'm hitting
himself reacting on the camera yeah he
definitely swinging on himself in fact a
few times they're hitting his head
saying well you know as he says on the
show right is it's a very bad move
they just missed it but also he's moving
quickly and there's no increment so you
do have to remember that part too that
they're just moving quick fast there's
no increment because if you think and
you need time to think here you will not
get any time back for per move Knight D6
and here we go I mean Knight takes G6 is
begging to be played right now Fabiano
sees it he's figured out which Knight to
work with and for the 65 000 plus you're
watching on Twitch and YouTube Welcome
to the Armageddon here in the Grand
Final reset of the chessful Masters
Fabiano caruana he had a terrible
position but now he can sacrifice his
Knight right in front of the black king
and Hikaru he is upset with himself I
can't believe he walked into this one
move idea he was playing too quickly and
there it is he goes for it Knight G6 the
tables have done one more time in this
match it is an insane day of Chess gives
a check but how do you continue continue
the attack David I'm not sure actually I
would have taken with the other night
okay he steps forward with his pawns
there's gonna be an avalanche all these
pawns are going to be thrown forward
towards that black king soon the black
king is naked it has no clothes on no
Defenders around it but still those two
black knights have some chances of
sneaking back kicking away that White
Queen which lacks squares so anything
could happen here I would choose white
if I was given this amount of time on
the clock Hikaru with five minutes
difficult to defend yeah
increment as well why
you advance that people and further down
the board hitting more pieces and then
bringing the Knight into the attack
Hikaru offers a trade you never trade
Queens in this position falls back is he
going to push the Heap on now is that
the idea gotta push something or maybe
sidestep with the white Rook the defile
has been abandoned now White's Rook can
activate looks very natural to me maybe
there's something even stronger yeah
look at E5 because it looks like black
has the square under control but you
actually can give up your Pawn on that
square because the queen is in forking
distance of the second Pawn it's very
complicated stuff here but if black
takes can white not just take back and
after Queen takes E5 maybe F4 here oh
and Knight F3 doesn't work double attack
oh my God you win material you win a
piece okay he plays a choir to move
maybe equally strong the evaluation bar
does drop though I think your move
Robert was the way to go and this is the
current position blacks Knights are
holding things together for now but it
is hanging by a threat for Hikaru
Nakamura
look at that I mean when the last time
you've seen Four Past pawns right in
fact five on the whole board like the
sea Pawn passed the e-pawn passed the F1
guess what passed GH pass all of these
pawns are past spawns so if we trade
Queens maybe at some point well he could
also sacrifice and get some of it back
if he needs to but definitely
complicated position and no increment
switching Focus probably with this queen
slide and black defending everything
Hikaru he's the best defender or one of
the best defenders in chess history can
he hold this one oh Fabi I love his
chances I love his position but one slip
and black will get the Queens off and
that could be an end to his hopes yeah
and it's going to be so hard to also
keep the pressure on the clock in this
extremely complicated position it is a
clutch moment but the very best in the
world do bring out their very best in
these moments when the pressure is high
expectation is high Fabi cannot
sacrifice on D6 anymore how does he
continue the pressure how does he
continue the attack here he needs to use
the clock as a weapon as James always
says it's the 17th piece you have to use
your extra time if you're fobby the
position is very complicated so he's
trying to find the right move he sees
his Queen is attacking a pawn over there
should not be taken because Rook D4 not
a move I was expecting and the engine
hates it oh they say that's game over
what yeah
Nakamura is just trying to play on the
clock he's worrying about the 17th piece
he's focused on blitzing this game down
not losing on time but it was loose for
white maybe there was a way to punish
that white Rook hanging in the air like
that on a Central Square not guarded by
pawns Fabi I think he needs to back up
with his Rook just Retreat it that White
Queen is stuck right now where she is
defending purely yeah the problem here
is uh I I understand you know why you
know he messed up with rookie four but I
mean like you could he couldn't find the
moon anyway whatever that was he moved
it back but the problem is I can't move
right like I can't push the pawns they
all are going to be hanging I can't play
the Jeep on because the Knight hangs I
can't move the Knight like everything is
range my pieces are not coordinated
right and I literally can't move any of
the pawns without something dropping so
I mean you might even have to consider
something like Knight F5 just to get rid
of the Knight but it's a very difficult
position for probably maybe bishop H1 or
F1 I could just I can't move anything
right a very tough position the thing is
black can't move too much either so
that's why playing on the clock but it
might have been so effective you just
kind of Shuffle Shuffle play on your
opponent's time only try and strike when
they're low when they have no time to
react now there's only 20 seconds in it
this one could go either way and Hikaru
he's pushing he's going for gold with
the c Pawn
is it just going to promote it's a great
decision by a car why not you have a
passport push and get his Rook behind it
while kicking the White Queen out of the
way white does not have an attack black
has enough pieces in front of the king I
love this decision by icaro he also is
about to be ahead in the clock there is
no increment and Fabiano has to win and
hikaru's position is better wow after
that blunder what a resilient player he
is to now have the advantage great
recovery skills and super speed from
Hikaru Nakamura look at this the night
coming forward it's all momentum black
both on the board and the clock Fabi
reacting whoa he jumps in with his Queen
not a great Square iffy Karu really
wants he can force the Queens off the
board there we go does it immediately he
finds it there is no square for the
queen they have to be traded off and he
jumps in with the Knight but it's too
late the C3 Pawn is super strong two
squares away from queening the other
Knight jumps into the attack the edit is
going to jump further Hit The Rook the C
Pawn advances Fabi in big trouble here
and the headboard's back oh yeah he
might have rookie three work rookie 3c2
Rook C3 Rook CA 97 right so we do have
uh I think we can chase this Pawn down
yep some tricks Rook C1 now then oh he
didn't even care about it what the heck
is it 33 62 what does he have in mind
right he just knows his position is on
the verge of losing so far he's looking
at the clock he's looking the board he
knows that hope is about to leave and so
he's just trying to do something but
Knight D3 looks like just a knockout
yeah he's gonna play it and he's pausing
just for a moment it's on the board and
he stops the C2 Pawn now the other
Knight jumps in at Pawn at the corner of
the boat will be picked up it's not just
upon that night will assist the sea Pawn
down you've got to move you've got to
slide your rook in front of the sea Pawn
right now and try and capture it yeah
but everything's falling everything's
collapsing maybe you pick up that strong
black pass Pawn but your whole Center
collapses White's pawns will start
falling like flies and Fabio only has a
few minutes to deal with the wreckage of
his position yeah I think you're right
Tanya just you have to gamble at this
point go for that black porn but it's
not gonna work anyway he Retreats his
Knight covering some squares now just
start getting greedy start picking them
off one by one okay black doesn't go for
those white pawns yet he improves this
Rook first of all he wants to make a new
Queen hikaranakamura
yeah the only way he loses this game is
if those white pawns start rolling up
the board so he's like let me attack
your knight that night he's trying to
stop that past Pawn so the Knight is
going to a defensive stance here and he
may try to bring his Rook down for a
trade if he can get those Rooks off the
board on the second rank then he is
going to win quite easily you can see
him thinking what how do I end this game
here he does not want to allow fobby's
pawns to make any progress yeah Fabi
shook his head he's been stoic the whole
day but uh that we did see a small head
shake maybe that black Black Knight is
going to move just to unblock there we
go gaining time against the white Rook
the black Rook now ready to jump in over
the next couple of turns maybe he can
even jump in uh yeah Rook D2 is strong
there it is yeah and then Bishop E4 nice
pin and you win that one Bishop is going
to be overwhelmed oh 93 that's a piece
what is going on luck is winning a piece
that's it you double up on it and that's
it it's game over yeah didn't even need
to win the game but he's getting a dub
here hey he blundered in this one and
he's still winning
yeah you see it on the faces now Hikaru
smiling Fabi devastated nothing to do
your white Bishop Falls and the white
pawns unable to Sprint forward fast
enough
the whole position collapses this is
very painful for white yeah painful
harsh stuff the small margins at this
level do eventually pay off and Hikaru
is just too quick on the day Abby
panicked at the wrong moment played so
well but uh okay one more move the
bishop Falls how is he going to fight on
okay another night check and this black
pawn is gonna completely paralyze the
white pieces and I think he's had enough
now is it he's reaching out and there it
is
resigns what an Armageddon game by
Hikaru he takes the chessable Masters
and with that also punches his ticket to
the finals of the Champions chest star
what a performance by him all day long
today yeah it's been up and down up and
down but in the end we had seven wins
out of eight for black geez that is
crazy was it six out of seven it was a
lot of wins for black but uh yeah he
deserved it he was too strong in the
Armageddon yeah and we saw Fabiano there
it's such a difficult moment and he
feels so dejected so close and yet so
far you start the day he's been in the
winners bracket but it just looks like
Hikaru was the one who was willing to
take the risks and it paid off yeah you
enter a day like this when you have odds
right five little carwana came through
the winners bracket he could lose the
first match and still keep going but
today was not his day if it had been two
days ago we had the same exact format
maybe five minutes taking them down but
hakara was way too strong today he
earned himself this title
yeah what a big moment this is as Hikaru
Nakamura he beat Magnus Carlton on his
way of winning to winning the first his
first title at the Champions chess store
and of course wins thirty thousand
dollars and punches his ticket to the
Grand Final also congratulations to
runners-up Fabiano caruana who did have
really big moments in the tournament he
played a fantastic event David yeah
fabi's on a hot streak in general in
Rapid chest and he really showed it in
this tournament when you come up against
the hikar Nakamura though it can be
difficult and it was here that Hikaru
clinched the win we already talked about
the game turning it's all about this
Black Sea porn right now but Hikaru
realized he could eradicate all
potential White counter play in one
swoop he brought his Queen across the
whole way trading off these queens and
as we saw in the end game this Pawn was
too strong if we fast forward a few
moves the killer blow was in this
position the Black Knight is attacked
most mere mortals would move it out the
way and the game would continue but
Hikaru saw this was the moment to strike
he brought his Rook down pinning and
winning Bishop takes poor now making
full use of the fact that this white
Bishop is paralyzed and uh one final
move to put the nail in this night move
overwhelms the white Bishop great game
great finish by Hikaru Nakamura and is
deserved tournament Victor
very well said David because it started
as a day that Hikaru needed to win two
matches to win the championship and this
is how he did it he won the first set
and then in the Grand Final reset
winning the first game the second game
Fabiano caruana on a win on demand
managed to strike back but then the
Armageddon was just all Hikaru and he
managed to dominate that one and we've
got the champion of the adjustable
masters with us Hikaru congratulations
thank you so much appreciate it hey guys
that was some high-level chess it was
such an intense match I have to ask you
what are you most pleased about and
there's a lot that you have to choose
from
um I mean the match started off terribly
I mean in this first game I should have
lost I think when I won this first game
that sort of turned the tide around
um and I mean the the rest match was
also very very choppy or actually sorry
I forgot I lost the second game so no it
was the third game that that winning
release Force settled everything down
um yeah I mean it was two very very
difficult matches I seemed like like
this whole event actually it seemed the
black the black pieces seem to be
preferable for the most part so um it
was just difficult but I found a way to
get it done when it mattered yeah I
think you have the stats with seven out
of eight wins for the black pieces uh
today Hikaru and but that second game
from the Grand Final reset the moment
you took that pawn on B7 what happened
there because we were quite shocked with
that decision
well I mean there's a simple answer I'm
not stockfish so I can I confuse the
move order that's the simple answer
um I mean basically what happened in
that game is that there was a very
similar position I looked at a couple of
days ago
um where if black has castled E5 V5
Bishop D3 Bishop B1 is very good for
white but because Fabian hadn't Castle I
shouldn't have played this whole E5 move
and everything else that followed and um
I mean when I played Queen B7 it's
already hard to play I mean maybe a
computer could just say you're down upon
it doesn't matter but at least for us
humans it's not possible play like that
so that's just how it goes
well hakara huge congratulations winning
two matches in a row today on demand no
easy feed but how did you do it because
yesterday you also said after beating
Madness you had to find your motivation
where did it come from
well I mean it's you just show up and
you play and I mean I think the most
important thing is that I mean I'm
trying to think of a politically correct
way to put this but but Fabiano and I
both once again we're not playing our
best chess you know you can say whatever
the reasons might be for that but we
both were a little bit off again today
and and so I think that when Fabiana
wasn't completely there that gave me
some confidence to um to basically like
feel my way through it through the match
um but but I do think for sure like
Fabiano I mean he did not play his best
I definitely did not play my best maybe
at the end I kind of started playing
well but I mean both of us just like our
first match it wasn't wasn't the best
quality and I think you know when you
play against a great Champion like
Fabiano
um when he brings his A-game you're very
scared I mean he's one of the best best
ever and um I think that gave me some
confidence
congratulations man you made it that was
a very very uh uh through the commanding
performer especially at the end there
too as well so good stuff man and when's
your next turn and what do you have
coming up next besides obviously uh we
have the content you got to stream and
we gotta we gotta do the Recaps but
what's the next tournament
um I mean I don't I don't have any
tournaments planned I'll play a
tournament in in like may I guess I have
this event in the Norway chest but it's
uh yeah I mean it's it's all what it is
you know I do want to add something
though um which is like for people who
are wondering about this uh this whole
Smith more I played I'm obviously gonna
do a recap later but I came up with the
idea to play it against Magnus I was
hoping to get like one or two million
view video I you know make a great title
like you know I beat the world champion
with the smithmore Gambit but Magus
didn't do it so I ended up using it
today and I mean I'm I'm very pleased
because I won the first game I had a
much better position again I'm not 3 500
so I couldn't prove the advantage in the
second game in the Smith Mora but
um it was uh I'm very pleased that I
showed that you know you can play
gambits you don't have to play proper
chess and you can still have a great
time and win games it's nice and Hikaru
congratulations yesterday I asked about
your choice of t-shirt and I've got to
ask again today any message behind that
one
no I mean there's no message behind it
but I thought it's like people were
making the joke uh I saw some joke that
it's like it was like Hikaru literally
doesn't care an opera against like I'd
rather be playing poke it's like Magnus
I'd rather be playing poke or Carlson so
I figured I'd try to just just be like
Magnus and like showcase it that I like
poker just like just like him we have
similar tastes
wow hey guys it's been such an awesome
tournament the chassis Masters have you
overall had fun playing here
I mean I've had fun the last two days I
mean the first couple days were very
very choppy I mean don't forget in the
very first match against photos save I
mean I I was down two to one and then in
the fourth game I won this huge game um
but the black pieces of tied match I
mean the Wesley match also could have
gone either way I mean all the matches
were very very uh stressful so Blaster
days were fun but everything prior to
that was just a slog and uh I'm just
glad that I made it through and even
though I don't think I played my best
chess uh I was I was I guess best one
when it really mattered and hikara you
made your way through the losers bracket
so I kind of want your honest take what
would you have given your chances of
winning the event heading into your
match against Magnus and then once again
heading into the match today against
Fabiano
well I mean I not to sort of belabor the
obvious point but it seems to me that a
lot of these matches came down to who
got the black pieces in the Armageddon
game
um I'm not sure if white even won a
single Armageddon game maybe maybe
Fabian or somebody did but I feel like
black one like 90 or one or drew the
games to advance in the Armageddon so I
think really this tournament it comes
down to who's best at I guess like uh
best at Game Theory and and guessing
what the lowest time is going to be that
you need so I do think that um that that
maybe is a slight slight thing that I
disliked it seems like black one like
every single Armageddon game
I was so much fun to watch on your car
sorry sorry Robert asked a question I'm
losing my mind you asked what percent I
would give right yeah
I would say I gave myself maybe like a
20 chance
um of coming back but you know I think
that the thing is like for Fabian it was
all about the first match once the first
match goes away I think the momentum was
definitely my favorite
yeah some amazing tests about you there
and we want to bring up the nft trophy
that you have one with this Championship
uh congratulations and of course the big
ticket to the finals of the Champions
chest star what does that mean for you
um well okay the trophy is nice but I'm
conf I'm confused I get seated I mean I
was reading the regulations the other
day and I actually didn't understand I
thought there was a gauntlet tournament
to get into the finals so I I actually
I'm a little bit surprised by that I I
didn't I was trying to read it I didn't
understand anything
um but if I'm in the finals it's
obviously great that means that I can I
can chill get back to my my real job
all right well we look forward to that
and congratulations Hikaru what a
fantastic performance and thank you for
entertaining us so with the orchard
thank you so much again
is the champion of the chessable Masters
what a performance he went down to the
losers bracket beat the world champion
comes back up and takes it away in two
sets David amazing stuff he's a beast
he's just fantastic at speed chess and
he showed it today
um yeah deserved winner as I mentioned
really impressive stuff
James your thought on that amazing
performance I mean he had a few stumbles
but I mean again when it had like when
it gets warmed up when Hikaru gets
warmed up it's a problem you know what I
mean so he stumbled a little bit in
there right as every player would but
he's very good at you know when I
Stumble you get back up and I'm warmed
up and he just crossed the rest of it
and came through on top like he does in
many events I mean it's ridiculous he's
just an absolute monster
and to do that again it's a player like
Fabiano caruano Fabi is one of the best
in the world he's had such a great
performance in this tournament few would
have predicted the day to end like this
Robert it really went down to the wire
you heard it from hikara himself he did
not predict the day to end like this he
gave himself 20 chances he said he was
in trouble during that first game when
he was down a pawn with seemingly very
little compensation but he won when he
had to he showed that he is an absolute
Force he took down magnets yesterday he
took him Fabiano twice today very few
people could say they've done that
what an amazing day of Chess we've had
and David what do you think how is this
for Hikaru moving forward on the door
it's going to be a huge confidence boost
as Robert mentioned beating Magnus not
many people can achieve that beating
Fabby as well in two consecutive matches
also impressive he now will be setting
his sights on that Grand Final trying to
win the whole tour itself he's like I'm
not a professional player but he's just
conquering everything I'm gonna win this
I'm gonna win that I'm winning this I'm
winning now I'm a World Champ I'm an
official World Champ and then maybe he'd
be a world champion classical one day
too of course who knows he's half man
half chessful master champion we he
answered that question for us we don't
have to wonder anymore
so much at stake at every event of the
Champions Chester it's been a fantastic
chessable Masters we've seen Drama
action on the board off the board
brilliances Mouse slips blunders and
painting ones everything that we are
here for it is intense transaction and
it ends with these door standings which
is so critical to make it to the finals
we see that Hikaru Nakamura with that
win at full position with 250 points and
Magnus Carson also looking good with 225
points well these two players have
punched their tickets into the finals of
the Champions Chester and these are the
prizes as we can see uh Hikaru Nakamura
with 50 000 earnings so far and still a
big tour left so many events Robert so
many events remaining tour points also
dictate who wins the end of season the
monetary prizes but Fabiano caruana he
slides into third he started in division
two at the air things Masters he wins uh
second place here in division one and I
want to give a quick shout out to Alexi
serrana he was in the third division but
he keeps fighting he started in division
one the air things Masters there he is
in sixth in the money rankings after
playing in division three here in
chessful Masters that's a lot of dollars
that's a lot of dollars on the screen
make you want to level up the game you
know what I mean Dave are you gonna hop
in there big dog that's a lot of dollars
up there man I might have to I've got to
say I love this new tour format it's
really opened up the Chess World
supporting players at all levels
amateurs pros and uh yeah hopefully
inspiring the Next Generation to come
through and play in the event 100. of
course we've got the next event also
coming up we already
found players and four others will join
in from the planes the champion makes it
through Fabiano caruana runners-up of
the event and a Magnus Carlton these top
three places from division one have
qualified to the next event and not the
back after winning that division two
will be in division one of the next
event which starts from May 22nd that's
a big moment for Abdullah he earned it
he won all of his matches including
beating Maxine Buster legrov twice he
beat a niche Geary in the very first
round of the competition it was never
easy for him but the Uzbek teenager he
led his country to Olympiad gold he's
the former World rapid Champion he's a
teenager and now he is your chessel
Masters division two winner that's crazy
that's crazy I mean he's a teenager and
he's a World Champ right so now that's
crazy wait to five ten years from now
where would this kid be I mean it amazes
me how strong he is right watch a lot of
his games I recommend you guys do the
same at home I mean I do satoroph is an
absolute beast and we're about to see
him do some more work I'm gonna make a
bold prediction guys I think abdusator
if he's gonna win division one one of
these events in the rest of the season
wow the youngest ever won rapid Champion
another back I'd do such Rob oh David
that with a hot dick on that speaking of
all the Championships we've got a big
event coming up guys around one in two
days
I'm really excited about that yeah
taking on ding it's going to be a fun
time for the Chess World it certainly
will be you have the number two player
in the world taking on the number three
player in the world no matter when that
happens everyone will be eating their
popcorn watching it just waiting for the
action so I'm also excited we'll be
covering some of it ourselves so it's
going to be a fun month it actually
starts at five eastern time five five
excuse me five a.m eastern time so of
course if you're gonna be up wow you
know I may not be up but I might be up
for those but of course it's gonna be
very exciting right I gotta watch every
single game check everything right take
off work whatever you got to do but this
is going to be exciting right you got
that point then going at it yeah we're
so spoiled just we've had so much chess
a feast of Chess and there's more to
come but first we need to take a break
and uh yeah I'm gonna be tuning into
that match I'm gonna be watching you
guys commenting
and is it really hard right now to pick
a favorite in that module number two
well number three such a close one I'll
say never oh you are picking a favorite
yeah I pick a favorite netball got the
experience I mean if you have experience
right he's done one World Champ already
and of course if you have nerves I'm
sure you guys a lot of nerves World
Championship everybody watching you this
is his second one so he's used to a ding
he's definitely gonna have to you know
get that Psych in that mental part right
for this first one for him Robert how
much of an advantage is that that nepo
has played one match before I've heard
from all of the previous Challengers you
cannot replicate that experience no
matter how much you prepare no matter
how much you train you are not in that
Arena facing off for a world
championship title so nepo has that
experience but I think dingley Ren he's
ready you spoke to him the other day he
seems like he is very happy to start
playing hang on would be it is every
chess player's dream to be where Ian
Nepal and ding are David we'll have a
new world champion by the end of the
month what does that mean for the Chess
World well we've got to look on the
bright side it is a bit sad it's the end
of an era it's the end of magnus's
magnus's reign as uh classical Champion
but these two players they are
phenomenal themselves and I'm sure
they'll be great Representatives whoever
wins uh of the Chess World so I just
think it's great for chess and long may
continue yeah it's all about Chess
without Magnus but I mean a Magnus may
come back you never know that'd be crazy
and have two living world Champs going
at a young world champion no I'm world
champion I like to go on that that's
going to be great for for TV and for all
chess yeah Magnus Carlson is the
strongest chess player in the world
nobody's denying that including Jana
pumps and ding the run that does not
mean we're not gonna have a feast
watching that matchup you don't get to
see players go 14 games in a row
throughout a month this is going to be
super exciting stuff and dingley ren
Jana pumps you one of them will be the
first first world champion not named
Magnus Carlson in a decade I have a vile
theory that we might see Magnus fight
once again for the world championship
match yes or no David uh no comment
maybe James what do you think I think
yeah at some point you know especially
when he mentioned he was like yeah I
mean if it's a format change which of
course I mean fide may actually do a
format change at some point if he likes
it Magnus will come back that's gonna be
wild do you think we're gonna see that
Robert I think we will see Magnus
Carlson play in the world rapid and the
world Blitz championships I'm taking the
easy way out of this one he will play in
World Championship sanctioned events wow
Magnus Carlson well as of today is the
classical world champion rapid and Blitz
World Champion at the end of the month
it is going to be a new classical world
champion either Jana Pony or dingler and
guys I have to say this is getting a bit
emotional it's been an amazing five days
and I'm feeling a bit sad right now
don't bring it in guys oh my God
all right guys let me went home all you
guys that watch too chat love everybody
to watch and tune in it was great it was
awesome yeah what account
the energy going and of course a huge
shout out to the team behind the scenes
for making it all possible and
congratulations
it's a goodbye from us we will be back
next tournament
what does the T-shirt say there I
knocked out a pro daddy's been sort of
struggling with the shoulder injury
[Music]
got in time trouble and once that
happened he stumbled that's a
well-earned victory for car Nakamura
he is just relieved with the position
this is the best position he's had all
game now he's so good at thinking on the
Fly he's immediately sensing okay I've
got to punish you
[Music]
thank you
oh
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
box
[Music]
thank you